GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
TODAY IS TUESDAY APRIL
NINETEENTH WE DO NOT YET HAVE A
QUORUM BUT WE'RE GOING TO START
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE WE HAVE A
POTENTIALLY VERY LONG HEARING
TODAY. I'M GONNA TAKE ONE ITEM
OUT OF ORDER AND WE'RE GONNA-START WITH ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY SIX MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN. AND THIS IS BECAUSE
WE HAVE A- DIFFICULT PROPONENT
WHICH I'M SORRY A FORMER
COLLEAGUE. AS A WITNESS WHO HAS
A VERY DIFFICULT SCHEDULE AND I
WANTED TO ACCOMMODATE HIM SO
WE'RE GONNA START WITH AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY SIX AND THEN WILL.
GO IN ORDER THIS MAIENSCHEIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
I THANK YOU FOR THE COURTESY AS
WELL FOR OUR FORMER COLLEAGUE
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AND
SPECIFIED COUNTY COUNCILS AND
CITY ATTORNEYS TO BRING ACTIONS
UNDER THE UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW
TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS.
CURRENT LAW ALSO ALLOWS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS TO ISSUE PRE
LITIGATION SUBPOENAS FOR
DOCUMENTS OR TESTIMONY TO
CONFIDENTIALLY INVESTIGATE
WHETHER A VIOLATION HAS OCCURRED
. DESPITE HAVING THE EXACT SAME
AUTHORITY TO FILE YOU SEE L.
ACTIONS CITY ATTORNEYS AND
COUNTY COUNCILS DO NOT HAVE THE
SAME ABILITY TO FILE PRE
LITIGATION SUBPONAS. AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY SIX WILL ADDRESS
THIS ANOMALY BY PROVIDING THESE
COUNTY COUNCILS AND CITY
ATTORNEYS THE SAME INVESTIGATIVE
TOOLS AS THEIR DISTRICT ATTORNEY
COUNTERPARTS FOR UCL ACTIONS.
ALLOWING THEM TO SUBPOENA
RECORDS AND OTHER NON PUBLIC
INFORMATION BEFORE FILING A
LAWSUIT. THE BILL WILL BOLSTER
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND HELP TO
EXPEDITE UCL INVESTIGATIONS AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY SIX ALSO
PROVIDES ADEQUATE PROTECTION TO
SUBPOENAED ENTITIES. INCLUDING
CONFIDENTIALITY PROTECTIONS AND
THE ABILITY TO CHALLENGE THE
SUBPOENA IN COURT. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY ON THE PHONE IS MY
FRIEND AND ALL OF OUR FORMER
COLLEAGUE. AT THE CITY ATTORNEY
FOR THE CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
DAVID CHIU. WHO I BELIEVE WHO I
KNOW WILL TESTIFY NEXT AND THEN
IN PERSON I ALSO HAVE MARK AND
CORN WHO'S THE SENIOR CHIEF
DEPUTY CITY ATTORNEY FOR THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO. GREAT THANK
YOU SO I DO HAVE MISTER TO
LISTED ON THE TELEPHONE. WHO
ABANDONED THIS COMMITTEE. FEW
MONTHS BACK. MISTER CHU ARE YOU
WITH US. I AM MISTER CHAIRMAN
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE- LET ME
FIRST JUST START BY SAYING THE
CAN BUT LET THE LEGISLATURE
DURING THE FALL READ THAT THEY
DIDN'T HAVE A CHANCE TO THANK
YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF ARE
COLLEAGUES FOR LEADING ONE OF MY
ABSOLUTELY FAVORITE COMMITTEES-
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I
APPRECIATE YOU HAVING ME BACKING
FOR YOUR COMPETITION THIS
MORNING. I WANNA THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN FOR
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY SIX AS HE
MENTIONED YEARS AGO THE COMPANY
LEGISLATURE WE DECIDED TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS BY KNOCKING
UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW AN
IMPORTANT STATUTE TO COMBAT
UNFAIR. UNLAWFUL AND FRAUDULENT
BUSINESS PRACTICES ARE ATTORNEY
GENERAL ALL FIFTY EIGHT DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS IN THE CIVIL PUBLIC
LAW OFFICES OF THE LARGEST
CITIES AND COUNTIES IN OUR STATE
FOR ALL VESTED WITH THE SAME
STORY TO ENFORCE THE UCL. I
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE SEVEN
DOUBLE PROSECUTORIAL OFFICES
THAT HAVE USED THE UCL
JUDICIOUSLY TO PROTECT CONSUMERS
AND MANY CONTACTS AT THE AUTHOR
STATED WHILE THE H. E. N. D. H.
AT OUR OFFICES HAVE THE SAME
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY WE
UNFORTUNATELY DON'T HAVE THE
SAME INVESTIGATIVE AUTHORITY TO
USE ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT US.
THIS BILL WOULD SIMPLY ENSURE
THAT ALL ENTITIES AUTHORIZED TO
ENFORCE THE UCL SHOP TOOLS TO DO
SO EFFECTIVELY AT THE MOMENT OUR
OFFICE THAT HAVE LITIGATION AS
THE ONLY TOOL TO ADDRESS UNDER
BUSINESS PRACTICES SUCH
ADMINISTRATIVE SUBPOENAS WULD
ALLOW US TO GATHER INFORMATION
AND DIALOGUE DIRECTLY WITH
BUSINESSES THAT ARE BEING
INVESTIGATED. THIS WILL HAVE
SEVERAL GOOD OUTCOMES FIRST
IDENTIFYING BAD ACTORS THE
PROFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY
IT'S IN THE PUBLIC SPAT BEST
INTERESTS BOTH CONSUMERS AS WELL
AS LAW ABIDING BUSINESSES AND
INDUSTRY WILL BENEFIT WHEN BAD
ACTORS REQUIRED TO PLAY BY THE
RULES THAT'S WHY IT'S CALLED THE
UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW WHICH THE
SECOND IN ADDITION TO LEVELING
THE PLAYING FIELD. THIS BILL
COULD RESULT IN FEWER LAWSUITS
SINCE OUR OFFICES WOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE SUBJECTS
AND REACH EARLIER RESOLUTIONS
RENDERING LITIGATION UNNECESSARY. ADMINISTRATIVE SUBPOENA ALL
THREE OF THE THAT THIS ARE LAW.
IN CLEAR THAT BUSINESS OF LONG
JOINED. THEY CALL LOSS. IN MANY
INSTANCES WITHOUT HEAT SUBPOENAS
J. WOULD BE DELAYED AND IN SOME.
JUSTICE WOULD BE TO. I ORDERS IN
THE DRAW THE SOME IN THE TO
ENSURE ALL CIVIL PROSECUTOR CAN
SCAN THE PERFECT PLACE FOR
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER TO NICE TO HAVE
YOUR VOICE BACK IN OUR COMMITTEE
. ALL RIGHT THAT'S WHAT
ESTIMATES HERE. I THANK YOU AS
CHAIRMAN A GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS MARK AND CORN ON THE SENIOR
DITCH CHIEF DEPUTY CITY ATTORNEY
FOR THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO. I AM
THE HEAD OF OUR OFFICES
AFFIRMATIVE CIVIL ENFORCEMENT
UNIT. AND HAVE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR UNFAIR COMPETITION CASES.
SAN DIEGO CITY ATTORNEY MARA
ELLIOTT ASKED ME TO APPEAR ON
HER BEHALF TODAY AND SHE THANKS
THIS COMMITTEE FOR ITS
ENGAGEMENT ON THESE ISSUES. MY
OFFICE IS THE PRINCIPAL CONSUMER
PROTECTION AGNCY FOR THE EIGHTH
LARGEST CITY IN THE UNITED
STATES. THE VAST MAJORITY OF OUR
CASES INVOLVE MATTERS OF A
STRICTLY LOCAL CONCERN- CARS
THAT ARE TOTAL DESPITE BEING
LEGALLY PARKED. CONTRACTORS WHO
DON'T FINISH THE JOB DESPITE
BEING FULLY PAID. AND LANDLORDS
WHO SEXUALLY HARASS THEIR
TENANTS. MOST OF THE TIME THE
HIT A WALL WHERE ADDITIONAL
FACTS ARE NEEDED IN ORDER TO- AT
THAT CAN ONLY BE OBTAINED BY
SUBPOENA. ONE MATTER IS THAT WE
ARE WORKING ON RIGHT NOW
CURRENTLY INVESTIGATING IS A
PRIME EXAMPLE A CONTRACTOR IN
OUR AREA HAS BEEN EMPLOYING
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS. BUT HASN'T
PAID THEM THE WAGES THAT THEY'VE
EARNED. THEY'VE GIVEN US SOME
DETAILS WERE UNDERSTANDABLY
RELUCTANT TO MAKES A SWORN
STATEMENT OR TO AGREE TO TESTIFY
IN COURT. DUE TO THE PRECARIOUS
IMMIGRATION STATUS. WE NEED THE
BUSINESS RECORDS OF THE
CONTRACTOR TO EVALUATE WORK
CLAIMS. BUT WE CAN'T GET THE
RECORDS THROUGH REGULAR
DISCOVERY CHANNEL BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH PROOF TO FILE
LAWSUIT. WITHOUT AN ACTIVE
LAWSUIT WE CAN'T MAKE A DEMAND
FOR DOCUMENTS. A PRE FINDING
SUBPOENA WOULD ENABLE US TO
SUPPORT OR CONTRADICT THE
WORKERS ALLEGATIONS AND CARRY
OUT THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
ENFORCE THE UNFAIR COMPETITION
LAW. WITH WHICH THIS LEGISLATURE
HAS CHARGED MY OFFICE. AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY SIX IS AN IMPORTANT
TOOL TO PROTECT CONSUMERS THE
ENVIRONMENT AND WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE URGE AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR A BI TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY SIX THIS POINT WE'LL
JUST TAKE NAME AFFILIATION AND-
SUPPORT THANK YOU. HEY CALMLY
WITH L. A. COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS POWER CO SPONSOR
THANK YOU. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MICHAEL RAT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY CO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MISTER TURN
MEMBER SYLVIA SALINAS SHARM
BEHALF OF THE OFFICE OF LOS
ANGELES CITY ATTORNEY MIKE FEWER
A CO SPONSOR IN SUPPORT. AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE OFFICE OF
SITTING COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO
MAYOR LONDON BREED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE. RIGHTS
THING NONE OPERATOR WHICH WILL
PULL LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY SIX. AGAIN
WILL NOT TAKE FURTHER TESTIMONY
BUT NAME AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT
. THANK YOU MR IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO I TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT FOR
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE FALL BY ZERO. TO
TESTIFY FOR AB. TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY SIX. AND NOBODY IS QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION. TO AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY SIX I HAVE
COURTNEY JENSEN. MORNING NOTHING
LIKE RUNNING THE COMMITTEE IS
SPECIAL ORDER- GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS COURTNEY JENSEN
WITH FERNANDES CERVANTES
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF CHSE JACKET AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY SIX. THE BILL
SEEKS TO EXTEND THE AUTHORITY TO
ISSUE PRE LITIGATION
ADMINISTRATIVE SUBPOENAS TO
FORCE CITY ATTORNEY'S
POTENTIALLY INFRINGING ON THE
JUDICIAL PROCESS I DO PROCESS
RATES OF USINESSES
ORGANIZATIONS AND INDIVIDUALS IN
CALIFORNIA- THE AUTHORITY BEING
GRANTED UNDER AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY SIX CAN BE USED AGAINST
ANYONE AT ANY TIME FROM THE
LARGEST OF CORPORATIONS TO THE
MOST STRUGGLING OF NONPROFITS
AND SMALL BUSINESSES. AS THIS
POWER APPLIES BROADLY TO ANY
PERSON DEFINED AS ALL NATURAL
PERSONS CORPORATIONS FIRMS
PARTNERSHIPS JOINT STOCK
COMPANIES ASSOCIATIONS AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS OF PERSONS. THAT'S
WILL POTENTIALLY MAKE BUSINESSES
VULNERABLE TO BASELESS FISHING
EXPEDITIONS AND PUT POLITICAL
MANEUVERS FOR NO COMPELLING
PUBLIC POLICY REASON. WE DO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US AND
WE HAVE PROVIDED THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE WITH AMENDMENT CONCEPTS
THAT WOULD RESOLVE SOME OF OUR
CONCERNS. WE ARE ASKING FOR
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD PROVIDE
BUSINESSES WITH THE ABILITY TO
FILE AN EARLY MOTION TO QUASH A
PRE LITIGATION SUBPOENA. THE
FILING OF THE SUBPOENA ALONE IS
NOT EVIDENCE OF WRONGDOING BUT
THE PUBLIC AWARENESS OF A
SUBPOENA COULD HAVE REAL
FINANCIAL. AND REPUTATIONAL
CONSEQUENCES FOR A BUSINESS OR
ORGANIZATION PUTTING THE
PUNISHMENT BEFORE ANY EVIDENCE
OF MISCONDUCT RESPONDED TO BE
ABLE TO PETITION THE COURT TO
QUASH PRE LITIGATION SUBPOENAS
<c.green>EFORE ACTION IS TAKEN TO COMPEL</c>
COMPLIANCE. RESPECT RESTRICT PRE
LITIGATION SUBPOENAS TO DOCUMENT
PRODUCTION ONLY SO THE
BUSINESSES AND THEIR LEADERSHIP
ARE NOT SUBJECTED MY APOLOGIES.
ARE NOT SUBJECTED TO UNTOLD
HOURS OF DEPOSITIONS THAT ARE
COSTLY TIME CONSUMING AND
PREMATURELY PUNITIVE. ADDISON
SAID AN ANNUAL USE TRACKING SO
THE LEGISLATURE HASN'T OF THOR
AND A OPPORTUNITY TO SEE HOW
THIS POWER IS BEING USED AND
PRACTICE AND HAVE THE ABILITY TO
AMEND OR WITHDRAW THE POWER IF
NEEDED IF NEED BE. REQUIRED THE
COORDINATION OF GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES TO AVOID REDUNDANCY
SINCE DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AND
ATTORNEY GENERAL ALREADY HAVE
THIS POWER CITY ATTORNEY SHOULD
HAVE TO COORDINATE WITH THEM TO
PREVENT DUPLICATION. COMPLYINGWITH THESE DEMANDS IS A TIME
CONSUMING AND LABOR IS PROCESS
CREATING EXORBITANT COSTS FOR
RECIPIENTS OF THE SUBPOENAS
WITHOUT ANY INSURED BENEFIT TO
THE STATE. WE BELIEVE THESE
AMENDMENTS WOULD ENSURE THE
BUSINESSES ORGANIZATIONS AND
INDIVIDUALS ARE AFFORDED FAIR
AND RIGHT REASONABLE DUE PROCESS
PROTECTIONS AGAIN WE APPRECIATE.
THAT WE ARE. WE APPRECIATE WHAT
WE UNDERSTAND AS THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US ON
THE BILL BUT TODAY REMAIN AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
IN THE HEARING ROOM. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ROBERT MUTRIE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE ALSO IN OPPOSITION
BUT- INJURING ENGAGEMENT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM. I'D SAY NOT OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN ALLIANCE FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY SIX AND WILL TAKE
NAME AFFILIATION AND OPPOSITION. I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FOR AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
WHEN FILED BY ZERO. FOR AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY SIX IN
OPPOSITION AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
. WE ARE NEW TARGET WAS HACKED
AND RESPECTFUL POSITION. FOR
ANYBODY ELSE THAT YOU WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AND ONE MOMENT MISTER CHAIR.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE. TWENTY
SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. BY TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY
SEVEN MARCH RIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I BET YOU TWENTY SEVEN GO
AHEAD. AND THEN WELL YOU KNOW.
THERE YOU GO. THANK YOU EMILY
DAHLE BEHALF THE COMPANY GRADING
THE AND OPPOSE LEFT THAT
POSITION THANK YOU. AND THE
FINAL REMINDER TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. FOR SURE NOBODY ELSE WAS
KILLING UP. I THANK YOU OPERATOR
YOU MAY CLOSE THE LINES WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. WHAT
ALL RIGHT I THINK MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS BILL. TO THE
OPPOSITION I PROMISE YOU THE SKY
IS NOT FALLING AND- THESE CITY
ATTORNEYS I THINK I KNOW ALL OF
THEM ARE VERY RESPECTFUL OF
THEIR POSITION AND THE LAW THEY
ARE ELECTED OFFICIALS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AS OUR DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS. I DON'T THINK WE SEEN
ABUSIVELY SUBPOENAS I THINK THE
BILL IS IN FINE FORM TO MOVE
FROM THIS COMMITTEE AND WE DON'T
YET HAVE A QUORUM BUT WE WILL
CERTAINLY TAKE IT UP ONCE WE GET
IT MR MAIENSCHEIN YOU MAY CLOSE
YET THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR I WANT TO. THANK AS CITY
ATTORNEY DAVID CHIU SAN DIEGO
CITY ATTORNEY MARA ELLIOTT- AND
CHIEF DEPUTY. MARK AND CORN FOR
THEIR TESTIMONY AND I AND I
THINK YOU SAID IT WELL THE SKY
ISN'T FALLING AND WE IF THIS WAS
HAPPENING WE HAVE FIFTY EIGHT
DA'S RIGHT NOW AND AN AG WHO
HAVE THIS POWER AND WE HAVEN'T
HAD THE SITUATION THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF TIMES- WHERE THESE
DOCUMENTS ACTUALLY EXONERATE. AT
BUSINESSES IN FACT OBVIOUSLY
MORE OFTEN THAN NOT THE SUBPOENA
DOCUMENTS REQUIRED UNDER
SUBPOENA ARE CONFIDENTIAL. SO I
THINK THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
APPROPRIATE IT THAT IN NO WAY
ALTERS THE EXISTING DUE PROCESS
RIGHTS OF BUSINESSES ANYBODY
SUBJECT TO A SUBPOENA CAN ALWAYS
ASK THE COURT TO DETERMINE THE
APPROPRIATENESS OF A SUBPOENA
THAT REMAINS UNCHANGED SO I
BELIEVE THIS IS APPROPRIATE IT
PROTECTS CONSUMERS IT PROTECTS
CALIFORNIANS AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT MEASURE FOR THIS
COMMITTEE AT TO AN AXE WITH
THAT. WHAT'S COMMITTEE HERE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH I.
RATES NOW BACK IN ORDER THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR PATIENCE MISTER
WOULD WILL GO TO OUR ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY FIVE.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY THINK MR STONE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY FIVE- OVER
THE PAST FEW YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE SCENE AND A LARGE-NUMBER OF BILLS WITH SICK ALL
THE SUGGESTED. CHANGES TO THE
LETTERMAN PETROUS SHORT ACT.
WHILE WELL INTENDED THESE
PROPOSALS TENDED TO ADDRESS
SINGLE ACTS ASPECTS OF LPS
RATHER THAN A- RATHER THAN AT A
BROADER MORE SYSTEMIC. ISSUES OF
A FIFTY FIVE YEAR OLD PROGRAM
THAT TO MY KNOWLEDGE HAS NEVER
HAD A FULL EVALUATION OR REPORT.
THAT'S WHY LAST DECEMBER
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY AND HEALTH
COMMITTEES CONDUCTED A JOINT
HEARING ON THE L. P. S. ACT.
AFTER NEARLY NINE HOURS OF
TESTIMONY AND DISCUSSION IT WAS
APPARENT THAT THE SYSTEM NEEDS
ADDRESSING. MOST ALARMING WAS
THE LACK OF CLARITY AND
CONSISTENCY IN SOME BASIC BACK
ASPECTS OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE ACT. THESE INCONSISTENCIES
RESULT IN PEOPLE BEING DETAINED
ON FIFTY ONE FIFTY HOLDS TREATED
DIFFERENTLY DEPENDING ON WHERE
THEY RESIDE. WHERE THEY ARE HELD
OR HOW THINGS ARE INTERPRETED.
THE SECOND MOST ALARMING
REVELATION WAS THE ALMOST
COMPLETE LACK OF DATA EITHER
REAL TIME OR HISTORICAL. HOW CAN
A SYSTEM THAT IS DESIGNED TO
PROTECT AND SERVE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO DATA UPON WHICH TO
ASSESS ITS EFFECTIVENESS. HOW
CAN WE AS A LEGISLATURE BE
CALLED UPON TO DO THE RIGHT
THING ON BEHALF OF CITIZENS. WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT WE DON'T KNOW.
AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY FIVE IS A
RELATIVELY SIMPLE BILL AND
DEFINITELY A WORK IN PROGRESS.
IT SEEKS TO CLARIFY CERTAIN DUE
PROCESS PROTECTIONS FOR
INVOLUNTARY DETENTIONS TO ENSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS. HE CLARIFIES
FUNDAMENTAL THINGS SUCH AS WHEN
THE CLOCK ACTUALLY BEGINS ON A
FIFTY ONE FIFTY HOLD. FROM THE
DATA PERSPECTIVE WE HAVE LAID
OUT A REPORTING FRAMEWORK
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH A GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS TO SPECIFY EXACTLY
WHAT DATA SHOULD BE REQUIRED
FROM THE COUNTIES. THE
FACILITIES THE ONLY OWES AND
OTHERS. THE BILL WILL CONTINUE
TO EVOLVE AS IT WORKS ITS WAY
THROUGH THE PROCESS. AB TWENTY
TWO SEVENTY FIVE ISN'T THE
PANACEA FOR THE L. P. S. ACT.
WILL CLARIFY SOME CRITICAL DUE
PROCESS PROTECTIONS AND
INCREASED OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY THROUGH ENHANCED
DATA COLLECTION. AB TWENTY TWO
IS A BEGINNING. ELIGIBLE TO SAY
IT'S AN HONOR TO WORK WITH THE
CHAIR AS AS A JOINT AUTHORS ON
THIS BILL. AND WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES HERE TO SPEAK TODAY-
AND I'M NOT SURE THAT YOU MISTER
CHAIR IF YOU'RE IF YOU PLAN TO
SAY ANYTHING ON THIS MORNING. NO-NO- RESERVE COMMENT FOR A LITTLE
BIT LATER BUT THANK YOU THINK
BRING THAT IN THIS THANK YOU SO
WE HAVE TO WITNESSES- TO SPEAK.
TO AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY FIVE
MICHELLE CABRERA WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION. AND DEBORAH ROTH
WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA. AND THAT WILL BE
JOINING US ON THE PHONE. GREAT
THANK YOU. ACTUALLY BOTH LISTED
ON TE TELEPHONE MICHELLE
CABRERA ARE YOU WITH US YES HI
RIGHT HERE. SORRY GIVE HER A
PHONE IF THAT. THAT'S THE SORRY
FOR THE LAST MINUTE SWITCH UP
THEIR CHAIRS AND MEMBERS
MICHELLE CAPITA WITH THE COUNTY
BE REAL HOPE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA CBH DA
MEMBERS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
DELIVERY AS OF MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER SERVICES
IN THE PUBLIC SAFETY NET
PARTICULARLY FOR CHILDREN AND
ADULTS WITH SIGNIFICANT MENTAL
HEALTH OR SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
NEEDS INCLUDING LOCAL OVERSIGHT
OF THE LPS FACT. CBH DA HAS A
SUPPORT IN CONCEPT ON AB TWO TWO
SEVEN FIVE AND I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIRS AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH TO POTENTIAL CHANGES TO
THE LPS ACT STARTING WITH THE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING IN THE
FALL AND CULMINATING IN THIS
BILL. FIRST I WANT TO SAY THAT
OUR MEMBERS TAKE THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY UNDER LPS LAW
VERY SERIOUSLY OUR MEMBERS
UNDERSTAND BOTH THE AWESOME
RESPONSIBILITIES AFFORDED TO
THEM IN DETERMINING WHEN AND HOW
TO PUT A PERSON'S INDIVIDUAL
RIGHTS CAN BE REMOVED. AND THE
PROTECTION OF HUMAN LIFE WHEN AN
INDIVIDUAL MAY BE A RISK TO
THEMSELVES OR TO OTHERS DUE TO
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH CONDITION.
WELL COUNTIES ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR DETERMINING WHO MAY PLACE
AND REMOVE HOLDS. ALONG WITH
COORDINATION WITH OUR PUBLIC
GUARDIANS TO ARRANGE FOR
TREATMENT AND SERVICES FOR
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES. WE SHARE
OVERLAPPING ROLES AN
RESPONSIBILITIES WITH VARIOUS
OTHER ENTITIES AND SYSTEMS
INCLUDING LAW ENFORCEMENT
HOSPITALS COMMERCIAL AND
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS.
EXISTING REPORTING STRUCTURES
FALL SHORT BECAUSE THEY FAIL TO
RECOGNIZE THIS COMPLEXITY NOT
ALL LPS ACTIVITIES HAPPEN IN THE
CONTEXT OF DESIGNATED
FACILITIES. AND COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DOES NOT HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO COMPEL OUR
PARTNERS WHETHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
HOSPITALS OR HEALTH PLANS TO
REPORT TO US SO THAT WE CAN IN
TURN PROVIDE A COMPLETE PICTURE
OF INVOLUNTARY HOLDS AND
TREATMENT TO THE STATE. WE'RE
EXCITED ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY
THAT AB TWO TWO SEVEN FIVE
PRESENTS FOR US TO MAKE
MEANINGFUL PROGRESS IN ANSWERING
A SIMPLE BUT IMPORTANT SET OF
QUESTIONS. WHO IS PLACED ON HOLD
FOR HOW LONG AND WHAT HAPPENS TO
THEM WE BELIEVE THAT THIS BASIC
MACRO LEVEL DATA CAN HELP THE
STATE TO BEGIN TO UNDERSTAND
WHETHER AND WHEN INVOLUNTARY
TREATMENT IS USED AND HOW
EFFECTIVE IT MAY BE FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS AND THE COMMUNITIES
THAT WE SERVE. WHILE OUR MEMBERS
HAVE CONCERNS WITH SOME OF THE
LANGUAGE AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED.
M. IN PARTICULAR WE BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO BALANCE DUE PROCESS
RIGHTS WITH THE PROTECTION OF
LIFE FOR OUR CLIENTS- WHEN ALL
TOO OFTEN THEIR LIVES HANG IN
THE BALANCE OF PROVIDER
AVAILABILITY AND WILLINGNESS. WE
DO BELIEVE THAT OUR GOALS OF
LINE WITH THOSE OF THE AUTHORS
IN BALANCING TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY ALONG WITH TRYING
TO BETTER STANDARDIZE PRACTICES
ACROSS THE STATE. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS TO ACHIEVE THESE AIMS
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. RIGHT OUR NEXT
WITNESS IS DEBORAH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD HAVE
BROUGHT DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
ALL THE EFFORT YOU HAVE PUT INTO
THIS BILL AND THE VERY LONG
HEARING THAT YOU HELD IN
DECEMBER. ARE YOUR BILL BUILT ON
THAT HEARING AND OUT OF THAT
AUDIT REPORT MAKING A VERY
IMPORTANT STEP IN LANTERN AND
PATRICK SHORT ACT REFORMS- ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT TO PROCESS
PROTECTIONS THAT THIS BILL
ADDRESSES. IS TO CLARIFY THAT
WHEN A PERSON IS HELD ON A
SEVENTY TWO HOUR HOLD. THE CLOCK
FOR THE SEVENTY TWO HOURS BEGAN
WHEN THE PERSON IS DETAINED. SO
IF YOU'RE DETAINED FOR A SEVENTY
TWO HOUR HOLD BUT THEN YOU END
UP IN A NON COUNTY COUNTY
DESIGNATED FACILITY OF THE CARD-
MISS CABARRUS REFERENCE BUT
THERE IS NOT ENOUGH INFORMATION-
ABOUT- IT DOESN'T MATTER YOU ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE TRANSFERRED TO A
COUNTY DESIGNATED FACILITY AND
EVALUATED SO THAT. YOU CAN BE-
REALLY A TREAT. AND DISPOSED OF
AIM PROVISIONS TO ADDRESS
SITUATIONS WHERE IT IS
IMPOSSIBLE BEYOND THE CONTROL OF
THE FACILITY TO HAVE THAT
COMPLETED WITHIN SEVENTY TWO
HOURS. AND WE THINK THAT IT IS
AN IMPORTANT STEP THERE ARE
OTHER OPPOSITION IN THE BILL
THAT COULD BE ONE OF THE MOST.
IMPORTANT- AND WE THANK BY WHAT
WE WERE. FROM THE HEARING AND
FROM THE ARTICLE IS THAT THERE
ARE SOME VERY. AMONG CAR. AND
EVEN WITHIN INDIVIDUAL. APART IS
NOT A CONFLICT. DESIGNATED AND I
WAS GOING TO PUT FILL IN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HAPPY ANSWER ANY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. RIGHT IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE
SUPPORT FOR AB. TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY FIVE. ALL RIGHT SING
NINE OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO EDUCATE SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
TWO SEVENTY FIVE. AND WILL TAKE
NAME AFFILIATION SUPPORTS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR
AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE FALL BY
ZERO TO TOUCH FIND SUPPORT FOR
AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY FIVE. AND
WE'LL START OUT WITH POINT SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TO MADDEN
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS IN WE'RE
IN A SUPPORTIVE AMENDED POSITION
THANK YOU. AT ONE MOMENT I WILL
GO TO LINE SIXTY FOUR YOU ARE
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN BOB ROBERT HARRIS ON
BEHALF OF THAT SO YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT AND
CONCEPT WITH THIS BILL WE THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT. LOOKING FORWARD
PACK UP OKAY THANK YOU. IF THERE
ARE ANY OTHER OF PARTICIPANTS
THAT WOULD LIKE TO A QUEUE UP
FOR THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND MISTER
CHAIR NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU AND
BEFORE WE MOVED OPPOSITION SO
THERE'S SOME AMENDMENTS AND
THEY'RE- LISTED IN THE- ANALYSIS
EXERTING THOSE ARMY ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. RIGHT WILL NOW MOVES
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY FIVE. RIGHT
SIGNALED OPERATOR WOULD YOU OF
ALLIANCE FOR OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY FIVE.
THE OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY FIVE. SURE
SIR IS NEEDED AND IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO PLAY I OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE
FILED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NOBODY IS KILLING UP THANK YOU
YOU MAY CLOSE ALLIANCE I WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEES
AND MISTER WHAT I JUST WANT TO
CREATE THE COLLABORATIVE WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WE'VE HAD WITH OUR
TWO COMMITTEES I THINK IT'S BEEN
REALLY. ASTONISHING AND VERY
HELPFUL WITH THE DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES FROM THE HEALTH
SIDE AND THEN OF COURSE THE
JUDICIARY SIDE WERE WERE.
LOOKING OUT FOR THAT THE RIGHTS
OF INDIVIDUAL PEOPLE AND I DO. I
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT THE CURRENT
IMPETUS ACROSS THE BOARD FROM
THE CARE COURTS ALL THESE OTHER
PROPOSALS THAT ARE COMING
THROUGH. AND YET THE HEARING
THAT WE HAD WAS VERY LUMINATE
HANG ON SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
WITHIN THE EXISTING LPS SYSTEM.
AND IS ORIGINALLY FRAME THE CARE
CORPORATE PUZZLE BEING. PUT MORE
OF A FRONTEND AND THE LPS SYSTEM
BEING AS A BACKSTOP UNDERSCORED
THE NEED TO HAVE THIS LEVEL OF
INVESTIGATION I THINK RIGHT NOW
WITH THE DISCUSSIONS. OF CARE
ACCORDING ALL THESE BILLS.
THERE'S A LOT OF CONFUSION OF
LINES IN HERE WHICH MAKES ME A
LITTLE BIT CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE IMPOSING WHAT POTENTIALLY
IMPOSING ON COUNTIES AND- WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO SUBJECT PEOPLE TO
AS THEY COME INTO THE SYSTEM SO
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE HOWEVER THIS WORK I
DO BELIEVE IT'S ABSOLUTELY
FOUNDATIONAL. TO GETTING NEXT
STEPS DONE AND IT'S JUST BEEN
SUCH A PLEASURE WORKING WITH
YOUR COMMITTEE AND YOUR
EXPERTISE ON IN THIS AREA THAT
WE CAN COLLABORATE AND PUT
TOGETHER SOMETHING THAT. I HATE
TO SAY ANYTHING IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS THIS IS CERTAINLY
WORTHY OF MOVING OUT OF THE THIS
COMMITTEE AND MOVING FORWARD BUT
YET THERE ARE QUESTIONS BEING
RAISED THAT I THINK WE
DEFINITELY NEED TO BE LOOKING AT
AND TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION AS
WE AS WE MOVE SOMETHING THROUGH
SO I. VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
WORK ON HERE. OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS WAS REST. I DO%
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THE DATA HOW ARE WE
GOING TO TRY TO WORK ON
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN'T FULLY
EVALUATE I APPRECIATE ALSO THAT
D. AND THE BILL YOU HAVE THE DUE
PROCESS PROTECTIONS. AND WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ANY FOR ANY
REFORM TO THE LANDRUM AND
PATCHES. SHORT ACT I THINK
FINDING THAT BALANCE BETWEEN
INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS AND SOCIETY'S
RESPONSIBILITIES. ARE CLEARLY AS
THE CHAIR HAS INDICATED THAT THE
US IS A STEP. IN IN. IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND IN THE
PROPER DIRECTION AND I DO
APPRECIATE. THANK YOU. Q. OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS RIGHT SEEING
NONE DR WOULD YOU MAY CLOSE YES-
AND THANK YOU THANK YOU TO
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF THE CHERUB IT'S BEEN A
PLEASURE WORKING WITH YOU IT'S
AT I DON'T RECALL IN MY TIME IN
THE LEGISLATURE OF A BILL WHERE
THAN I COULD I WOULD HAVE
REMEMBER BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN THE
CHAIR OF WHERE WE'VE OUT WITH
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE CHAIR OF
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE KITTY
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN JOINT
AUTHORED A BILL BUT I THINK THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS ISSUE. AND
THE LACK OF FOUNDATIONAL DATA IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL THE
CLARIFICATION OF WIN A FIFTY ONE
FIFTY ACTUALLY BEGINS WILL BE A
HUGE HUGE HELP FOR EVERYONE
THERE'S SUCH SUCH CONFUSION
AROUND THAT AND ANYBODY WHO'S
WATCHED MY WORK OVER THE YEARS
KNOWS THAT DATA IS FOUNDATIONAL
TO PRETTY MUCH EVERYTHING I DO
AND- THIS IS A REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT EFFORT AND I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR SUPPORT ASPIRIN I
VOTE WHEN YOU HAVE A QUORUM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE WILL
TAKE IT UP WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
ALL RIGHTS. MR TANG. ALL RIGHT
OF NUMBER TWO A. B. FIFTEEN
NINETY FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU IN
YOUR COMMITTEE ON. ALL THE HELP
ON A. B. FIFTEEN NINETY FOUR AB
FIFTEEN NINETY FOUR ESTABLISHES
THE FIRE ARMS INDUSTRY
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT AS WE'VE SEEN
A FEW SATURDAYS AGO WE HAD A
VERY HORRIFIC. MASS SHOOTING
JUST A FEW BLOCKS FROM HERE- AND
UNFORTUNATELY THAT WAS NOT THE
ONLY ONE THAT HAPPENED THIS YEAR
WE'VE SEEN. AS WE STARTED TO
COME OUT THE PANDEMIC A RASH OF
MASS SHOOTINGS ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY- LONG CALIFORNIA WE
PRIDE OURSELVES ON HAVING FAIRLY
STRICT. GUN CONTROL LAWS WE'VE
DONE BETTER THAN OTHER OTHER
STATES BUT STILL NOT GOOD
ENOUGH- ONE MASS SHOOTINGS ONE
MASS SHOOTING TOO MANY WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS REALLY. THAT
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR LOCAL
CITIES- INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
VICTIMS OF FIRE ARMS VIOLENCE TO
REALLY HOLD THE GUN INDUSTRY
ACCOUNTABLE THEY ARE THE ONLY
INDUSTRY AS YOU ARE WELL AS THIS
COMMITTEES WELL AWARE- THAT HAS
COMPLETE LIABILITY FOR THE
PRODUCTS THAT THEY PUT IN OUR
COMMUNITY. AND THE DAMAGE THAT
IS CAUSED TO INDIVIDUALS WHO USE
THEIR PRODUCTS- UNFORTUNATELY.
THIS LIABILITY HAS A FEDERAL
SHIELD- WE BELIEVE THAT AB
FIFTEEN NINETY FOUR COMPLETE
LEGAL MODELED AFTER WHAT NEW
YORK HAD ALREADY PASSED AND
SIGNED INTO LAW- WE THINK IT
PROVIDES A REALLY GOOD
OPPORTUNITY TO PUT THE POWER
BACK IN THE HANDS OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE THE INDIVIDUAL VICTIMS
OF GUN VIOLENCE IN REALLY. BUT
WHAT WE HOPE IS BY HOLDING THIS
INDUSTRY ACCOUNTABLE THAT THEY
WILL BE MUCH MORE THOUGHTFUL
ABOUT HOW THEY SELL THEIR
WEAPONS- WHAT THEY DO WHEN
SOMEONE BUYS A WEAPON THE
EDUCATION. ARE REGARDING- SAFELY
STORING- SAFELY USING THESE
WEAPONS- WE BELIEE THAT THE
INDUSTRY REALLY NEEDS TO STEP IT
UP AND REALLY BE HELD
SIGNIFICANTLY MUCH MORE
ACCOUNTABLE- I THINK IT'S NOT
VERY FAIR THAT THE TOY INDUSTRY
HAS A LOT MORE LIABILITY THEN
THE GOT INDUSTRY. MR THIS REALLY
AN OPPORTUNITY TO AGAIN. MAKE
SURE THAT OUR CITIES ARE
COMMUNITIES CAN DO EVERYTHING IN
THEIR POWER AND THEIR LEGAL
POWER. TO HOLD THIS INDUSTRY
ACCOUNTABLE AND KEEP OUR STREETS
SAFE WITHOUT RESPECT BASS RIGHT
BOTH ON A. B. A. B. FIFTEEN
NINETY FOUR. WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES- FOR THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN. THANK YOU AND BEFORE
WE TAKE THE WITNESSES THEIR
AMENDMENTS LISTED IN THE
ANALYSIS YOU'RE TAKING THOSE
MOMENTS HAPPY TO TAKE THOSE OVER
THE BRIDGE ALL THE HELP THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE THAT. A RATES
W DO HAVE TWO WITNESSES TANYA
SHORT. ARE YOU WITH US ON THE
PHONE THE MORNING CARE ACT DOWN
AND- YES GOOD MORNING CHAIRED
STYLE. AND DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS
OF THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS TONY STARK
AND PETER CALDERON DIRECTOR OF
STATE AND FEDERAL POLICY OF
BRADY. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN NINETY
FOUR. AS YOU HAVE HEARD SINCE
THE PASSAGE OF PLAQUE THAT
FIREARMS MANUFACTURERS AND
SELLERS HAVE BEEN AFFORDED
SPECIAL PROTECTION. NOT GIVEN
THE OTHER INDUSTRIES AFTER
SHUTTING OFF AND SHUTTING THE
COURTHOUSE DOOR TO THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN INJURED AS A RESULT OF
YOUR RESPONSIBLE. NEGLIGENT ARE
CHANGES COMING DISTRICT CONTACT
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE
ACTIONABLE UNDER CIVIL JUSTICE
PRINCIPLES. THESE PROTECTIONS
OFTEN RESULT IN THE CLIFF CASES
CASES THAT DRAG ON FOR YOUR
PENDING APPEAL AND HAVE HAD A
CHILLING EFFECT ON CASES BROUGHT
AGAINST THE GUN INDUSTRY. MOST
TROUBLING IT HAS ALLOWED THE
INDUSTRY TO PUT PROFITS OVER
PEOPLE. AB FIFTEEN NINETY FOUR
RECTIFY THIS INJUSTICE INJUSTICE
BY CREATING A LAW THAT WOULD
SERVE AS ONE OF THE SIX EXPLICIT
EXCEPTION THE FACT THAT. THAT
PERMIT CIVIL ACTION ONE COUNTRY
MEMBERS KNOWINGLY VIOLATE A
STATE OR FEDERAL STATUTE
APPLICABLE TO THE SALE OR
MARKETING OF THE PRODUCT. AB
FIFTEEN NINETY FOUR CREATE SUCH
A STATUTE BY ESTABLISHING A
FIREARM INDUSTRY STANDARD OF
CONDUCT UNDER WHICH GOT INDUSTRY
MEMBERS. WILL BE REQUIRED TO
ESTABLISH A BOARD STREET WILL
CONTROL TO PREVENT DANGEROUS
SALES. AND PROMOTE THEIR WOULD
PROHIBIT GUN INDUSTRY MEMBERS
FROM CREATING AN UNREASONABLE
RISK OF HARM TO THE PUBLIC OR
ENGAGING IN OTHER UNFAIR DANGERS
BUSINESS PRACTICE THAT. BY
CREATING THE POSSIBILITY OF
CIVIL LIABILITY AB FIFTEEN
NINETY FOUR WILL NOT ONLY
PROVIDE CIVIL JUSTICE TO VICTIMS
AND SURVIVORS. AND ENTIRE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY BUT WILL
ALSO INCENTIVIZE THE GUN
INDUSTRY TO ENGAGE AND
REASONABLE AND SAFE BUSINESS
PRACTICES. WHICH WILL PREVENT
GUN VIOLENCE BEFORE IT HAPPENS
AND THE FULL CONTENTS INTO
COMMUNITIES DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY TRAFFICKED FIREARMS.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR THIS BILL
DOES NOT CREATE STRICT LIABILITY
OR GUARANTEE IF THEY WROTE
JUDGMENT. WILL NOT ALLOW
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS TO PROCEED
RATHER IT WILL ENSURE THAT THE
GUN INDUSTRY TREATED LIKE AND
IT'S SUBJECT TO THE MEASURE THAT
MECHANISMS AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
AT EVERY OTHER INDUSTRY IN THE
COUNTRY. BECAUSE NO. SHOULD BE A
THE LOCK. GUN INDUSTRY NUMBER.
IRRESPONSIBLY OVER. MAY THELEMA
FIRE. THEY SHOULD BE HOW
ACCOUNT. THIS BILL WILL. SURE
PASSED IS PART. THE PEOPLE.
THANK YOU TO SOME MEMBER AND
GENERAL BONTA THEIR STRONG
LEADERSHIP ON THE BILL AND TO
THE COMMITTEE. I URGE YOU TO
VOTE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND THEN
LAUREN LEAP. CHAIR SOON AND
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY MY NAME IS
LAUREN LEE AND I'VE BEEN A
GRASSROOTS GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION ACTIVIST FOR MORE
THAN TWENTY YEARS. I ACTIVISM
BEGAN AS IT DOES FOR SO MANY
PEOPLE IN RESPONSE TO MY
FAMILY'S PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
WITH GUN VIOLENCE. IN THE SUMMER
OF NINETEEN NINETY NINE HEAVILY
ARMED NEO **** ATTACKED A JEWISH
COMMUNITY CENTER IN A SUBURB OF
LOS ANGELES. BUILDING WITH
MULTIPLE PARENTS HIGH CAPACITY
MAGAZINES AND BEGAN SHOOTING.
ESPERANZA BULLETS LASTED LESS
THAN A MINUTE DURING WHICH TIME
ABOUT SEVENTY ROUNDS WERE FIRED
AND MULTIPLE PEOPLE WERE SHOT.
ASSEMBLY OF JEWISH ADULTS.
INSTEAD HE ENCOUNTERED SMALL
CHILDREN WHO WERE ATTENDING
SUMMER DAY CAMP. MY SIX YEAR OLD
SON WAS ONE OF THE CHILDREN IN
THE LINE OF FIRE. IT WAS HIT
MULTIPLE TIMES AND MY EIGHT YEAR
OLD SON WHAT KIND OF TWO HUNDRED
OTHER CHILDREN WHO WITNESS THANK
. AFTER LEAVING THE JCC THE
SHOOTER MURDERED JOSEPH ILETO
FILIPINO AMERICAN POSTAL WORKERS
ON HIS ROUTE DELIVERING MAIL. MY
SON SURVIVED HIS WOUNDS BUT FOR
BOTH OF MY CHILDREN MY FAMILY
AND MY COMMUNITY THE EMOTIONAL
SCARS WILL LAST A LIFETIME. OUR
EXPERIENCE THIS EXPERIENCE IS
UNIQUELY AMERICAN. AFTER THE
SHOOTING WE JOINED WITH OTHER
FAMILIES TO SUE THE GUN
MANUFACTURERS THAT ENGAGED IN
DANGEROUS AND IRRESPONSIBLE
BUSINESS PRACTICES RELATED TO
THE MANUFACTURE MARKETING AND
DISTRIBUTION OF THE SHOOTER'S
FIREARMS. WE FILED OUR SUIT IN
TWO THOUSAND BUT THE GUN
INDUSTRY FOUGHT US FOR FIVE
YEARS AND ALL THE WAY UP TO THE
SUPREME COURT TO STOP THE CASE
FROM GOING TO TRIAL. THE SUPREME
COURT RULE TO ALLOW THE CASE TO
MOVE FORWARD. BUT LITTLE DID WE
KNOW THAT CONGRESS HAD ALSO BEEN
LOOKING AT FIREARM INDUSTRY
LAWSUITS LIKE OURS. THAT SAME
YEAR IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE
CONGRESS PASSED THE PROTECTION
OF LAWFUL COMMERCE IN ARMS ACT
FOR PLACA. NOT ONLY TO POCKET
PROTECTS THE INDUSTRY FROM NEW
LAWSUIT. THAT IMPACTED BUT IT
IMPACTED CASES LIKE OURS THAT
HAD ALREADY BEEN FILED. OKAY
SHIELDED AND CONTINUES TO SHIELD
BAD ACTORS IN THE GUN INDUSTRY
FOR MOST OF TH LAWSUIT AND WAS
RETROACTIVE TO OUR STATE WHICH
WAS FINALLY TO COME TO TRIAL.
JUST LIKE THAT THE MANUFACTURERS
WHO ACTED IRRESPONSIBLY OR
DANGEROUSLY WERE OFF THE HOOK.
MY FAMILY AND OTHER OF THE JCC
SHOOTING RAMPAGE NO LONGER HAD
RECOURSE THROUGH THE COURTS.
CITY WAS IN PURE READING AND
UNFAIR IS AN UNDERSTATEMENT. OUR
NATION IS FOUNDED ON THE BELIEF
IN EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW
NO AMERICAN SHOULD HAVE
COURTHOUSE DOORS SLAMMED IN
THEIR FACE BECAUSE THE INDUSTRY
THAT HARMS THEM IT'S GIVEN
SPECIAL PROTECTION BY CONGRESS.
THAT'S NOT EQUAL JUSTICE IT'S
NOT FAIR IT'S NOT RIGHT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO AGREES WHICH
IS WHY THIS CRITICAL LEGISLATION
THAT WERE IMPORTANT TO THE GUN
INDUSTRY KNOWS THEIR BUSINESS
PRACTICES CREATE UNACCEPTABLE
RISKS FOR THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
BUT WITHOUT FEAR OF
REPERCUSSIONS THERE IS NO
INCENTIVE TO CHANGE THERE MUST
FATAL HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR ROLE IN THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IMPACTED
EVERY YEAR BY GUN VIOLENCE.
THOSE INJURED KILLED THEIR LOVED
ONES THEIR COMMUNITIES
DEVASTATED BY GUN VIOLENCE THIS
BILL WILL ENSURE THAT VICTIMS
AND SURVIVORS LIKE ME AND MY
CHILDREN HAVE ACCESS TO JUSTICE
. THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIANG FOR YOUR DEDICATED WORK
ON THIS ISSUE I URGE YOUR
COLLEAGUES TO VOTE IN SUPPORT OF
FAIRNESS AND IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN NINETY FOUR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO'D
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR A
BI FIFTEEN NINETY FOUR. THIS
POINT WE WILL NOT TAKE FURTHER
TESTS MONEY BUT NAME AFFILIATION
ENDS AND SUPPORT SYLVIUS ALICIA
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE. RIGHT WILL MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR A BI FIFTEEN NINETY FOUR. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR A BI FIFTEEN NINETY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE FELL BY
ZERO FOR SUPPORT. AND WE WILL
BEGIN WITH LINE SEVENTY THREE
MISTER CHAIR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS STATE
HUTCHINGS WITH THE BRINK OF A
POLICY GROUP TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF MOUNTAIN
VIEW SUPPORT. WE WILL GO LINE
TWENTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING OF COOKING I THOUGHT
BEHALF OF EVERY COUNTER GUN
SAFETY AND SUPPORT. THANK
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING REBECCA GONZALEZ OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT AND ALSO
VOLUNTEER LEADER WITH BAGGAGE
BRADY CAMPAIGN GOAL COUNTRY
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANKS FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS RAYMOND
PHILLIP CHEN LIVING IN CLERMONT
CALIFORNIA CAN IN THE LONG TEAR
WITH MOMS DEMAND ACTION FOR GUN
SENSE AGAIN SENSITIVITY TRONG.
OCTAGONS SUPPORT. BOB AB FIFTEEN
NINETY FOUR THANK YOU. THE FINAL
REMINDER TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
FOR A BI FIFTEEN NINETY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME NINE THIRTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS RACHEL
MICHAELSON AND I'M A VOLUNTEER
WITH MOMS DEMAND ACTION FOR GUN
SENSE CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN NINETY FOUR. AND LINE
SIXTY YOUR OPEN. HELLO MY NAME
IS HARPER RICHARDSON AND- IT
STERLING SUPPORT WITH MARCH FOR
OUR LIVES A NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION WORKING FOR GUN
VIOLENCE SAFETY. MISTER CHAIR
THERE KNOW WHETHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
WE WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION I
HAVE ONE OPPOSITION LISTED ON.
COMING WITH US ON THE TELEPHONE
RAY GRIFFITH ARE YOU WITH US.
YES SIR THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS FOR THE RECORD ROY
GRIFFITHS LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION COMING UP OUR
MEMBERS CALIFORNIA WE'RE STRONG
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN NINETY FOUR THE VEGAS OF
THIS BILL IS TROUBLING ONE MUST
ASK WHAT DOESTHAT EVEN MEAN. A
FIREARM RELATED PRODUCT THAT IS
LIKELY TO CREATE A SUBSTANTIAL
REASONABLE RISK OF HARM TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY THEY
BEGIN TO NINETY FOUR SO BROUGHT
ALMOST ANYONE COULD BRING CIVIL
SUIT AGAINST THE FARM INDUSTRY
IT'S AN ATTACK ON THE LAWFUL
COMMERCE OF FARM FOR THE INTENT
TO LIMIT THE AVAILABILITY OF
FARMS THIS IS ANOTHER MISGUIDED
BILL THAT SEEKS TO SCORCHING
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST THE RIGHTS
OF THOSE ENGAGE IN LAWFUL
COMMERCE. TO RESPECT LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS ACCESS TO FARMS AND
HOLDING ACCOUNTABLE THOSE WHO
MISUSE FARMS FARMS ARE NEARLY
SHAPE ADAM IT TOOL IS THE
OPERATOR THAT CAN SOMETIMES BE
UNSAFE EITHER BY NEGLIGENCE
MALICIOUS CRIMINAL INTENT WE
MUST INSTEAD FOCUS OUR TIME AND
RESOURCES ON THOSE WHO CHOOSE TO
USE FARMS THE COMMISSION VIOLENT
CRIMES. HOUSE SUBSTANTIAL
REGIONAL RISK OF HARM TO THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY EVEN DECIDED
FEDERAL LAW PROHIBITS PROHIBITS
MANUFACTURERS FROM BEING SUED
THE PROTECTION OF LAWFUL
COMMERCE ACT PROTECTS
MANUFACTURERS AND DEALERS FROM
BEING SUED OF FARMERS USED IN A
CRIME THE ACT WAS PASSED BY THE
U. S. SENATE IN TWO THOUSAND
FIVE AND PROHIBITS VICTIMS OF
PERSON MISUSING FARM PRODUCTS
AND SEEKING DAMAGES. OR
INJUNCTIONS THE RELEASE. THE
RULING TO BUSINESSES IN A STATES
BELIEVE ENGAGE COM CANNOT AND
SHOULD BE LAW FOR THE- OF WHO
HAS. TO OUTSIDE OF THE CONTROL
AND THE MISUSE OF THE PRODUCT
THE RULING STATED. THE
POSSIBILITY IMPOSING LIABILITY
ENTIRE INDUSTRY FOR THE HARM
THAT IS SOLELY CAUSED BY OTHERS
SHOULDN'T BE USED TO THE LEGAL
SYSTEM. IT A ROBUST PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE IN OUR NATIONAL
NATION'S LAWSUIT THREATENS THE
DOMINATION. BUT BASIC
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS CIVIL
LIBERTY AND INVITES TO
DISASSEMBLY AND DESTABILIZATION
OF. OTHER INDUSTRIES AND
ECONOMIC SECTORS LAWFULLY
COMPETING IN FREE ENTERPRISE
SYSTEM UNITED STATES. AND
CONSTITUTIONAL REASONABLE
BURDEN. ON INTERSTATE AND
FOREIGN COMMERCE UNITED STATES.
I'M NOT GOING TO THE NUMEROUS
EXAMPLES OCCASIONAL ACROSS THE
NATION THAT SUPPORTS THIS RULING
BUT IT SUFFICES TO SAY AB
FIFTEEN NINETY FOUR IS CLEARLY
IN DIRECT CONFLICT WITH FEDERAL
LAW. AND HAS BEEN TRIED AND
TESTED IT CLEARLY VIOLATES THE
FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT NO STATE
SHALL MAKE OR ENFORCE ANY LAW
WHICH BRIDGES THE PRIVILEGES OR
IMMUNITIES OF CITIZENS UNITED
STATES. HAVE TO RESULT IN
DISTRACTED LAW ENFORCEMENT WASTE
OF TAX DOLLARS. IT WILL BE
CHALLENGING IT WILL BE REPEAL.
FARMS ARE TOOLS YOU CANNOT HOLD
MANUFACTURES LIABLE FOR THE
ACTIONS THOSE WHO USE THEM FOR
CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR. WHAT'S NEXT
TO IMPORTANT GENERAL MOTORS WHEN
AN INDIVIDUAL GETS BEHIND THE
WHEEL INTOXICATED TAKES HUMAN
LIFE. PURSUING MANUFACTURE SO
IMPORTANT SOMEONE DECIDES TO
DIVE INTO THE SHALLOW AND THAT'S
NOT INTENDED FOR DIVING. YOU
WERE OPENING A PANDORA'S BOX AND
TAKING ACTION THAT WILL BOG DOWN
AN ALREADY TAX COURT SYSTEM.
INSTEAD WE DEMAND THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE AND ARE TURNING
GENERAL REINSTATE LAWS TO KEEP
HARDENED CRIMINALS OFF OUR
STREETS. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIANS OF THE VERY TURNED
OUT WE FOUNDATION OF OUR
ORGANIZATION. AND OUR CONSTANT
GOAL TO WORK TOWARDS COMMONSENSE
SOLUTIONS REGARDING ISSUES OF
CRIME AND FIREARM OWNERSHIP.
THIS CAN ONLY BE DONE HOWEVER
WITHOUT SACRIFICING A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO BELIEVE
LAW ABIDING CITIZENS PROTECT
THEIR FAMILIES ENJOY COMPETITIVE
SHOOTING BENCH. CERTAINLY AFTER. CERTAINLY GOING AFTER THOSE
TWO MEN SURE LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
NOT THE END. FOR THESE REASONS
WE STAND AS ON. TO THIS BILL. WE
ALSO TEACH VERY MUCH OF. WHEN
MEMBERS ARE VIEWS. TRAGIC INTO.
AND CALLING THOSE WHO SHOOT WHEN
THEY ARE. CLEARLY GET BY LAW. SO
FOR ALL THE REASONS ABOVE WE
CA. AND STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU
TO VOTE NO ON THIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU WILL NOT
MOVE TO. ANY OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO GET OPPOSITION TO AB FIFTEEN
NINETY FOUR. AGAIN WILL BE
TAKING NAME AFFILIATION AND
OPPOSITION ONLY. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR OPPOSITION
TO AB FIFTY NINETY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE FALL BY ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION TO AB FIFTEEN NINETY
FOUR. AND ONE MOMENT THE
STRUCTURE WE ARE GIVING A NUMBER
OF PARTICIPANTS QUEUING UP.
BASIS MOMENTARILY. IT WILL BEGIN
WITH LINE THIRTY FIVE YOUR OPEN. NINE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I DO IT RIGHT THE
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION. YES
WE CAN GO AHEAD HELLO OKAY TO BE
IN REQUEST REGIONAL DIRECTOR OF
THE NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
BORDERLINE FORTY ONE YOU ARE
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS CAROL A
MEMBER OF THE NRA AND ITS
EUROPEAN ALLIES STRONGLY OPPOSE
FIFTY NINE FOUR. NINE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY FORTY
THREE ARE YOU MUTED. YES SORRY
SORRY ABOUT THAT MISTER CHAIR
THE STOMACH MAN ON THE CHAIR OF
THE SOUTH SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF
THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG OPPOSITION. FIND FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANKS FOR CALLING ON THE
MOBILE OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
ASSOCIATION- IN STRONG POSITION
SB FIFTEEN NINETY FOUR THANKS
VERY MUCH. NINE EIGHTY YOUR OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD THIS IS TAMMY
VAN BACK ON THE NUMBER OF
VENTURA COUNTY GUN OWNERS AND
ATTORNEY AND MOTHER OF TWO AND
I'M OPPOSED TO THIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU. SIX POINT. EIGHTY
TWO. MY NAME IS JAMES O'BRIEN
I'M A LIFELONG MEMBER OF THE NRA
AND MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. ONE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS PAT
HEARD AND I'M A LIFE MEMBER OF
THE NRA LIFE MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
TAMA COUNTY GUN OWNERS CHAPTER
OF THE CALIFORNIA REPLICAS TO
ASSOCIATION. AND RETIRED SURGEON
OF THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
AND I AM IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
AB FIFTEEN NINETY FOUR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ONE EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS MIKE ELLIOTT SOME A
MEMBER CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION INVENTOR COUNTY GUN
OWNERS I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. AS A FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
OPPOSITION TO AB FIFTEEN NINETY
FOUR POINT EIGHTY NINE YOU ARE
OPEN. THANK YOU- MY NAME IS
FRANK MCCARTHY I AM A MEMBER OF
THE BAND CHURCH VENTURA COUNTY
GUN OWNERS- FOR THE CALIFORNIA
RIGHT AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION.
AND A MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL
RIFLE ASSOCIATION OF WHICH
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WHY NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS RON LANDER I REPRESENT
THE RPA CHAPTER IN RIVERSIDE
CALIFORNIA RETIRED SERGEANT FROM
THE LA COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT I WOULD LIKE TO
OPPOSE. THIS BILL ALSO. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE EXHAUSTED THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
PRETTY MAKE CLOSE ALLIANCE OF
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SINGH
NATT VISITING YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I
STARTED WITH THE EXAMPLE OF SAN
FRANCISCO WE ONLY NEED THAT'S
OUR SENSE AFTER MEADOW- IN TERMS
OF MASS SHOOTINGS WE ONLY NEED
TO GO AROUND THE ROOM VERY
QUICKLY TO REMIND OURSELVES OF
ALL THE MASS SHOOTINGS THAT HAVE
OCCURRED JUST IN RECENT HISTORY
WHAT THE TO SAN JOSE AT MY
COLLEAGUES- BTA HEADQUARTERS
WITH A MASS SHOOTING WITH THE
GUNS AND THE AMMUNITION WERE
COMPLETELY OBTAINED LEGALLY. WE
HADN'T SAMPOERNA DINO A HORRIFIC
WORKPLACE SHOOTING. IN IN SAN
FRANCISCO A SHOOTING AT OUR UPS
FACILITY THESE WERE ALL FIREARMS
THAT WERE OBTAINED LEGALLY
FIREARMS ARE DESIGNED TO KILL
PEOPLE THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE GOING
TO DO. IT AGAIN WHILE THE
OPPOSITION LAID OUT IN LEGALESE
A LOT OF- VERY CONVOLUTED
MESSAGING HERE'S A SIMPLE FACT.
THIS INDUSTRY GETS PROTECTION
THAT NO OTHER INDUSTRY IN THE
UNITED STATES CATS. THIS THIS
BILL WILL JUST HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE LIKE EVERY OTHER
INDUSTRY GUNS ARE NOT CARS. THE
PURPOSE OF A GUN IS TO HARM
ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL. IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT A CAR WHERE WE'RE USING
IT TO TRANSPORT PEOPLE AND IN
FACT THIS IS HOLDING THE GUN
INDUSTRY TO THE SAME LIABILITY
THAT THE AUTO INDUSTRY WHAT HOLE
FOR THE TOY INDUSTRY OR ANY
OTHER INDUSTRY. THIS IS A VERY
REASONABLE BILL IT ALLOWS
INDIVIDUALS LIKE MISS LEAPS TO
TAKE MATTERS INTO THEIR OWN
HANDS WHICH IS- WHAT EVERY OTHER
AMERICAN AND ANY OTHER INDUSTRY
IS ALLOWED TO DO- IT'S A VERY
COMMON SENSE BILL TO ALLOW ALSO
CITIES TO TAKE ACTION SO THAT MY
CITY OR THE CITY OF SAN JOSE OR
THE CITY SAMPOERNA DINO OR NOW
THE CITY SACRAMENTO. COULD HAVE
TAKEN SOME CORRECTIVE ACTION
AGAIN WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
IT'S TIME TO ALLOW COMMUNITIES
TO PROTECT THEMSELVES IN AB
FIFTEEN NINETY FOUR DOES EXACTLY
THAT RESPECT AFTER ABOUT THANK
YOU THANK YOU ASSISTING WE WILL
TAKE IT UP ONCE WE HAVE COR
THANK. YOU I WILL MOVE TO OUR
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT MISTER SMITH. GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE. FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL AND
ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS AS WE'VE
BEEN DISCUSSED. I BELIEVE THIS
BILL AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED.
DOES WHAT'S NEEDED TO HELP CURB
THE ILLICIT MARKET IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. OPPONENTS OF THIS
BILL ARGUED THAT A MARKET FOR
CANNABIS IN CALIFORNIA IS TOO
STRONG. THE POTENTIAL PROFITS TO
BE MADE OR TWO GREAT. FOR THE
PROPOSED FINES IN THIS
LEGISLATION TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT
DENTS IN THE ILLICIT MARKET.
HOWEVER I BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE
MISUNDERSTOOD THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL WHICH IS TO INCENTIVIZE
COMPLIANCE. AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT DOES INCREASE THE
COST BURDEN OF FINE SIGNIFICAN
GOOD LUCK SIGNIFICANTLY. IN ANY
OPERATION THAT CHOOSES TO REMAIN
IN NONCOMPLIANCE WILL HAVE TO
SHOULDER THOSE COST. HOWEVER THE
BILL OFFERS AN AMNESTY PERIOD OF
TWO WEEKS THAT ALLOWS
INDIVIDUALS A CHANCE TO PAY THE
PERMIT FEE. AND THEN COME INTO
COMPLIANCE. THIS BILL IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TO FIXING THE
PITFALLS OF THE LEGALIZATION AND
ENSURE THAT THE LEGAL INDUSTRY
CAN THRIVE IN CALIFORNIA. ON THE
PHONE I HAVE BRAD JENSEN WITH
THE SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY.
FOLLOWED BY LIEUTENANT MARC
MOROCCO WITH THE SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
THANK YOU I DO HAVE THOSE TWO
WITNESSES BRED JENSEN ARE YOU
WITH US ON THE TELEPHONE. IF I
AM GOOD MORNING. I'M BRAD JENSEN
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS FOR SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY WHICH IS THE SPONSOR OF
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT.
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY LIKE MANY
PARTS OF THE STATE IS STRUGGLING
WITH WIDESPREAD ILLEGAL CANNABIS
FARMING. WE CURRENTLY ESTIMATE
WE HAVE OVER THIRTEEN HUNDRED
ILLEGAL FARMS IN THE MOJAVE
DESERT SOME ESTIMATES ARE AS
HIGH AS TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED. WE
BELIEVE THAT AN INCREASE IN THE
FINES FOR ILLEGAL CANNABIS
ACTIVITY WOULD ACT AS BOTH A
DETERRENT TO ILLEGAL ACTIVITY
AND AN INCENTIVE TO COMPLY WITH
THE LAW. WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE AMENDMENTS TO STREAMLINE THE
FINE STRUCTURE WHILE INCLUDING
AN AMNESTY PERIOD TO ALLOW THOSE
WHO HAVE BEEN FIND. TIME TO
OBTAIN A PERMIT. PART OF THE
CHALLENGE OF ILLEGAL CANNABIS IS
DETERRING ILLEGAL ACTIVITY WHILE
STRENGTHENING THE LEGAL MARKET.
THERE ARE MANY LEGAL CANNABIS
BUSINESS OWNERS TO OBTAIN
PERMITS. FOLLOWED STATE AND
LOCAL REGULATIONS. TO PAY THEIR
TAXES AND OBEY THE LAW. AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
ADVANCE IS A SENSIBLE POLICY
THAT WILL SUPPORT LEGAL CANNABIS
BUSINESSES. WILL HELP DETER
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY AND ENCOURAGE
MORE COMPLIANCE WITH STATE LAW.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND THEN. MARK
BRACCO. YES GOOD MORNING- MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
I MARK BROKEN LIEUTENANT GENERAL
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
KINGS NARCOTICS DIVISION- ONE OF
MY DUTIES AS I'M OVERSEEING- ALL
OF THE- MARIJUANA SUPPRESSION ON
TOP OF OUR OTHER- NARCOTICS
TEAMS OVERDOSE RESPONSE I'M HERE
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT. I WANTED TO
PICK OUT A FEW POINTS THE
CURRENT FINE STRUCTURE FOR
ILLEGAL CULTIVATION AND NON
COMPLIANCE ARE NOT EFFECTIVE IN
COMBATING THIS PROBLEM- THE
ILLEGAL CANNABIS MARKET IS
SURGING AND HEART COUNTY- SAMBAR
DINO. WERE ALSO ORGANIZED SISTER
AND BROTHER COUNTIES OF
RIVERSIDE AND LOS ANGELES ARE
SAYING THE SAME ISSUES- THE
WHOLE STATE ARE NOT EVEN- JUST
CALIFORNIA. OREGON WASHINGTON OR
DEALING WITH THE SAME PROBLEMS
WITH THESE ILLEGAL CULTIVATION
SITES. OTHER INDOOR AND OUTDOOR
- ARE. SHERIFF DEPARTMENT TEAMS.
HAVE MADE IT TO DIFFERENT
ATTEMPTS WITH LARGE SCALE
OPERATIONS THAT ARE MULTI MONTH
THAT DEPARTMENT. ADULT
DEPLOYMENT RESOURCE HEAVY- WE'RE
CURRENTLY DOING OPERATION HAMMER
STRIKE WHICH WAS- SUPPOSED TO BE
A TWELVE MONTH OPERATION BUT NOW
IT'S LOOKING LIKE IT'S GONNA BE
EIGHTEEN. WE ADDED ADDITIONAL-
DEPUTIES AND CIVILIAN PERSONNEL
OVER TWENTY TO THE DIVISION TO
DEAL WITH THE ILLEGAL
CULTIVATION. THAT'S ALL THEY DO
FIVE DAYS A WEEK IS HANDLE THE
SEARCH WARRANT SERVICE AND
DESTRUCTION OF THE ILLEGAL
CANNABIS- OVER THE LAST EIGHT
MONTHS THAT THIS OPERATION'S
BEEN GOING WE'VE ALREADY SEIZED
OVER ONE MILLION AND PRODUCT-
AND A HUNDRED TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND POUNDS OF PROCESSED
ILLEGAL CANNABIS. AND WE'VE
ALREADY CREATED OVER FIVE
THOUSAND GREENHOUSE GROWERS-
CLOSED ABOUT FIFTY INDOOR GROWS
AT RESIDENTIAL SITES- THE TOTAL
PRODUCT OVER THIS EIGHT MONTH
PROGRAM WE'VE SEIZED IT IS OVER
SIX HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AND THAT'S AT A
WHOLESALE VALUE. NOT EVEN GOING
TO WHAT THAT VALUE WOULD HAVE
BEEN WORTH IT A LEGAL- LOCATION
- IT WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT AS A
RECONFIGURED THE FINES- FOR
THESE ILLEGAL ACTIVITIES- TO BE
FOUR TIMES THE COST OF THE
PERMITS IT ALSO PROVIDES SOME
AMNESTY BY ALLOWING DEPARTMENT
OF CANNABIS CONTROL. TO WAIVE
FINES IF THE PENALIZED
INDIVIDUALS APPLIED- OBTAINS OR
COMMERCIAL LICENSING. AND
COMPLIES WITH THE LAWS. TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY IT ALSO ACTS GOOD
STATE POLICY UNDER THIS BILL THE
CAMPUS OPERATIONS MAKING
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
PER YEAR. WILL NOT BE ALLOWED TO
SHRUG OFF FIND IN A WAY THAT
THEY DO RIGHT NOW- IT OCCURRED
IT WILL ENCOURAGE COMPLIANCE
WITH THE STATE LAW- JUST A-
COUPLE OTHER AND- NOTES ON THIS-
THESE LEGAL SITE FOR OUR
DEPUTIES HAVE BEEN SHOT AT- BOTH
OF THESE- THREE INCIDENTS TO OF-
THE- SUBJECTS CANTONESE GROWS.
DOT ARE THAT THEY WERE JUST AT
PEOPLE DON'T RELY THERE SHOULD
AT THE COPS WHICH IS EVEN MORE-
SCARY TO DEAL WITH FOR OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS- CIRCLE.
AROUND THE COMMUNITY BEING
IMPACTED. YES I'M FINISHING UP
OUR WORLD COMMUNITY IS BEING-
WATER THEFT IN THE WATER LETTER
LEVELS BEING IMPACTED- BY HAVING
TO RE DRILL WELLS THAT COST
THEM- TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS TO DEAL WITH THAT- I'M
JUST SIR- URGING THE SUPPORT OF
AB. TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU GUYS FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU. RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT TO AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT. ALL
RIGHT SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD
YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE
SUPPORT FOR A BI. TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT AGAIN WILL TAKE
NAME AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT.
PLEASE BREAK TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONE FILED BY ZERO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT FOR AB. TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT. MISTER CHAIR
NOBODY'S QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE
THEN TO OPPOSITION I DO NOT HAVE
ANY LISTED OPPOSITION. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT. I HATE SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANY OPPOSITION TO AB.
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT. YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NOW MISTER
CHAIR NOBODY QUEUEING UP AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT HANK YOU ARE PRE
MAKE CLOSE THE LINES OF BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MS REYES. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
I'M VERY PLEASED THAT YOU HAVE
BROUGHT THIS BILL FORWARD. I
APPRECIATE ALL THE EFFORTS OF
SOMEBODY- COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IN THE WORK THEY HAVE
DONE. TO TRY TO STOP THE- THE
ILLEGAL- INDUSTRY IT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS LEGAL AND
SOMETHING THAT- THERE IS AN
OUTLET AND- THE FACT THAT THIS
ENCOURAGES COMPLIANCE IS ONE OF
THE WITNESSES TALKED ABOUT. THE
INCENTIVE TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE I THINK IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THAT THE AMNESTY
PERIOD AND THE- RECOMMENDATION
FROM THE COMMITTEE ABOUT
STREAMLINING THE PROCESS I THINK
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AS WELL
SO I DO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD. THANK YOU OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. RIGHT THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU MRS FOR TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS I AM CONCERNS
SINCE WE HAVE. VERY RESPONSES
COUNTY BY COUNTY TO THE
LEGALIZATION OF CANNABIS AND
SOME COUNTIES ARE UNWILLING TO
ALLOW. FOR GROWTH OTHERWISE
LEGAL GROSS I THINK WE NEED THEM
WITH THE AMENDMENTS ARE INTENDED
TO DO IS. DISTINGUISH BETWEEN
WHAT ARE. WOULD BE CONSIDERED
ILLEGAL GROWS THAT WAS STANDING
LAW VERSUS WHAT JUST A COUNTY
WHO IS UNWILLING TO ALLOW OR
CITY AND WILLING TO ALLOW. GROSS
WOULD CONSIDER ILLEGAL GROWS AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO GET OUT HERE SO. THANK YOU
AND WITH THAT YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- FOR THE
DISCUSSION. IT WHEN YOU GET A
QUORUM I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU FOR. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL MOVE TO OUR ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY
MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BERS.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT A. B. TWENTY TWO SIXTY.
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE CERTAIN-PUBLIC AND PRIVATE BUILDINGS
CONSTRUCTED AFTER JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TO INSTALL
AND MAINTAIN SIX TRAUMA KITS ON
THEIR PREMISES IN ORDER TREAT
PEOPLE IN NEED OF AN- EMERGENCY
MEDICAL CARE. DURING A DRAMATIC
EMERGENCY EVENT. IN RESPONSE TO
THE TRAGIC MASS SHOOTING AT
SANDY HOOK ELEMENTARY SCHOOL A
GROUP OF DOCTORS CONVENE A PANEL
OF NATIONAL EXPERTS FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND BURNT YOU
MEDICAL SERVICE SERVICES. TO
CREATE IMPROVED RESPONSE SYSTEM
DIRECTED PRIMARILY AT THE
CONTROL OF LIFE THREATENING
BLOOD LOSS. IN THE
RECOMMENDATION THE GROUP OF
EXPERTS CONCLUDED THAT
BYSTANDERS IMMEDIATE RESPONDER
SHOULD BE TRAINED AND EMPOWERED
TO STOP EMERGED IN ORDER TO SAVE
LIVES. THESE EXPERTS ALSO
RECOMMEND A TRAUMA KITS BE
PLACED IN PUBLIC PLACES SUCH AS
SHOPPING MALLS SCHOOLS SPORTS
VENUES TRANSPORTATION CENTERS
EXEDRA RIGHT NEXT TO EIGHTIES.
RECOGNIZING DIFFICULT TO
MAINTAIN DIRECT PRESSURE THEY
ALSO RECOMMENDED THE USE OF
TOURNIQUETS TO CONTROL SEVERE
BLEEDING. WITH MASS CASUALTY
EVENTS BECOMING MORE COMMON IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN PRESIDENT OBAMA
LAUNCHED STOP THE BLEED
CAMPAIGN. TO ENCOURAGE
BYSTANDERS TO BECOME TRAINED AND
EMPOWERED TO TAKE FLIGHTS. JONES
WHAT YOU MISS PERSON. IN ROUTE.
SACRAMENTO LIKE COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY IS NO
STRANGER TO THESE DRAMATIC
EVENTS THE LAST TWO MONTHS HAVE
BEEN STE TWO MASS SHOOTINGS THAT
HAVE TAKEN THE LIVES OF INNOCENT
VICTIMS. DURING THE TRAGIC
EVENTS PERSON SUFFERING FROM
SEVERE BLOOD LOSS CAN DIE WITHIN
FIVE MINUTES SO EVERY SECOND
COUNTS THAT IS WHY IT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE OUR MEDIA
RESPONDERS. HAVE THE
INSTRUCTIONS AND EQUIPMENT
NEEDED SAVE TO RENDER EMERGENCY
CARE AT THE SCENE OF AN
EMERGENCY. RECENT AMENDMENTS
CLARIFIES HOW THIS BILL. APPLIES
TO THE GOOD SAMARITAN LAW AND
WHICH SHOULD BE PROPERLY MANAGED
INTO THE RESTOCKING REPLACE
EQUIPMENT AMONG OTHER THINGS.
BEFORE I INTRODUCED MY WITNESSES
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE SUPPORTERS
AND STAKEHOLDERS WHAT WORKED
DILIGENTLY. ON THE BILL
INCLUDING THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF SURGEONS CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE AND THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
FOR THEIR SYSTEMS. TO ADDRESS
THIS LIABILITY CONCERNS WITH THE
PREVIOUS VERSIONS OF THE BLL.
WHAT'S HERE TO MEET TODAY TO
PROVIDE IN PERSON TESTIMONY THIS
DOCTOR AMY LIKE PART A TRAUMA
SURGEON WITH THE U. S. C. SAN
DIEGO HEALTH AND DR THOMAS
DUNCAN WHO IS ALSO A TRAUMA-SURGEON WITH THE VENT VENTURA
COUNTY MEDICAL CENTER. THANK YOU
THANK YOU THE FIRST WITNESS
WITH. A GOOD MORNING I THANK THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE FOR THE
PRIVILEGE OF ADDRESSING HERE I
AM DOCTOR IN DELIBERATE ABOARD A
DOUBLE BOARD CERTIFIED TRAUMA
SURGEON AT LEVEL ONE TRAUMA
CENTER AT THE UNIVERSITY. OF SAN
DIEGO I REPRESENT THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF SURGEONS TODAY THE
THREE CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF SURGEONS AND
MYSELF. LIFE THREATENING KIND
ANYWHERE YOUR HOME THE WORK
PLACE IN PUBLIC PLACES INVOLVING
TRAFFIC ACCIDENTS AND YES EVEN
MASS TRAUMA EVENTS. IT CAN BE
ACCIDENTAL. INTENTIONAL OR FROM
NATURAL DISASTER NOT UNLIKE AN
UNPREDICTABLE HEART ATTACK AND
CARDIAC ARREST THAT MUST BE
ADDRESSED WITH CPR TRAINING. AND
EIGHTY D. EQUIPMENT. CONTROL
TRAINING IN TRAUMA KITS MUST
ALSO BE READILY AVAILABLE TO
ADDRESS LIFE THREATENING
HEMORRHAGE IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
THE STOP THE BLEED PROGRAM WAS
DEVELOPED BY THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF SURGEONS AND
COSPONSORED BY THE WHITE HOUSE
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY. AND THIS MADE THIS
POSSIBLE. THESE NATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS THE NATIONAL
GOVERNMENT HAVE RECOGNIZE THE
POSITIVE IMPACT OF TRAINING AND
THE AVAILABILITY OF THIS NON
EXPIRED LIQUID MEANT AND WHAT IT
CAN HAVE ON THE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND THE LIFESAVING ABILITY OF
OUR NEIGHBORS. FAMILY MEMBERS
AND COWORKERS. THE INJURED
BLEEDING PATIENT MUST SURVIVE
LONG ENOUGH TO GET TO A TRAUMA
CENTER SO WE CAN TREAT THEM
BEFORE THEY HAVE LET OUT. AN
ADULT COMPLETED DEATH WITHIN
FIVE MINUTES THAT'S BEFORE
MERGING SEE MEDICAL SERVICES CAN
ARRIVE. BLEEDING CAN BE TREATED
WITH EASY TO USE TOOLS AND THE
PUBLIC CAN BE TRAINED IT
CONTAINS SIMPLE EQUIPMENT GLOVES
AND A MASK. TRAUMA SHEARS WHICH
ARE SIMPLY SAYS- THAT ARE BLUNT
TIPPED IN SAFE. AND GAUZE
PACKING AND A TOURNIQUET. THERE
ARE NO EXPIRATION DATES ON THIS
EQUIPMENT AS REQUIRED BY AB TWO
TWO SIX ZERO. THE TOURNIQUET
SIMPLY MUST BE A STANDARDIZED
QUALITY TO ENSURE ITS
EFFECTIVENESS. EDUCATION TO THE
PUBLIC IS WIDESPREAD IN FREE. AN
EXISTING CALIFORNIA LAW EXEMPTS
ANYONE WHO PROVIDES EMERGENCY
ASSISTANCE FROM CIVIL LIABILITY.
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT SPONSOR SUPPORT OR TRAIN
PEOPLE ARE ALSO EXEMPT FROM
THESE ARE ALLEGATIONS UP. CIVIL
ALLEGATIONS. CALIFORNIA HAS LED
THE EFFORT TO REQUIRE EIGHTIES.
AVAILABILITY OF BLEEDING CONTROL
KITS ALSO MAKES THESE TOOLS.
ACCESSIBLE TO SAVE LIVES.
KEEPING THEM NEAR AD'S REDUCED
INSTALLATION COSTS AND THE COST
IS MINIMAL JUST 15% OF WHAT
EIGHT ONE AIDE THE INSTALLATION
AS- EACH KIT SUCH AS THIS IS
ABOUT FORTY DOLLARS- AND COLD-
THAT- IS LESS THAN TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLARS FOR ALL SIX KIDS
REQUIRED IN THE BILL. PUBLISHED
STUDY HAS CHAU TOURNIQUET USING
L. A. COUNTY. DECREASED IN
HOSPITAL DEATH RATE FROM 9% DOWN
21% WHEN THAT TOURNIQUETS WERE
USED PRIOR TO TRANSPORT TO THE
HOSPITAL. SURVEYS ALSO SHOW THAT
THE GENERAL PUBLIC SUPPORTS THE
AVAILABILITY OF THESE KIDS. AND
THAT THEY WILL PARTICIPATE IN
THE LIFE. OF TO SAVE A LIFE
PARTICULARLY WHEN THERE'S POP
PROTECTIVE GEAR SUCH AS GLOVES
AND MASKS. AND EQUIPMENT SUCH AS
GAUZE OR THE TOURNIQUET ARE
AVAILABLE TO THEM. THE
WIDESPREAD AVAILABILITY OF THESE
TOOLS THESE TECHNIQUES WILL SAVE
MORE LIVES IN RESULT IN LESS
BLOOD TRANSFUSION. I URGE YOU TO
VOTE YES ON AB TWO TWO SIX ZERO
FOR BLEEDING CONTROL KITS. TO
MEET AVAIL A TO BE MADE
AVAILABLE WHERE THEY ARE NEEDED.
IN THE COMMUNITY TO SAVE LIVES
AND TO STOP THE BLEED. THANK YOU
THAT'S WHAT HIS PLANS. GOOD
MORNING AND THANK YOU TO DISHES
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY NAME IS
DR THOMAS DUNCAN I'M TO TRAUMA
MEDICAL DIRECTOR VENTURA COUNTY
MEDICAL CENTER AN AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF SURGEONS ADULT LEVEL
TWO TRAUMA CENTER. TODAY I ALSO
REPRESENT THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF SURGEONS AND THREE OF ITS
AFFILIATED CHAPTERS THIS BILL
HAS WIDE SUPPORT INCLUDING BUT
NOT LIMITED TO MULTI
DISCIPLINARY STATE AND NATIONAL
SURGICAL ORGANIZATIONS THE CAT
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND CALIFORNIA NURSES IT ALSO
HAS GENERAL SUPPORT FROM MANY
FIRE POLICE AND EMS. NOW
ACTUALLY BURDEN NARI ARE GOING
TO GIVE YOU A BRIEF
DEMONSTRATION AN OVERVIEW OF THE
APPROACHABILITY OF THE
TECHNIQUES BY DEMONSTRATING
WON'T PACK IN AND TRYING TO GET
A APPLICATION. THE CIVICS ARE
COVERED IN THE STOP THE BLEED
FREE TRAINING SESSIONS AND
PICTORIAL INSTRUCTIONS ARE
INCLUDED AND ALL STOP THE BLEED.
TRAUMA KITS COURSES OFTEN TAUGHT
IN HIGH SCHOOLS TO STUDENTS AND
ARE GENERALIZED TO THE PUBLIC.
THERE ARE TWO MAIN TECHNIQUES
WON'T PACK IN WITHHOLDING
PRESSURE AND IF NECESSARY
TOURNIQUET PLACEMENT. RECENT
STUDIES HAVE NOT DEMONSTRATED
ANY ADVERSE EFFECTS OF INJURY OR
LIMB LOSS FROM TOURNIQUET USE
AND EITHER COMBAT OR CIVILIAN
ENVIRONMENTS. AWORI NOW
RELEGATED TO HISTORY. ROBUST
TRAINING AS TAUGHT BY THE STOP
THE BLEED CURRICULUM SUPPORTS
SURVIVAL AND TRANSPORT TO TRAUMA
CENTERS THAT CAN THEN ADDRESS
THE INJURY AND SAVE LIVES.
ESTRADA'S SURGEONS WE KNOW THE
PATIENT MUST BE ALIVE FOR US TO
INNOVATE THESE SIMPLE TECHNIQUES
ALLOW MORE PATIENTS TO HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY. HELP US STOP THE
BLEED VOTE TO ADVANCE AB TWENTY
TWO SIXTY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
TWO SIXTY WILL TAKE NAME
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT NO
FURTHER TESTIMONY THANK YOU. I
J. DOUCETTE I'M CHIEF OF TRAUMA
AT UC SAN DIEGO- ALSO GOVERNOR
IN THE CHAPTERS AMERICOLD
RESURGENCE AND A THREE TIME
AFGHANISTAN VETERAN. AND I GIVE
A VERY STRONG SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY TWO SIXTY. I'M ALEXANDER
JOHNS I'M A GENERAL SURGERY
RESIDENT HERE IN SACRAMENTO AT
UC DAVIS AND I GIVE MY STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY.
CHRIS JOHNSON MANAGER STATE
AFFAIRS FOR THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF SURGEONS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN ALLIANCE FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
TWO SIXTY. THANK YOU IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
TO AB. TWENTY TWO SIXTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. SECURE WILL BEGIN
WITH LINE FORTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD FORTY TWO. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS RECTANGLE
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN NURSES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT. LINE TWELVE YOU
ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CORNY DELGADO
ON BEHALF OF THE EMERGENCY
NURSES ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. THE FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTY ONE OF MANY MANY CLINICAL
AT. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRANDON
MARCHING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIR THERE'S NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU OPERATOR WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION I DO
NOT HAVE ANY OPPOSITION LISTED
THERE ANY OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTY. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS REX W. HYMAN CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
I JUST WANT TO TAKE THE TIME WE
WERE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
BEFORE WE HAD A GREAT TIME
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
STAFF WE REALLY APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE. AND
WE WOULD LIKE TO FORMALLY REMOVE
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE. RIGHT SIGNAL
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANY OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY TWO SIXTY. EXPRESSED
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE FALL BY ZERO.
MISTER CHAIR NOBODY'S QUEUING UP
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU OPERATOR YOU
MAY CLOSE THE LINES WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE THIS RODRIGUEZ YOU MAY
CLOSE. WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK GOD THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR SUPPORT WHEN YOU DO HAVE A
QUORUM AS YOU CAN SEE IN MY HAND
AS A KID ROUGHLY ABOUT FORTY
DOLLARS WITH THIS WOULD SAVE
SOMEONE'S LIFE FOR THE TIME
EVER- BECOMES NEEDED WITHOUT
URGING ME OUT FOR A VOTE. THANK
YOU. WE WILL TAKE IT UP ONCE WE
HAVE A CORE THANK YOU. MR
MEDINA. ARE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN A.
B. EIGHTEEN FORTY FOUR.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING. THANK
YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS TODAY I'M
PRESENTING A. B. EIGHTEEN FORTY
FOUR WHICH STRENGTHENS THE
ACCOUNTABILITY TRANSPARENCY AND
INVESTIGATION. OF SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT UNDER TITLE NINE. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO THE UNITED
STATES PASSED TITLE NINE OF
FEDERAL LAW THAT PROHIBITS SEX
OR GENDER BASED DISCRIMINATION
HARASSMENT OR ASSAULT IN
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS AND
ACTIVITIES THAT INSTITUTION.
MOREOVER IT REQUIRES
INSTITUTIONS TO TAKE NECESSARY
STEPS TO PREVENT SEX BASED
DISCRIMINATION HARASSMENT OR
ASSAULT ON THEIR CAMPUSES.
ACROSS EVERY CAMPUS A TITLE NINE
COURTNEY IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
RECEIVING REPORTS OF AN
OVERSEEING INVESTIGATIONS
RELATED TO SEXUAL ASSAULT
HARASSMENT STALKING AND ABUSIVE
RELATIONSHIPS. EVEN WITH THE
RECENT UPDATES TO TITLE NINE THE
PROCESS TO REPORT VIOLATIONS
RELIES SOLELY UPON SURVIVORS
BILLING BEING WILLING TO SHARE
THEIR EXPERIENCE WHICH FOR MANY
REPRESENTS A BARRIER TO JUSTICE.
IN RECENT YEARS UNITED STATES
OFFICE OF CIVIL RIGHTS HAS
PENED FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE CASES PERTAINING TO
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES MIS
HANDLING REPORTS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT. AND DISCRIMINATION.
ACCORDING TO RESEARCH BY THE
CHRONICLE OF HIGHER EDUCATION
ONLY SEVENTY FIVE OF THOSE CASES
HAVE BEEN RESOLVED. AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY FOUR CREATES A
COMPREHENSIVE OVERSIGHT PROCESS
OF EMPLOYEES AT PUBLIC COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES SPECIFICALLY.
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTION IS
AWARE OF ANY PENDING OR%
COMPLETED INVESTIGATIONS OF
MISCONDUCT WHEN HIRING AN
APPLICANT FOR POSITION. MOREOVER
REQUIRES INSTITUTIONS TO SHARE
RECORDS OF PREVIOUS EMPLOYEES
WHO'VE BEEN FORMALLY
INVESTIGATED AND FOUND VIA THE
TITLE MY PROCESS TO HAVE
COMMITTED SEXUAL MISCONDUCT OR
OF GONE THROUGH THE INFORMAL
RESOLUTION PROCESS. FINALLY A.
B. EIGHTEEN FORTY FOUR
ESTABLISHES POSITIONS ON
CAMPUSES TO ADVISE AND SUPPORT
INDIVIDUALS WHO'VE EXPERIENCED
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND MISCONDUCT
ON CAMPUS. I AM PLEASED TO HAVE
INTRODUCED AMENDMENTS IN THIS
COMMITTEE WHICH ALLEVIATE
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL
ESPECIALLY IN REGARDS TO
LIABILITY FOR INSTITUTIONS AND
FALSE REPORT OF EMPLOYEES. AB
EIGHTEEN FORTY FOUR THAT'S FOR
FILLS THE INTENT OF TITLE NINE
BY STAB WISHING ADDITIONAL
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
AND STRENGTHENING SUPPORTS SO
SURVIVORS FEEL SAFE TO REPORT
INCIDENTS OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
WHICH HOPEFULLY WILL LEAD TO A
SAFER CAMPUS FOR ALL. THANK YOU
SO JUST FOR CLARITY YOUR TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS LISTED IN THE
ANALYSIS IS AUTHORS OF THEM I AM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. RIGHT I DO
NOT HAVE ANY WITNESSES LISTED.
SO IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY FOUR. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
STILL THIS LEADS SHAUN BEHALF OF
THE OVER TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
FACULTY STAFF COACHES AND
LIBRARIANS OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
THE HEARING ROOM IN SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT SEE NONE OPERATOR WOULD
YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR ANY
SUPPORT FOR AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI EIGHTEEN FORTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE FALL BY ZERO FOR
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTEEN FORTY FOUR
NINE THIRTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR TERROR AND
MEMBERS KATHY VAN OFTEN
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING TEN
THOUSAND WOMEN ACROSS THE STATE.
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE. THANK YOU. Y. AND ONE
OH FIVE. BUT THEY SHOULD BE WITH
US ONE MOMENT MISTER CHAIR THE
OPERATORS WITH SOME. ANYBODY
ELSE GOING HIT ONES THAT
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. TESTIFIED FOR
ITS SUPPORT FOR A BI FORTY
EIGHTEEN FORTY FOUR AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE ONE OH FIVE YOU ARE
OPEN. GOOD MORNING TERRY MEMBERS
THIS IS SHANNON THOMPSON WITH
THE CAL STATE SENATE THIRTY SEMI
OFFICIAL VOICE AND CSU STUDENT
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND
THERE ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
CUED UP MR CARE THANK YOU
OPERATOR WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I DO NOT HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION LISTED IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
FOUR. SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD
YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR ANY
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TO.
SHOW OPPOSITION TO AB AT FORTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME WHEN FALL BY ZERO.
NOBODY SPOKE ONE FIST IS QUEUING
UP ONE MOMENT WILL BE WITH US
MOMENTARILY. AGAIN FOR
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE OH THREE
YOUR OPEN ONE OF THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THREE MY NAME IS GREG IN
DOLLARS AND THE LEGISLATIVE
FELLOW WITH THE FOUNDATION FOR
INDIVIDUAL INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS IN
EDUCATION WE AREOPPOSED AND
MATHEMATICS. THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING UP.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU OPERATOR YOU
MAY CLOSE THE LINES AND WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. CIGNA
SOME MEDIA YOU MAY COSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE WHEN SHE HAVE A CORE THANK
YOU WANT TO A QUORUM WE WILL.
TAKE IT UP THANK YOU THANK YOU
MEDINA. RIGHT SEEING NO OTHER
AUTHORS OTHER THAN FOLKS WERE
HERE MISTER LEE ARE YOU READY TO
PRESENT ALL RIGHT WE'LL TAKE UP
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY
FIFTY. HELLO GOOD MORNING
MORNING SHARE MEMBERS I'M
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIFTY THIS BILL SEEKS TO PREVENT
SPECULATIVE ACTIONS BY REQUIRING
A FIVE YEARS OF PROPERTY
OWNERSHIP BEFORE THE ELLIS ACT
CAN BE INVOKED THE ALSO ACT WAS
ORIGINALLY PASSED TO ALLOW MOM
AND POP LANDLORDS LEAVE THE
RENTAL HOUSING BUSINESS. WITHOUT
SOME THEIR PROPERTY I CREATING A
FIVE YEAR HOLDING PERIOD BEFORE
THE ELSE THAT CAN BE INVOKED
ARBIL CONTINUES TO RESPECT LONG
TERM LANDLORDS WHO HAVE BEEN IN
THIS BUSINESS FOR DECADES IN
THIS VERSION OF THE BILL.
FOOTBOARD AMENDMENTS THAT
CLARIFY THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT
APPLY TO MOM AND POP LANDLORDS.
WHO MAY MANAGE A PROPERTY WITH
THE L. C. OR TRUST. THE GOAL OF
THIS BILLS TO PREVENT THE ABUSE
OF PROPERTY SPECULATOR MOVING
FOR BILLION ITS FOR PROFIT. IF
AB TWENTY FIFTY SIGNED INTO LAW
LATER THIS YEAR ANYONE WHO HAS
OWNED THE PROPERTY FROM TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND PRIOR. CAN STILL
USE THE ELLIS ACT EXIT RENTAL
BUSINESS TOO OFTEN MANY TENANTS
IN RENT STABILIZED UNITS LIVE IN
CONSTANT FEAR THAT THEY'RE
BUILDING WILL BE SOLD TO THE
HIGHEST BIDDER. AND BE SUBJECT
IN A FICTIONAL AFTER. I THINK
THIS BILL WILL A CRUCIAL
STABILISING EFFECT WHEN RENTERS
WILL NOT HAVE TO WORRY- THE
WORRY THAT A NEW OWNER IS GOING
TO EVICT THEM WITHIN MONTHS OF
CLOSING ESCROW. SINCE
200-012-7000 UNITS IN LOS
ANGELES ALONE HAVE BEEN TAKEN
OFF RENTAL MARKET USING THE
ELLIS ACT. DISPLACING OVER SIXTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE. CONTINUE TO BE
SO THEY ALSO ACT DOES NOT
PRODUCE HOUSING. THE PRODUCES
DISPLACEMENT. AND WORSENS OUR
HOUSING CRISIS BY ALLOWING REAL
ESTATE SPECULATORS A PROFIT
MOTIVE TO REMOVE AFFORDABLE
UNITS. FROM FROM THE HOUSING
STOCK. DURING OUR PLAN PRESIDENT
DOCTOR ARE UNPRECEDENTED
UNPRECEDENTED HOUSING CRISIS WE
MUST INCLUDE DEFENSIVE MEASURES
AGAINST DISPLACEMENT AND
HOMELESSNESS. THE BILL BEFORE
TODAY'S A GUARDRAIL GET SMART
ACTIONS AND MORE PEOPLE LOSING
THE ROOF OVER THE HEADS. OF
STRICTLY AFTER I'VE OPENED TODAY
I'M JOINED BY BRIAN AUGUSTA. THE
C. R. L. A. FOUNDATION AND ON
THE PHONE WITH WILL HAVE ARCHIE
SYLVESTER WHO IS IMPACTED
RESIDENT OF ELLIS ACT EVICTIONS.
THANK YOU THE FIRST WITNESS HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
BEHIND A GUEST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION. PART OF A
COALITION OF TENANT GROUPS
SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE. THE
AUTHOR IS LAID OUT THE NEED FOR
THE BILL VERY WELL I'LL JUST
NOTE THAT. WITH RESPECT TO THE
L. ATTACKED AS ORIGINALLY
ENACTED THE PURPOSE WAS TO ALLOW
A LANDLORD WHO HAS BEEN IN THE
RENTAL HOUSING BUSINESS. TO HAVE
A MECHANISM TO EXIT THE RENTAL
HOUSING BUSINESS NOTWITHSTANDING
LOCAL. LOCALLY ENACTED
RESTRICTIONS ON GOING OUT OF THE
RENTAL HOUSING BUSINESS BY
AFFECTING ALL OF THE EXISTING
TENANTS THAT IS DISTINCT FROM A.
B. SPECULATOR PURCHASES AN
ONGOING RENTAL PROPERTY
IMMEDIATELY DECLARES THEIR
INTENT TO ACCEPT THE RENTAL
HOUSING MARKET THAT WAS NOT. THE
INTENT OF ALICE. THIS BILL
PROVIDES A REASONABLE LIMIT ON
THAT ACTIVITY. WHILE STILL
PRESERVING THE ABILITY OF THE
LANDLORDS TO EXIT THE RENTAL
MARKET AND WHEN WE- THE
DISCUSSION ABOUT PRIOR VERSION
OF THIS BILL ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HEARD WAS THAT IT WOULD
IMPACT MOM AND POP LANDLORDS WHO
MAY WANT TO MOVE INTO THE UNITS.
THIS BILL NOW ADDRESSES THAT
CONCERN AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE
THINK IT'S A REASONABLE.
CLARIFICATION OF ELLIS THAT WILL
PROTECT TENANTS FROM
DISPLACEMENT AND WE WOULD URGE
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. AND THEN
ARCHIE SYLVESTER ON THE
TELEPHONE ARE YOU WITH US. SO GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THANKS OXYGEN
ASSIGNMENTS- CONSISTENT. BONTA
IT SHOULD BE CONSISTENT NAMAN
WITH NEED TWENTY EIGHT NINE
HUNDRED AND SOME WILL BE YOU.
REVIEWS THE AMOUNT. WILL BE AND
IT'S NOT SO LONG. I'M NOT SAYING
THAT THIS CONCERT DURING MY
MIDDLE.
IN NINETEEN SIXTIES MCCORKLE
CERVANTES HUNDRED ONE. HUNDRED
POINTS THIS IS ONE JUST A
HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT YEARS OLD
CHILDREN ARE NOT GOING TO
SMOKING AND EATING EVEN CALLING
ON THE CONTRACT. ONE WEEKS
ALMOST AND WE- THE TECHNICIAN
PROTECTION SPANO. RUSSIAN
IMMIGRANT JEANS AND MATTEUCCI
NEED JUST NOT ONLY SOME THE
STOCK. ONE NOT GOING TO NOW IN
ADDITION. PUBLIC FROM.
COMPARATIVELY MODEST SALARY IN
THE WILL BE PUSHED ALMOST FIFTY
NINETY DESPITE SOMETHING ST.
MOST THAT REQUIRES MONEY TO
DOCTORS SCHOOLS WILL BE
DESTROYED. IT'S AN ONGOING ISSUE
NOW WITH COUNSEL NEEDS BE.
SOMETIMES. IT'S NOT. THE SIMPLE
THE STORE WOMAN WHO COMES IN A
LITTLE BIT AND MAKING TENANTS
FROM WHO MADE MY NIGHT.
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS PLEASE
PLEASE YEAH AB TWO EIGHT. THANK
YOU HI NOW MOVE TO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTH ANY HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WILL TAKE NAME
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT FOR A BI
TWENTY FIFTY OKAY MARC STIVERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT.
FILTHIEST ONLY SHAUN BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBERS ON THIS
PROMISE ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
ADVOCATES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE FOR AB TWENTY FIFTY
IN SUPPORT ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE
WILL NOW MOVE TO. OPPOSITION I
HAVE EITHER DEBRA CARLTON OR
TONY BELIEVE FROM THE-
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION. YOU'RE WELCOME TO COME UP.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
ARE DEBRA CARLTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
YOU KNOW CLASS IN TWO MONTHS AGO
WE WERE HERE WITH ALMOST AN
IDENTICAL BILL- AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE STILL IN
THIS POSITION OF OPPOSITION- THE
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL DON'T
CHANGE OUR OPPOSITION- IT
SLIGHTLY CHANGES THE DEFINITION
OF OWNER. BASICALLY WHAT WE HAVE
OUR SMALL BUILDINGS ARE
CONVERTED YOU DON'T CONVERT A
LARGE APARTMENT COMPLEX IT'S
JUST VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE YOU
CONVERT SMALL BUILDINGS BECAUSE
AS WHAT THE AUTHORS INDICATED
THEY CALL THEM SPECULATORS BUT
THE OWNERS SELL TO EIGHT OWNER
WHO DOES CONVERT IT BECAUSE- YOU
CAN'T HOLD SMALL BUILDINGS
ESPECIALLY IN RENT CONTROL
JURISDICTIONS WITH THE LOW RENTS
TODAY YOU CAN'T PAY THE
MORTGAGE. SO YOU DO CONVERT TO
OWNERSHIP HOUSING IT'S NOT
CONDOS THEY CALL THEM TENANCY IN
COMMON. AND WHILE WE DON'T LIKE
TO SEE THE CONVERSION OF RENTAL
HOUSING- THE HOUSING NOT LOST
IT'S SOLD TO INDIVIDUALS WHO
OCCUPY THE HOUSING- AS THEIR OWN
IN MANY CASES THE RENT CONTROL
JURISDICTIONS THIS IS THE ONLY
WAY IN WHICH TENANTS OR PEOPLE
WHO WISH TO BUY HOUSING AND LIVE
THERE CAN DO SO IT'S TOO
EXPENSIVE. IN THESE RENT CONTROL
JURISDICTIONS SO UNFORTUNATELY
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO ASK
FOR YOUR NO VOTE AGAIN THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM BIKED INDICATE OPPOSITION
TO AB. TWENTY FIFTY. REX THAT
BEHIND THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION ALSO
OPPOSED THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAMBERS PAT RAN OUT THERE AND
READING ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE IN THE HEARING ROOM
. SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANY
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY FIFTY WE
WILL TAKE FURTHER TESTIMONY BUT
WE WILL TAKE NAME AFFILIATION
AND OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION AB TWENTY
FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AND WE WILL LIE NINETY
NINE YOUR OPEN. A GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
AM A FIFTY S. RICHARD DID I ASK
FOR WHAT YOU WANT TO TAKE
OPPOSITION. IT WILL TAKE
OPPOSITION BUT THIS BILL WILL
TAKE OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT ON
THE TELEPHONE LINES. THANK YOU
RICHARD IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO TRY
IN OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AND WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY
EIGHT EUROPE AND- THE MORNING
CARE NUMBER. KEENER'S ALSO THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
CAN YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS DATE SAYS IGOR
TRACK OF SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF B.
ALAMEDA COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY
BE CONDEMNED PLAN TRICKS COUNCIL
AND THE PARK WE CAN IF YOU NEED
THANK YOU SO MUCH. FIVE ONE OH
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. LARRY
GROSS COALITION FOR ECONOMIC
SURVIVAL A CO SPONSOR OF AB
TWENTY FIFTY ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES TWENTY THREE LOST THEIR
HOMES YOU TO THE ISLAND FACT
THEM OUT TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
AFFORDABLE UNITS WE URGE FIRMLY
YES VOTE ON AB TWENTY CRISPY
THANK YOU. FIND OUR SKIN ME
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
INTERMEMBRANE WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION AND THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION OF GREATER LA IN
OPPOSITION. NINE ONE EIGHT YOU
ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CLEAN GREASY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTED NOTEBOOK THANK YOU. I
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
BRIAN KINGSTON AND REPRESENT THE
BEAST THEY RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION AND THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION OF ORANGE COUNTY
ALSO URGING YOU TO VOTE THANK
YOU. FIND SEVENTY SIX EUROPE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
AMY SURE WITH THE GRASSROOTS
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
STATEWIDE CALLED ACE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. I'M ONE HUNDRED YOU ARE
OPEN. HELLO CARE NUMBERS IF THE
RANGE AWAY CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA YIMBY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. Y. AND ONE OH
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
DOING CAMP JUNIOR REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
RETIRED AMERICANS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY MODEL
SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE GET MORE I'M BE
HAPPENING WHAT AND MR ST PANCRAS
WHAT HOLLYWOOD VERY STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
JACKIE BE WITH HOUSING
CALIFORNIA WHERE PROUD TO
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU. NINE
ONE OH TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
IF YOU DON'T LAUNCH HERE WENT
DOWN BARBARA TENANTS UNION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THE FINAL
REMINDER TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
RURAL AND WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
OH NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SIR MEMBERS ANNUAL OR ON
BEHALF OF HI COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT CENTER IN LOS
ANGELES IN STRONG SUPPORT. NINE
ONE TWELVE YOU ARE OPEN.
RESEARCHER MEMBERS RAND MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION AND ITS HOUSING IS A
HUMAN RIGHT DIVISION IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE EXHAUSTED THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WILL A PRETTY MAY CLOSE THE
LINES THEN AND I WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. RIGHT
SINGER MR THE YOU MAY CLOSE
WESTROCK LAST DRIVER WHEN THEY
QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED BUT AGAIN
WHAT'S YOUR MIND THAT THIS BILL
DOES NOT CHANGE THE- RIGHT OF
ANY LANDLORD OR PROPERTY ARE TO
SELL. THE STILL CONSEIL. IT'S
JUST A MATTER OF FACT OF WHAT
THE NEW OWNER DOES IF THEY
ACTUALLY TO RESPECT THE- RESULT
OF THE ELLIS ACT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
LEE. ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE TO
ITEM NUMBER FIVE A. B. SIXTEEN
NINETY MINS RIVAS.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WANT TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS LISTED
ON PAGE TEN OF THE ANALYSIS
THANK YOU AND THANK YOUR TEAM
FOR WORKING WITH OUR OFFICE WITH
THE AMENDMENTS AB SIXTEEN NINETY
WILL TRANSITION THE SALE OF ALL
IN ONE DISPOSABLE VAPE SO WHICH
ARE NOT RE CHARGEABLE TO
REUSABLE AND RECHARGEABLE
NICOTINE PRODUCTS TO ADDRESS THE
IMPACTS THAT THE SINGLE USE
PRODUCTS HAVE ON OUR HEALTH AND
OUR ENVIRONMENT. ORDING TO THE
CDC THE UNITED STATES IS
EXPERIENCING AN EPIDEMIC OF LUNG
INJURY ASSOCIATED WITH YOUTH
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTE USE OF
VAPES. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN OVER
20% OF U. S. HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS REPORTED USING VAPES IN
SCHOOLS INCLUDING CLASSROOMS AND
BATHROOMS. THE USE OF DISPOSABLE
E. CIGARETTES INCREASED ABOUT A
1000% AMONG HIGH SCHOOL E.
CIGARETTE USERS IN TWENTY TWENTY
. TEENS MAY NOT REALIZE THAT
NICOTINE IS DEEPLY ADDICTIVE
NICOTINE ACTUALLY CHANGES
ADOLESCENT'S BRAIN CELL ACTIVITY
IN THE PARTS OF THE BRAIN
RESPONSIBLE FOR ATTENTION
LEARNING AND MEMORY AND CAN EVEN
WORSEN ANXIETY. ADDITIONALLY THE
ERROL SOUL FROM A VAPE DEVICE
HAS NOT BEEN PROVEN SAFE STUDIES
HAVE FOUND THAT IT CONTAINED
LEAD AND VOLATILE ORGANIC
COMPOUNDS SOME OF WHICH ARE
LINKED TO CANCER. AS VAPE USAGE
SURGES IN THE UNITED STATES THEY
OFTEN OVERLOOKED FOR THE FIRE
DANGER THEY POSE FOR WASTE AND
RECYCLING WORKERS ACCORDING TO
THE FDA VAPES CAN CATCH ON IRE
OR EXPLODE AND SERIOUSLY HURT
PEOPLE. A VAPE PENS MAIN SAFETY
ISSUE LIES IN THE LITHIUM ION
BATTERY IT CONTAINS TO FUEL THE
HEATING ELEMENT FOR A MISER. THE
SHAPING CONSTRUCTION OF
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES CAN MAKE
THEM BEHAVE LIKE FLAMING ROCKETS
WHEN A BATTERY FAILS. BETWEEN
JANUARY TWO THOUSAND NINE AND
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST. TWENTY
SIXTEEN HUNDRED NINE HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE SEPARATE INCIDENTS
OF EXPLOSION AND FIRE INVOLVING
AN ELECTRONIC CIGARETTE WERE
REPORTED BY THE U. S. MEDIA. 62%
OF THE INCIDENCE OF EXPLOSION
AND FIRE INVOLVING AN ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTE OR ITS BATTERY
OCCURRED WHEN THE DEVICE WAS
EITHER IN A POCKET OR ACTIVELY
IN USE. ADDITIONALLY VAPES CAN
ALSO CONTAIN HEAVY METAL BATTERY
ACID NICOTINE AND OTHER HARMFUL
CHEMICALS. IT PROBABLY DID BOTH
. OF THESE ALL IN ONE DISPOSE
VAPES ARE KNOWN TO LEACH TOXIC
CHEMICALS INTO THE ENVIRONMENT
POLLUTE WATER AND HARM WILDLIFE.
THE MICRO PLASTICS AND HAZARDOUS
CHEMICALS THAT LEACH FROM THIS
BAPE WASTE ACCUMULATES IN THE
FOOD CHAIN AND AFFECTS WHOLE
ECOSYSTEMS INCLUDING THE HEALTH
OF SOILS. CURRENT LAW PASSED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE AND AB NINE
THREE NINE SET OUR WASTE
HIERARCHY AT SOURCE REDUCTION
FIRST TEN RECYCLING REUSABLE
BABES ARE ALREADY WIDELY
AVAILABLE ON THE MARKET AND ARE
LESS WASTEFUL ALTERNATIVE. AND
HIERARCHY BY MOVING AWAY FROM
ALL IN ONE DISPOSABLE VAPES THE
SMOKING INDUSTRY WILL BE DRIVEN
TO TRANSITION THEIR PRODUCTS TO
BE LESS WASTEFUL. TODAY I HAVE.
MICHAEL DAFT WITH REPUBLIC
SERVICES AND JORDAN WELLS FROM
THE NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP ACTION
COUNCIL SERVICE SERVING AS OUR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU MEMBER RIVAS CHAIR AND
MEMBERS USE THE MICROPHONE
PLEASE. IT'S THE PERFECT. I AM
VERY INVOLVED WITH THE NATIONAL
STEWARDSHIP ACTION COUNCIL A
NONPROFIT THAT ADVOCATES FOR
CIRCULAR AND EQUITABLE ECONOMY
AND THE SPONSOR OF AB SIXTEEN
NINETY. AB SIXTY NINETY DAYS OUT
THE SALE OF WASTEFUL SINGLE USE
ALL IN ONE VAPING DEVICES WHICH
ARE COMPRISED OF A BATTERY THAT
CANNOT BE REMOVED. OR RECHARGE
THE ENTIRE UNIT SHOULD BE
DISPOSED OF AS HAZARDOUS WASTE
AT HHW FACILITIES ARE HOUSEHOLD
HAZARDOUS WASTE FACILITIES.
LITHIUM ION BATTERIES ARE MUCH
MORE PRONE TO SPARKING FIRES
THAN OTHER HOUSEHOLD BATTERIES
AND IT IS ILLEGAL TO DISPOSE OF
THEM IN THE TRASH OR RECYCLING
WHERE THEY CAN AND DO. CAUSE
FIRES THAT CAN RESULT IN
CATASTROPHIC AND COSTLY DAMAGE
TO PROPERTY AND THE ENVIRONMENT
WITH THE POTENTIAL TO HURT
PEOPLE INCLUDING OUR WASTE
INDUSTRY WORKERS. ADDITIONALLY
WE HAVE A TRUTH IN LABELING
PROBLEM MANY NON RECHARGEABLE
VAPING DEVICES WE FIND ONLINE LÀ
ONLINE OUR LABEL DISPOSABLE
WHICH IMPLIES THAT CAN BE
DISPOSED OF IN THE TRASH. AND
SOME GO BEYOND THAT AND ACTUALLY
SAY SOME THINGS LIKE SINGLE USE
NO HASSLE OF WORRYING ABOUT
CHARGING THE DEVICE OR REFILLING
WITH AEGIS AND RECYCLABLE AND
ECO FRIENDLY. THIS LEADS TO
CONSUMER CONFUSION NEARLY HALF
OFALL SIX E. CIGARETTE
CONSUMERS ARE UNAWARE OF HOW TO
PROPERLY DISPOSE OF THEM. 51% OF
YOUNG E. CIGARETTE USERS
REPORTED DISPOSING OF EMPTY
DISPOSABLES IN THE TRASH AND
APPROXIMATELY ONE IN FIVE AND A
REGULAR RECYCLING BIN. IN VAPING
BE A DISPOSABLE PRODUCT IS ON
THE RISE. AMONG YOUTH E.
CIGARETTES ESPECIALLY THE
DISPOSABLES ARE MORE POPULAR
THAN ANY TRADITIONAL TOBACCO
PRODUCT BECAUSE THEY ARE CHEAPER
TO PURCHASE. ABOUT 54% OF YOUTH
WHO USE E. CIGARETTES USE
DISPOSABLES. ONE IN TEN OF YOUNG
E. CIGARETTE USERS REPORTED
DISCARDING OF THEIR DISPOSAL
DISPOSABLES BY SIMPLY THROWING
THEM ON THE GROUND. WHEN
ELECTRONIC BEEPING. PRODUCTS ARE
IMPROPERLY DISPOSED OF IN THE
ENVIRONMENT THEY MAY LEACH LED
KOBOL AND OTHER SUBSTANCES AND
TOXIC AMOUNTS. LASTLY TO STATE
APPOINTED BODIES HAVE
RECOMMENDED THAT CALIFORNIA
BANNED THE SALE OF E. CIGARETTES
INCLUDING THE STATE WIDE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL AND THE
SIXTEEN MEMBER STATEWIDE
RECYCLING COMMISSION WHICH
REPRESENTS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WASTE HAULERS NONPROFITS AND
UNIONS. I WANT TO THANK OUR
PRINCIPAL AUTHORS CHAIR STONE
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THREE OF US
SINGH CUDDY PETRIE-NORRIS FOR
THEIR LEADERSHIP ON THIS BILL AS
WELL AS THE TWENTY CO AUTHORS.
WE WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION IN
THE PRIOR COMMITTEE AND THE BILL
HAS BEEN AMENDED TO REMOVE MUCH
OF THE OPPOSITION I RISK URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB SIXTY NINE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT
THIS PLACE. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS MICHAEL DAFT WITH THE
PAN MCKAY LEE HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF REPUBLIC SERVICES A
LEADING SOLID WASTE RECYCLING
AND COMPOST PROVIDER HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND NATIONWIDE.
REPUBLIC SERVICES WANTS TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING THIS MEASURE THAT WE
BELIEVE WILL ENHANCE THE SAFETY
OF OUR EMPLOYEES AT OUR
FACILITIES. AROUND THE STATE AS
THE AUTHOR STATED A. B. SIXTEEN
NINETY SIX TO LIMIT TOBACCO
SINGLE USE PRODUCTS. PRODUCTS
WHICH ARE TOO OFTEN DISPOSED OF
IN THE TRASH AND END UP IN OUR
COLLECTION VEHICLES AND
ULTIMATELY THE REPUBLICS
BASILIDES. THE IMPACTS OF SINGLE
USE PRODUCTS ON THE ENVIRONMENT
IN THE WASTE AND RECYCLING
STREAMS. HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
HIGHLIGHTED. BUT FOR US AT
REPUBLIC SERVICES AND OTHER
SOLID WASTE COMPANIES THESE
ITEMS CAN HAVE OTHER NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES. IN THE CASE OF THE
PRODUCTS IDENTIFIED IN AB
SIXTEEN NINETY SPECIFICALLY THE
LITHIUM ION BATTERIES. THEY CAN
LEAD TO FIRES AND OTHER HAZARDS
ARE FACILITIES. WHILE THERE HAVE
BEEN FIRES IN THE PAST. PRIOR TO
THESE PRODUCTS BEING INTRODUCED
IN RECENT YEARS THESE NEW
SMALLER DIFFICULT IDENTIFY
BATTERIES STILL END UP IN OUR
WASTE STREAM AND END UP CAUSING
FIRES AT MANY OF REPUBLIC
SOCIETIES. FOR EXAMPLE THERE
WERE SIX FIRES ACROSS TWENTY
TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT
THE RICHMOND TRANSFER STATION
ALONE. REPUBLIC SERVICES
BELIEVES THAT THESE SMALL
BATTERIES ENTERING THE WASTE
STREAM HAS LED TO AN INCREASE IN
FIRES IN RECENT YEARS. REPUBLICS
LOS ANGELES FACILITIES HAVE ALSO
REPORTED FIRES CAUSED BY THE
HEAT AND PRESSURE FROM THE HEAVY
EQUIPMENT GRABBING OR PUSHING A
LOAD WITH ONE OF THESE LITHIUM
ION BATTERIES IN IT. LEADING TO
A SPARK OR IGNITION OF A FIRE.
THE SAFETY OF THE EMPLOYEES OF
THESE FACILITIES IS TOP PRIORITY
FOR REPUBLIC SERVICES AND
PROHIBITING THE SALE OF THESE
PRODUCTS AND SHIFTING THEM. TO
RECHARGEABLE VERSIONS WILL HELP
ELIMINATE POTENTIAL FIRE HAZARDS
OF THE FACILITIES. BY ENSURING
THE SINGLE USE VERSIONS OF THESE
PRODUCTS DO NOT END UP DISPOSING
THE WASTE STREAM. I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING THIS IN RESPECT WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ARE THERE
OTHERS IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
WE WILL NOT TAKE FURTHER
TESTIMONY BUT HIS NAME
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JASON
SHELTER ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL
ALAMEDA STOP WASTE AND WESTERN
PLASTER WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. NOT LEAVE ONE
REPRESENTING HEALTH OFFICES-
SESSION OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
. JOHNSON CLAIMED AFTER THE CITY
OF ENCINITAS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE IN THE HEARING
ROOM IN SUPPORT. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN ALLIANCE
FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR A BI
SIXTEEN NINETY. TO SHOW SUPPOR
FOR AB SIXTY NINETY PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN FALL
BY ZERO POINT FIFTY NINE YOU ARE
ALL THAT. GOOD MORNING MR
CHARACTER ROCKS ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY IT'S A LOT OF EACH IN
SUPPORT OF THE- SIX WILL DELIGHT
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SHARON MEMBERS ERICA
ROMERO ON BEHALF OF FREAKING
QUITE IN STRONG SUPPORT. NINE
ONE ONE YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THE CARPET
PUT CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE
AND TRONG SUPPORT. AND AT THE
FINAL REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR- AB SIXTY NINETY PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AND LINE ONE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUED
UP THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO OPPOSITION HI IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SIXTEEN NINETY. ALL RIGHT SEEING
NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANY OPPOSITION TO AB
SIXTEEN NINETY. TO OPPOSITION
FOR AB SIXTEEN NINETY PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE
FILED BY ZERO. JACARE NOBODY'S
KILLING UP ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
OF READY MADE CLOTHES LIGHTS
OFFERING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SUCH AS IT IS
QUESTIONS COMMENCEMENT ADDRESS.
SYCIP I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU
DO AN INFORMATIONAL- THE-
PROGRAM FOR HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
THE TESTIMONY GAVE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS SO
IMPORTANT FOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS TO HEAR- SO APART FROM
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT THE BILL IS
ABOUT BUT JUST THE INFORMATION
THAT YOU PROVIDE IT IS SO
IMPORTANT. THANK YOU. YOU THANK
YOU RIGHT THIS RIVAS YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
ASK- FOR AN AYE VOTE AND THANK
YOU FOR JOINING ME ON THIS BILL
AND FOR ALL THE SUPPORT THAT
YOUR COMMITTEE HAS GIVEN THIS
THANK YOU BILL THANK YOU WE WILL
TAKE IT UP WHAT. QUORUM THANK
YOU. RIGHT ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY MISS MATTEUCCI.
WHAT GOOD MORNING. AS CHAIR
THANKS FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWO TWO
TWO ZERO- THIS IS A BILL TO
ESTABLISH A HOMELESS COURT PILOT
PROGRAM TO BE ADMINISTERED BY
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL. I CAME TO
THIS ISSUE THROUGH A CITY A
BEAUTIFUL COASTAL CITY IN MY
DISTRICT A REDONDO BEACH WHICH
HAS TAKEN A LEADERSHIP AND
ESTABLISHING A- HOMELESS COURT
THROUGH THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SUPERIOR COURT- THIS PROGRAM HAS
BEEN HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL AND WE
HAVE THE CITY ATTORNEY FROM.
REDONDO BEACH HERE TO SHARE MORE
DETAILS IN TERMS OF THE PROGRAM
BUT- I AS THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
SUMMARIZES THIS IS NOT A NEW
CONCEPT- IT THERE ARE OVER FOUR
HUNDRED. HOMELESS COURTS AND
OTHER COLLABORATIVE COURTS
THROUGHOUT. POIGNANT BUT THE
BASIC CONCEPT IS PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD IT'S TO USE A
CRIMINAL COURTS NOT OF FOR-
CRIMINAL PUNISHMENT ESPECIALLY
FOR LOW LEVEL OFFENSES BUT TO
USE IT AS A POINT OF
INTERVENTION TO PROVIDE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES WHETHER IT'S
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES SUBSTANCE
ABUSE. HOUSING JOB TRAINING- TO
HELP GET THESE- LOW LEVEL
CRIMINAL OFFENDERS BACK ON THEIR
FEET- IN ORDER TO- TO- GET THEM
OFF THE STREETS- THIS BILL
PROPOSES A GRANT PROGRAM TO BE-
TO PROMOTE AND SUPPORT HOMELESS
COURTS. NOT ONLY AND COMMUNITIES
LIKE REDONDO BEACH BUT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- HERE IN A
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE IS A MIKE WEBB. THE CITY
ATTORNEY OF REDONDO BEACH
CORRECT FIRST WITNESS PLEASE
WHAT THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
TO- SPEAK BEFORE YOU ON THIS
PROGRAM IN A WAY THAT- HELP SET
UP THE MOST IMPOVERISHED MEMBERS
OF OUR SOCIETY HELP SET THEM UP
FOR SUCCESS. AS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI MENTION THIS
IS NOT A NEW PROGRAM BUT- WHAT-
THE TWISTS WE PUT ON IT IS
BECAUSE THE PANDEMIC. WE BROUGHT
IT OUTDOORS AND WE PRIDE IT
OUTDOORS FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
L. A. COUNTY AND BECAUSE THIS IS
AN AT RISK POPULATION. AND WHAT
WE FOUND WAS THAT THE BENEFIT
IT'S NOT JUST HEALTH RELATED BUT
BY BRINGING. THE COURT ROOM
BRING IN THE JUSTICE SYSTEM TO
THE COMMUNITY WHERE THOSE-
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ALREADY
WORK. IT BECAME A LESS
THREATENING MORE INVITING WAY TO
GET THEM INVOLVED IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM THERE
ARE OTHER IN QUICKER WAYS. THE
TO GET SOME OF THESE
MISDEMEANORS DISMISSED BUT- OVER
71% OF THE PEOPLE THAT ARCH ARCH
AT INVITED INTO PROGRAM
PARTICIPATE AND ACCEPT SERVICES
AND THEY DO SO IN THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER. SO I ADVISE THEM TO DO
SO BECAUSE WE BRING ALL THE
SERVICES THAT ARE SORELY.
LACKING IN SOCIETY IN TERMS OF
ADDITIONAL MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELING ADDICTION DRUG.
COUNSELING WE HAVE A SEPARATE
NOT JUST THE PUBLIC DEFENDER
SAID STAFF THE COURT ROOM BUT A
SEPARATE PUBLIC DEFENDER
EXPUNGEMENT TEAM WE HAVE- CITY
ATTORNEY. PROGRAM FROM LA THAT
HELPS THEM- DISMISSED THE
CHARGES AND SO IN OTHER WORDS
WE'RE SETTING THEM UP FOR
SUCCESS BECAUSE HE CAN BE SO
HARD TO NAVIGATE ALL THE
DIFFERENT- BUREAUCRACIES THAT
THEY HAVE TO. NAVIGATE TO BE
ABLE TO QUALIFY FOR PERMANENT
HOUSING AND SO THIS BILL WOULD
YOU OUR PROGRAM IS ALREADY BEING
COPIED WITH- TO. IN SECOND. L.
I. IN TORRANCE OUR BIGGEST
NEIGHBORING CITY THIS WOULD PUT
A- OF A GRANT PROGRAM A PILOT
PROGRAM THROUGH JUDICIAL COUNCIL
TO SEE SENATE AND SEE. HOW IT
CAN BE. AND TO HELP ADDRESS THIS
CRISIS OF HOMELESSNESS THAT
WE'RE FACING SO I THINK IT'S
VERY VERY EXCITING- I WOULD SAY
THE ONE THAT THE- IT'S AN
EXCELLENT- MARKUP BUT I WOULD
POINT OUT. THIS IS AN OUTDOOR
COURT ROOM AND YOU WILL GET
PUSHED BACK IF THERE IS NOT A
PROVISION OF- OF SHERIFF'S
DEPUTIES TO DO SO OURS THAN IT
IS IN A PARKING A PARKING LOT-
RIGHT NEAR WHERE THEY RECEIVE
MEALS. OUT FOR LUNCH AND DINNER
WE SET THAT DATE UP DELIBERATELY
SO IT'S IMPORTANT THE SHERIFF
WOULDN'T AGREE TO IT IF WE
DIDN'T HAVE SECURITY WHICH WHAT
WE PAY FOR IN THE PILOT PROGRAM
WOULD HELP OTHER CITIES TOO. AND
THE INTERNET IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE- IT ALLOWS WALK UPS IT
ALLOWS MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY
WHO AREN'T FACING CRIMINAL
CHARGES TO COME IN AND HELP
THEIR WARRANTS RECALLED. IN THE
COURT CAN'T DEAL WITH ANY CASES
UNLESS THEY HAVE THE FILE IN
FRONT OF THEM THEY DON'T
TRANSPORT IT- THAT TO THE COURT
AND SO BUT WE SET UP WIFI SO
THOSE ARE IMPORTANT PIECES TO
THIS PROGRAM- BUT OTHER THAN
THAT I THOUGHT I THOUGHT THE
MARKET WAS GREAT I THINK- THE
NEED. TO MAKE CERTAIN ANYONE WHO
QUALIFIES THE GRANT PROVIDES
BOTH TRANSITIONAL AND PERMANENT
HOUSING IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE YOU
NEED TO GET THEM STABILIZE SO
THANK WITH THAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE. IN THE HEARING
ROOM IN SUPPORT. THIS IS AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN ALLIANCE
FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
DECADE SUPPORT TO AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY. TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR
AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME WHEN FILED BY ZERO. IT
SURE NOBODY'S GOING UP. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. TO AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES TO ANY OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY. YOU WOULD
LIKE TO PRESS OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN POWER
BY ZERO. NOBODY'S QUEUING UP. I
THANK YOU OF PROPERTY MAY CLOSE
ALLIES OF BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. C. NONE THE SERVER TO
G. MIKLOS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU WILL TAKE IT UP
ONCE WE HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT- NO OTHER AUTHORS MS
REYES WILL MOVE TO OUR ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
PRESENT AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
EIGHT WHICH WILL REVISE THE
COMMERCIALLY SEXUALLY EXPLOITED
CHILDREN PROGRAM KNOWN AS SEA
SICK. TO ENSURE BOTH SEX AND
LABOR TRAFFICKING CHILDREN ARE
IDENTIFIED SUPPORTED AND
PROTECTED. I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR FOR
THEIR WORK. AND THE INFORMATION
PROVIDED AND THE ANALYSIS AND WE
AND FOR ACCEPTING THE OFFER
AMENDMENTS TO REPLACE REFERENCE
TO LABOR TRAFFICKING WITH FORCED
LABOR WHICH IS DEFINED IN THE
PENAL CODE IN ORDER TO PROMOTE
CONSISTENCY WITH THE LAW. THIS
IS A PROGRAM WAS CREATED WITH
THE INTENT OF IDENTIFYING
PROVIDING SERVICES TO SAY
SEXUALLY TRAFFICKED CHILDREN BY
PROVIDING COUNTIES WITH OPTED IN
WITH THAT UP TO THE END. TO THE
PROGRAM WITH FUNDING AND
RESOURCES WITH HIS FUNDING AND
WITH THE RESOURCES COUNTIES
COULD ESTABLISH. LOCAL TASK
FORCES TO DIRECTLY INTERVENE IN
CASES OF SEXUALLY TRAFFICKED
CHILDREN AND PROVIDE SERVICES.
WITH THE C. SECOND PROGRAM. WELL
THE SIX THAT PROGRAM HAS WORKED
TO PROVIDE SEXUALLY TRAFFICKED
CHILDREN WITH ASSISTANCE AND
RESOURCES. LABOR TRAFFICKED
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN MISIDENTIFIED
AND DO NOT RECEIVE THE SAME
LEVEL OF TREATMENT OF SEXUALLY
TRAFFICKED CHILDREN. THIS IS
TROUBLING WHEN CONSIDERING THE
RESEARCH FROM THE COALITION TO
ABOLISH SLAVERY AND TRAFFICKING.
SUGGEST THAT LABOR TRAFFICKING
MAKES UP 39% OF ALL HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CALIFORNIA. TO
COMBAT THIS ISSUE AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY EIGHT WILL REVISE A C.
SEC PROGRAM TO INCLUDE ALL
CHILDREN WHO ARE VICTIMS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING BOTH SEXUAL
AND LABOR TRAFFICKED AUTHORIZED
A CHILD VICTIM OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING TO BE A JUDGE THE
DEPEND OF THE JUVENILE COURT. IN
CASES WHERE THE PARENT OR
GUARDIAN FAILS OR IS UNABLE TO
PROTECT THE CHILD FROM BEING
EXPLOITED. AND THIRD AB TWENTY
SIX TWENTY EIGHT WOULD ALSO
PROHIBIT A SOCIAL WORKER FROM
TAKING TEMPORARY CUSTODY OF
CHILD VICTIMS OF TRAFFICKING IF
THE PARENT OR GUARDIAN HAD NOT
PARTICIPATED DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY IN THE CHILD
TRAFFICKING. BY ENSURING THAT
THESE MECHANISMS ARE IN PLACE AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY EIGHT WILL
PROVIDE LABOR TRAFFICKED
CHILDREN WITH THE SAME COURT
PROCEDURES SERVICES AND
PROTECTIONS. AS SEXUALLY
TRAFFICKED CHILDREN. AND HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT TO OUR YOUTH
AND RARICK EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION. AND ADRIANA GRIFFIN.
LIVED EXPERIENCE CONSULTANT FOR
THE SONY THAT JANE. ANTI
TRAFFICKING POLICY INITIATIVE OF
LOYOLA LAW SCHOOL. MINNEDOSA
FIRST WITNESS PLEASE THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ETHAN RARICK I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION- HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SIX TWO EIGHT
TO THE COMMISSION IS AN
INDEPENDENT BIPARTISAN OVERSIGHT
AGENCY CHARGED WITH MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE STATE
GOVERNMENT IN TWENTY TWENTY WE
ISSUED A SERIES OF THREE REPORTS
EXAMINING THE STATE'S RESPONSE
TO LABOR TRAFFICKING. A HORRIFIC
CRIME THAT EXPLOITS INNOCENT
WORKERS TO FORCE FRAUD OR
COERCION DURING OUR STUDY OF
LABOR TRAFFICKING WE HEARD FROM
A BROAD ARRAY OF X. ADVOCATES
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS AND I
THINK IMPORTANTLY DIRECTLY FROM
THE SURVIVORS OF CHILDHOOD LABOR
TRAFFICKING TRAFFICKERS PREY ON
THE MOST VULNERABLE AMONG US
REGARDLESS OF GENDER AGE OR
CITIZENSHIP STATUS AND RESEARCH
SUGGESTS THE RUNAWAY AND
HOMELESS YOUTH AS WELL AS FOSTER
CHILDREN ARE PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE TO THIS EXPLOITATION.
YET CALIFORNIA'S PROTECTIONS FOR
LABOR TRAFFIC FOR CHILD VICTIMS
OF LABOR TRAFFICKING ARE THIN IN
OUR REPORT ENTITLED LABOR
TRAFFICKING STRATEGIES TO
UNCOVER THIS HIDDEN CRIME WE
FOUND THE PROTECTIONS FOR CHILD
VICTIMS FOCUS FAR MORE ON SEX
TRAFFICKING COMBATING SEX
TRAFFICKING IS ABSOLUTELY VITAL
AND MUST OF COURSE CONTINUE BUT
IT IS IMPERATIVE IN OUR
COMMISSION'S VIEW THAT WE TARGET
LABOR TRAFFICKING. JUST AS
AGGRESSIVELY TO ENSURE CHILD
VICTIMS OF ALL FORMS OF
TRAFFICKING ARE PROTECTED BY
STATE LAW THE COMMISSION
RECOMMENDED THAT LAWMAKERS
UPDATE EXISTING LAWS
SPECIFICALLY WE RECOMMENDED THAT
LAWS ADDRESSING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING OF COMMERCIALLY
SEXUALLY EXPLOITED CHILDREN BE
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE ALL FORMS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING THUS INCLUDING
ENSURING A CONSISTENT RESPONSE.
AS YOU KNOW AB TWO SIX TWO EIGHT
WOULD CARRY OUT THIS
RECOMMENDATION BY REVISING THE
COMMERCIALLY SEXUALLY EXPLOITED
CHILDREN PROGRAM TO INCLUDE ALL
CHILDREN WHO ARE VICTIMS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING THIS WOULD
INCLUDE VICTIMS OF LABOR
TRAFFICKING I WANT TO THANK THE
MAJORITY LEADER FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE IN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK HERE TODAY ON BEHALF THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU THANK GOODNESS
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THE GROUP.
FOR THE WRONG THE WRONG HAS-
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE SPACE
TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE MY NAME IS
ADRIANA GRIFFITH AND I AM THE
SURVIVOR CONSULTANT FOR THIS
NEEDED CHEN ANTI TRAFFICKING
INITIATIVES AND I'M HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY. TRAFFICKING EXPERIENCES
OCCUR ON A SPECTRUM AS THERE ARE
MANY DIFFERENT WAYS SOMEONE CAN
EXPERIENCE THIS TYPE OF HARM.
I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT MY
EXPERIENCE AS A SURVIVOR AS WELL
AS AN ADVOCATE AND PROGRAM
SPECIALIST FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING ABUSE AND
EXPLOITATION. IN THE EARLY DAYS
OF MY VICTIMIZATION THE LABOR
TRAFFICKING I WAS SUBJECTED TO
ACTED AS A GATEWAY TO
EXPERIENCING SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION. I HAD TO STEAL
FROM THE MALL. FIGHT OTHER
PEOPLE COMMIT FRAUD. IT WAS EVEN
COERCED INTO EXPLOITING OTHERS.
AT THE TIME I THOUGHT MY
BEHAVIORS WERE THE RESULT OF MY
OWN CHOICES. BUT LOOKING BACK I
REALIZE THERE WAS A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF MANIPULATION INVOLVED
THAT RISES TO THE ELEMENTS OF
FORCE FRAUD AND COERCION. IF MY
EXPERIENCE WAS RECOGNIZED AS
LABOR EXPLOITATION INSTEAD OF
CRIMINALITY. I COULD HAVE BEEN
CONNECTED TO THE SUPPORT OF
SERVICES THAT I NEEDED. WHICH
COULD HAVE HELPED ME AVOID
SEXUAL EXPLOITATION. I WISH I
COULD HAVE BEEN CONNECTED TO
OPPORTUNITIES FOR JOB TRAINING
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
GROWTH AND HEALING. INSTEAD OF
CRIMINALIZING SENT TO PRISON.
OUT SIDE OF MY OWN EXPERIENCE
I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
WITH YOUTH EXPERIENCING ABUSE
AND EXPLOITATION. HOWEVER
BECAUSE OF THE STATE'S OVER
EMPHASIS ON COMMERCIALLY
SEXUALLY EXPLOITED CHILDREN
OFTEN YOU ARE MISIDENTIFIED AND
NOT CONNECTED TO THE SERVICES
THEY NEED. YOUTH WHO ARE BEING
EXPLOITED FOR THEIR LABOUR AND
NON SEXUAL SERVICES ARE NOT
BEING GIVEN THE TOOLS THEY NEED
AND ARE RENDERED INCREDIBLY
VULNERABLE TO FURTHER
EXPLOITATION. INCLUDING SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION. THE OPPOSITION
BRINGS UP EMPTY SECULAR
ARGUMENTS THAT THERE'S NO DATA
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. HOWEVER
THERE IS NO DATA TO NOT SUPPORT
THIS BILL BECAUSE CALIFORNIA HAS
NOT BEEN MANDATED OR
INCENTIVIZED TO COLLECT ANY.
CALIFORNIA HAS FAILED SURVIVORS
AND EXPLOITED YOUTH BY FAILING
TO CORRECT THIS OVERSIGHT AND
THE CONSEQUENCES ARE DEVASTATING
FOR ALL STAKEHOLDERS. SURVIVORS
MISSED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONNECTED TO SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
AND PREVENT FURTHER EXPLOITATION
. SERVICE SERVICE PROVIDERS
MISSED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE COMMUNITIES WITH THE
TOOLS THEY NEED TO HELP
THEMSELVES AND OTHERS. AND
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES MISSED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO UNDERSTAND AND
PREVENT TRAFFICKING FROM AN
INTERSECTIONAL APPROACH FOR ALL
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. WE ALL LOSE WHEN
LABOR TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS ARE
NOT PROTECTED. I STRONGLY URGE
THIS COMMITTEE TO VOTE YES ON
THIS BILL AND SEND A MESSAGE TO
SURVIVORS IN CALIFORNIA THAT YOU
WILL NO LONGER LEAVE THEM
BEHIND. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
READ ANYONE ELSE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
EIGHT. HI I JUST OF THE JELLO
WITH A CITY DAY JANE ODDLY ON
ALL SCHOOL INITIATIVE A- CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL AND
THANKFUL FO THE SENATE WOMAN
FOR KAREN THIS BILL. IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE ARRESTING
NINE OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE. WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY EIGHTHS WILL
TAKE NAME AFFILIATION AND
SUPPORT ONLY WE WILL TAKE
FURTHER TESTIMONY. THANK YOU IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR A BI I. TWENTY SIX
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE FILED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME WE WERE LYING
SEVENTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING REBECCA GONZALEZ OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. AND FINAL REMINDER TO
TESTIFYING SUPPORTER SHOWS X.
SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOR AB TWENTY
SIX TWENTY EIGHT. MISTER CHAIR
NOBODY ELSE'SQUEUING UP THANK
YOU WE WILL NOW THEN MOVED TO
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY EIGHT. SEEING
NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY EIGHT. CHAU
OPPOSITION FOR AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE FILED BY
ZERO. MISTER CHAIRMAN NOBODY IS
KILLING UP. THANK YOU ARE PRETTY
MAY CLOSE THE LINES OF BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. CENA MIZ
RACEMIC CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY EIGHT
IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
TO HELP PROTECT OUR LABOR
TRAFFICKED CHILDREN AND I ALSO
FOR YOUR I. BOATS SYSTEMS WE
HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU FOR WHO
TAKE IT UP ONCE WE HAVE COR.
RIGHT MR GABRIEL OUR ITEM NUMBER
NINE AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY.
MORNING GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TODAY
TO PRESENT A. B. TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY WHICH WILL CREATE AN
OFFICE OF ACCESS TO JUSTICE
WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA DPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE. HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WE ARE FACING A WELL DOCUMENT
WELL DOCUMENTED ACCESS TO
JUSTICE CRISIS WELL THOSE WHO
CAN AFFORD AN ATTORNEY ENJOY THE
BENEFITS AND PROTECTIONS OF OUR
LEGAL SYSTEM FOR MANY LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS THE PROMISE OF
EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER LAW. IT'S
TOO OFTEN ILLUSORY. AB TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY WOULD ADDRESS THIS
INEQUITY BY ESTABLISHING AN
OFFICE IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. FOCUS ON PROVIDING
ACCESS TO JUSTICE FOR LOW INCOME
AND OTHER UNDERREPRESENTED
INDIVIDUALS IN THE CALIFORNIA
CIVIL JUSTICE SYSTEM. IT WOULD
IMPROVE THE DELIVERY OF LOCAL
LEGAL AID SERVICES PROMOTE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN STATE
AGENCIES. TRIAGE STATEWIDE CIVIL
LEGAL NEEDS AND DEVELOP POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS ON ACCESS TO
JUSTICE ISSUES. IN THE FEDERAL
EQUIVALENT ESTABLISHED BY
PRESIDENT OBAMA AND RECENTLY
REESTABLISHED BY PRESIDENT BIDEN
THIS OFFICE WILL IMPROVE ACCESS
TO LEGAL AID SERVICES AND HELP
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES IN NEED ACROSS OUR
STATE. WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IS LAUREN KLEIN THE
DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY AT THE
LEGAL AID ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU MR GABRIEL THERE ARE
AMENDMENTS YOU'RE TAKING THOSE
AS AUTHORS YES SIR. THANK YOU
FOR THAT. RIGHT I DO HAVE LORING
CLAIM LISTED WITH US ON THE
TELEPHONE ARE YOU WITH US. I'M
HERE GO AHEAD PLEASE GOOD
MORNING GOOD MORNING TEXT ON A
MEMBERSMY NAME IS LAURENKLEIN
I AM THE DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY AT
THE LEGAL AID ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT A
NETWORK OF MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
STATE FUNDED NONPROFIT THAT
PROVIDES FREE CIVIL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE. AND YOU JUST HEARD
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL DESCRIBE
WE ARE FACING A CRISIS OF ACCESS
TO JUSTICE HOW MUCH PEOPLE HAVE
SERIOUS LEGAL PROBLEMS THEY
CAN'T AFFORD LAWYERS AND THERE
AREN'T ENOUGH FREE LEGAL AID
LAWYERS TO HELP THEM. BUT TO
ACHIEVE TRUE ACCESS TO JUSTICE
WE MUST LOOK FURTHER THAN THE
NUMBER OF LAWYERS WE MUST ALSO
EXAMINE ARTISTS IN THE COURT THE
LAST WEEK PASSED THE WAY THOSE
LAWS ARE APPLIED AND THE WAY OUR
GOVERNMENT DELIVERS PROGRAM.
THAT'S WHY WE ARE PROUD TO
SPONSOR THIS BILL. TO CREATE AN
OFFICE OF ACCESS TO JUSTICE.
IT'S OFFICE WOULDN'T THE TO.
FEDERAL AND VECA. VISION OF
ACCESS AND FREE WEIGHTS. WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ITSELF. THROUGHOUT STATE
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS. AND
STATEWIDE THROUGH COLLABORATION
WITH LEGAL AID. MY ORGANIZATION
HAS WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE
STAFF OF THE FEDERAL OFFICE FOR
MANY YEARS INDIFFERENT TO
MAGNIFY OR REPLICATE SOME OF ITS
IMPACT HERE IN CALIFORNIA. FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN CALIFORNIA WAS SET
TO RECEIVE A SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL
BLOCK GRANTS. FROM THE VICTIMS
OF CRIME ACT UTILIZED RESEARCH
SHOWING THAT THE LEGAL
INTERVENTION IMPROVES OUTCOMES
FOR CRIME VICTIMS. TO CONVINCE
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
TO INCORPORATE IT INTO THEIR
PROGRAM. ULTIMATELY TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THROUGH
SEVERAL GRANT PROGRAMS. FUNDED
SERVICES ACCOUNT THE CRIME
VICTIM. ONE CALIFORNIA. A PRO
USING CANNABIS TAX REVENUE
DOLLARS WITH SIMILARLY AND BY
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. TO ENSURE A STABLE
LEGAL SYSTEMS GROUP AND
CORPORATE IT APPROPRIATELY. IN
THIS LEGISLATURE PASSED
EMERGENCY PROTECTION TO SPEND
THE PANDEMIC FIELD HOUSING
CRISIS I HAVE WORKED WITH NO
LESS THAN THREE STATE AGENCIES
TO ENSURE EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE AND PRESERVED AT THE NEW
LAW TOOK EFFECT AND PROGRAMS
SUCH AS EMERGENCY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE WERE ROLLED OUT. NONE
OF THIS WOULD'VE BEEN POSSIBLE
WITHOUT SOMEONE FACILITATING A
FOCUS ON ACCESS TO JUSTICE AND
COLLABORATION WITH LEGAL AID.
WELL MY ORGANIZATION HAS
CONVINCINGLY PROVE THE CONCEPT
THAT WORK IN THE BILL WE ARE FAR
FROM ACHIEVING THE VISION THAT
AN OFFICE OF ACCESS TO JUSTICE
ACCOMPLISH. I THINK THIS BILL
WOULD TAKE THE WORK WE HAVE
STARTED THE GENOCIDE THAT
OPTIMIZE THAT THROUGHOUT STATE
GOVERNMENT AND A FIRM CALIFORNIA
COMMITMENTS TRUE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE. FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONTINUED. LEADERSHIP AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. RIGHT IS THERE ANY IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR OTHERS WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY. THE POOR FOR
AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND WE'RE GOING
TO LINE NINETY NINE THE LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF
OF DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY THANK YOU. THERE'S NO ONE
I THINK YOU. ARE RIGHT THANK YOU
WE WILL THEN MOVE TO OPPOSITION
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO. SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR ANY
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY. ADDITION FOR TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND THERE IS NO WINNING Q.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU ARE PRETTY
MAY CLOSE THE LINES AND WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SIGNIN MISTER GARRETT YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU JUST WANT TO
THANK THE WITNESS- FOR ALL OF
THE WORK THEY DO- I THINK AS
THOSE OF A OF THE MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE RETURNEES ARE PROBABLY
FAMILIAR WITH THE EXTRAORDINARY
WORK THAT OUR LEGAL AID AGENCIES
JAIL. TO BRING ACCESS TO JUSTICE
TO THE FOREFRONT OF A
CONVERSATION ACROSS DEPARTMENTS
AND AGENCIES I THINK WOULD
BENEFIT A LOT OF OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
WITHOUT WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
WE WILL TAKE IT UP WHAT'S WE
HAVE CORE. THANK YOU. WE SEEM TO
HAVE NOT ONLY A DEARTH OF
MEMBERS BUT A DEARTH OF. AUTHORS
EVERYBODY WANTS TO HAVE THEIR
BILL HEARD TODAY WHO HASN'T BEEN
HEARD TODAY. NOW'S YOUR
OPPORTUNITY. THE NEW. THERE'S.
THIS YEAR OKAY. RIGHT I THINK
WHEN WE TAKE ABOUT A FIVE MINUTE
RECESS AND THAT'LL GIVE AUTHORS
A CHANCE TO GET HERE SO WE'LL BE
BACK IN A FEW MINUTES.
ALL RIGHTS WE ARE BACK WE HAVE
AN AUTHOR. SO WE'RE GONNA ROLES
WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN AB TWENTY SEVEN TEN
MISTER KALRA. THE OKAY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
ITS STAFF- WORK WITH MY OFFICE
ON THIS ISSUE I KNOW IT'S ONE
THAT HAS BEEN WORKED ON HER IN
IN RECENT YEARS I THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AB TWENTY
SEVEN TEN WOULD CREATE A
STATEWIDE TEN OPPORTUNITY
PURCHASE ACT AND COMMUNITY
OPPORTUNITY PURCHASE ACT. TO
GIVE TENANTS AND RESIDENT
ORGANIZATIONS THE FIRST
OPPORTUNITY TO PURCHASE THE
RENTAL PROPERTY THEY'LL BE PUT
UP FOR SALE. OVER THE YEARS WE
HAVE SEEN THE COSTA HOUSING GO
UP IN PRICE AS A RESULT OF REAL
ESTATE INVESTORS. BUYING UP
PROPERTIES GENTRIFYING
NEIGHBORHOODS AND DISPLACING LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
UNSUBSIDIZED AFFORDABLE HOMES
PURCHASED BY INVESTORS DON'T
ALWAYS GO BACK ON THE MARKET AND
AFFORDABLE RATE WHICH LEAVES
TENANTS WITH EVEN LESS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPTIONS. IN
ADDITION AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT
IS NOT DEED RESTRICT IS
DISAPPEARING DISAPPEARING FASTER
THAN WE CAN BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN OUR STATE AND IT IS
TIME THAT WE DO SOMETHING TO
ADDRESS A CRITICAL ISSUE. THAT
IS CRIPPLING OUR COMMUNITIES. AB
TWENTY SEVEN TEN WOULD GIVE
TENANTS AND RESIDENT
ORGANIZATIONS THE FIRST
OPPORTUNITY APPROACHING THE
RENTAL HOME BEING PUT UP FOR
SALE. OR BE ABLE TO MATCH OTHER
OFFERS. IN NO CASE WITH THIS
BILL REQUIRED OWNER TO SELL
THEIR PROPERTY OR RESTRICT THE
PRICE AT WHICH THEY CAN SELL IT.
BY CREATING A STATE Y. TOPA COPA
TENANTS AND RESIDENTIAL
ORGANIZATIONS CAN HAVE AFAIR
CHANCE TO COMPETE WTH CASH
OFFERS FROM THE PRIVATE MARKET.
AND ALTHOUGH THERE HAVE BEEN
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY SEVEN TEN
DIFFERS FROM ITS PREDECESSORS
ARE BY NO LONGER REQUIRING THE
DISCLOSURE OF TENANT'S PERSONAL
INFORMATION. ADDRESSING THE
CONCERN FOR THE OPPOSITION. AND
TO BE ERY CLEAR THIS BILL EXAMS
THE TRANSFER OR SALE THE FAMILY
MEMBERS. WE REACH OUT TO
OPPOSITION. SEVEN TO ENGAGE IN
CONVERSATION ARE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION TO
WORK WITH THEM. AB TWENTY SEVEN
TEN CAN BE AN INSTRUMENTAL PIECE
IN ADDRESSING THE CRITICAL
HOUSING CRISIS OUR STATE. BY
HELPING KEEP FAMILIES IN THEIR
HOME. A IN THEIR HOMES AND
PRESERVING AT RISK OF AFFORDABLE
RENTAL HOUSING ON THE PRIVATE
MARKET WOULD BE TODAY TO TESTIFY
SUPPORTERS ANDREAS RAMOS FROM
PUBLIC ADVOCATES. THANK YOU
FIRST WITNESS PLEASE THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ON THE S. ROMMEL'S I
SERVICE LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL FOR
PUBLIC ADVOCATES. WE ARE PLEASED
TO SPONSOR AB TWENTY SEVEN TEN A
BILL THAT WILL PROTECT TENANTS
AND INCREASE CALIFORNIA'S STOCK
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING. HOME IS
OUR LIVES HAPPENED WHERE
RELATIONSHIPS TAKE PLACE AND
WHERE FAMILIES THRIVE. OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE STABLE AND
HEALTHY WHEN EVERYONE HAS A SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE HOME. HOWEVER
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO FACE A
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS
THAT PUTS FAMILIES AT RISK
DISRUPTS OUR COMMUNITIES AND
MAKE STABLE HOUSING INCREASINGLY
OUT OF REACH FOR LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
THE STATE'S STOCK OF AFFORDABLE
RENTAL HOUSING ON THE PRIVATE
MARKET IS RAPIDLY DWINDLING.
THERE ARE AROUND SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND SUCH UNITS IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THEY MAY NOT STAY
AFFORDABLE FOR LONG. OVER A FIVE
YEAR PERIOD THE BAY AREA LOST
OVER THIRTY THOUSAND AFFORDABLE
UNITS ANNUALLY. AND OVER TWENTY
YEAR PERIOD SAN DIEGO LOS 72% OF
ITS HOUSING AFFORDABLE TO VERY
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. THESE
ISSUES HAVE ONLY BEEN WORSENED
BY THE ECONOMIC CHALLENGES OF
THE PANDEMIC. AB TWENTY SEVEN
TEN WILL HELP ADDRESS THESE
CHALLENGES BY CREATING A
STATEWIDE TENANT AND COMMUNITY
OPPORTUNITY TO PURCHASE POLICY.
THAT WILL STABILIZE RENTER
HOUSEHOLDS AND INCREASE OUR
SUPPLY OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IT
WILL GIVE TENANTS IN ENTITIES
SUCH AS NONPROFIT HOUSING
DEVELOPERS AND COMMUNITY LAND
TRUSTS A FIRST OPPORTUNITY TO
PURCHASE RENTAL HOUSING WHEN
OWNERS CHOOSE TO SELL. THE BILL
WILL NOT REQUIRED UNDER TO SELL
THEIR PROPERTY OR RESTRICT THE
PRICE AT WHICH THEY CAN SELL IT
. ONCE ACQUIRED THE PROPERTIES
WILL REMAIN AFFORDABLE WITH
BUILT IN PROTECTIONS AGAINST
DISPLACEMENT OF EXISTING AND NEW
TENANTS. THESE KINDS OF RIGHT OF
FIRST OFFER POLICIES OFTEN
CALLED COPA OR COPA. ALREADY
EXIST IN SOME LOOK LOCALITIES
SUCH AS SAN FRANCISCO AND
WASHINGTON DC. AND A PROVEN TO
BE EFFECTIVE TO COMBAT
DISPLACEMENT AND INCREASE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING STOCK. THIS
BILL WILL BUILD ON THE SUCCESSES
AND BRING THIS PROVEN STRATEGY
TO THE STATE LEVEL TO HELP KEEP
MORE CALIFORNIANS HOUSE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION FOR
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
URGE HER AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
TEN. REPORTER CHECK POINT.
SURPRISED GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
OR TRYING TO GUEST ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA REINVESTMENT
COALITION IN THE PUBLIC INTEREST
LAW PROJECT ON SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. HONORABLE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AMY HÌNH SHAKE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LAND TRUST
NETWORK ARE TWENTY SIX COMMUNITY
LAND TRUST AFFILIATES AND THREE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED RESIDENTS
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND
MARK STIVERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SEVEN TEN. SEEING
NONE ARE PRETTY WOULD YOU OPEN
THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY SEVEN TEN. WE WON'T BE
TAKING ANY FURTHER TESTIMONY BUT
NAME AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT.
REPORTER FOR AB TWENTY SEVEN TEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. FIRST
WE'RE GOING TO A LINE OF ONE
TWENTY EIGHT LET'S GO AHEAD. I
WANT TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SB
ON BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS JACKET BE
WITH HOUSING CALIFORNIA WE'RE
SPONSORING THE BILL ALONG WITH
OUTLOOK ADVOCATE THAN WE THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA AND
ANDREAS RAMOS FOR THEIR
EXCELLENT TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU. DO LINE
ONE FIFTEEN ONE ONE FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI CORNELIA WOULD
HOUSING NOW IF THE WHITE HOUSE
INTO I THINK THE COALITION IN
SUPPORT. LINE ONE TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS SHE ONLY IF WE GO I'M A
MANAGING DIRECTOR WITH POLICY
LINK WHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE ONE
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MORNING THIS IS ELEANOR ON
BEHALF OF THE THAI COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT CENTER IN LOS
ANGELES WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
LEVINE ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS IGOR
TRICKLED ON BEHALF OF THE
CONDEMNED WINTERS COUNCIL AND
THE PARK WE CAN AND FEEDING AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THERE IS NO
MARKET. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
OPERATOR WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE TO LISTED THE
RECALL TEN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION AND THEN
CREAM THREE SEE. WHO WILL BE
WITH US ON THE TELEPHONE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WILL START IN THE
HEARING ROOM PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING AGAIN DEBRA CARLTON OF
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION JUST LIKE BILLS. AND
TEN TODAY IN MOST AGO SHE SHOULD
YOU HAVE THE BUYER COME TO THE
TABLE WITH A PRE APPROVAL
LETTER- THEY COME THERE BECAUSE
THEY'VE BEEN AUTHORIZED BY A
BANK OR THEY ALREADY HAVE THEIR
FUNDING IN PLACE. I THINK THIS
BILL AS YOU KNOW CREATES A YEAR
LONG EVEN LONGER PROCESS IN
WHICH- POTENTIAL BUYERS CAN COME
TO THE TABLE FOR US THAT'S JUST
VERY UNREALISTIC AND THIS IS NOT
JUST ABOUT MAINTAINING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- EVEN CLASS
SAY. HIGH RENT PROPERTIES ALSO
WOULD HAVE TO REGISTER TO GIVE A
QUALIFIED ENTITIES THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO SUBMIT AN OFFER
AND YET NOT EVEN UNDER CONTRACT
THEY WILL GET ACCESS TO TENANT
INFORMATION GRANTED NOT THE SAME
AS BEFORE AND NOT SPECIFIC
TENANT INFORMATION BUT THEY WILL
HAVE ACCESS. TO PROVIDE TENANTS
INFORMATION ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
SALE OF THE PROPERTY. THEY WILL
NOT- THEY'RE NOT YET SERIOUS
BUYERS AND EVEN TENANT
ORGANIZATIONS WILL HAVE ACCESS
TO THE TENANTS AT THE PROPERTY.
UNFORTUNATELY WE SAW DURING THE
PANDEMIC THAT AN ETHICAL NOT ALL
BUT UNETHICAL TENANT
ORGANIZATIONS DID CONVINCE
TENANTS NOT TO PAY THE RENT EVEN
IF THEY COULD THIS WILL CONTINUE
IN THE SITUATION KNOWING THAT
THE PROPERTY WILL BE SOLD WE
DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT ACCESS
THAT WOULD.INTERFERE WITH A
POTENTIAL SALE IF THIS BILL WERE
TO BECOME LAW SO FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A NO VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU AND
THEN IS KAREEM THREE C. WITH US
ON THE TELEPHONE. THERMISTOR
CARE GOOD GOOD MORNING- MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU SIR- GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS HERE IN OPPOSITION TO
AB 271-080-2710 PROHIBITS RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNERS FROM SELLING
THEIR PROPERTY TO SOMEONE OTHER
THAN OF COURSE SO CALLED
QUALIFIED ENTITY FOR UP TO
ALMOST ONE YEAR FOR EXAMPLE THE
PARENTAL PROPERTY OWNER WISHES
TO SELL THEIR PROPERTY TO
WORKING FAMILIES THAT LIVED
NEARBY WE ARE INITIALLY
PROHIBITED FROM DOING SO AND
MUST FIRST PROVIDE DISCLOSURE
PACKAGES QUOTE UNQUOTE. TO
NONPROFIT CORPORATIONS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND ALLOW
THOSE CORPORATIONS MULTIPLE
MONTHS TO CONSIDER PURCHASING
THE PROPERTY AND SECURE
FINANCING MEANING IF THE
NONPROFIT CORPORATE A NONPROFIT
CORPORATION IN WHAT STATE SAN
FRANCISCO WHICH IS TO PURCHASE A
PROPERTY IN SAN DIEGO THEY GET
FIRST DIBS ON THE PROPERTY OVER
THE WORKING FAMILIES THAT ARE
ACTUALLY LOCATED IN THAT AREA
BILLS OWNERS REQUIREMENTS ALSO
MEETING THAT IF THE PROPERTY
OWNER NEEDS TO SELL THEIR
PROPERTY QUICKLY IN ORDER TO
MOVE CLOSER TO AGING PARENTS FOR
PAID FAMILY MEDICAL BILLS THEY
MUST FIRST OFFER THE PROPERTY TO
HUNDREDS OF NON PART PROFIT
CORPORATION OTHER GROUPS. AND
WAIT FOR MONTHS ON END IN ORDER
TO ACTUALLY FINALIZE THE SALE
AND MOVE ON WITH THEIR LIVES IN
THE END THIS BILL PRIORITIZES
ORGANIZATIONS IN OTHER PARTS OF
THE STATE OVER LOCAL WORKING
FAMILIES C. A. R. RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTED NO VOTE ON AB. TWENTY
SEVEN TEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT WE'LL OPEN UP TO
OFFICE. IN THE ROOM WILL TAKE
NAME AFFILIATION. AND OPPOSITION. MISTER CHAIRMAN HIS PATRON
WITH THEIR AND READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK YOU. MY NAME IS LINDA RICH I'M A
PROPERTY OWNER IN PLASTER COUNTY
AND THE COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
I REPRESENT MYSELF. AND I'M
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL AND I'LL
QUOTE THE FIFTH THE MEN
AMENDMENT OF THE UNITED STATES
O'CONNOR WE'RE NOT USING ANY
FURTHER TESTIMONY THANK YOU.
REXDALE BAHAMA BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION ALSO OPPOSED THANK
YOU THANK YOU. RIGHT OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE OPPOSITION. TO A. B.
TWENTY SEVEN TEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO AYE CHAU OPPOSITION TO AB THE
TWENTY SEVEN TEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND OUR FIRST. PERSONAL B. Y.
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EMILY DEL ON BEHALF OF THE
COMPANY GREAT MUSIC IN
OPPOSITION. FOR ANYBODY ELSE TO
SHOW OPPOSITION- PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE HAVE A
FEW MORE QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT
THEY SHOULD BE WITH US
MOMENTARILY. M. TOTALING ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY
YOU ARE OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ONE KING REPRESENTING SEVERAL
ASSOCIATIONS THE APARTMENT-
ORANGE COUNTY. IS THE RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION THEN- THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION. SOUTHWEST AND- FIVE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA HAWAII THEY-
HAVE A VERY DIFFERENT OF COURSE
LOVE OPPOSITION BECAUSE THEY'RE
ALREADY PROVIDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PRODUCTS. AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE ONE TWENTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS CHRIS WHITE SAKE
WITH THE WESTERN MANUFACTURED
HOUSING COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION
AND WE ARE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL GO
TO LINE ONE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ANTHONY HELPING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LAND TITLE
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION AS
WELL. BY ONE THIRTY ONE YOU ARE
OPEN. YES WE CARE MEMBERS
COMMINGLED WITH CALIFORNIA
BANKERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. SURE THERE
ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED
UP ALL RIGHT THANK YOU OPERATOR
YOU MAY CLOSE THE LINES WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE MISTER KALRA YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AS
SOMEONE- WHOSE FAMILY ALSO HAS
PROPERTY THAT WE RAN- THE
REALITY IS THIS IS SUCH THAT
RIGHT NOW THE WAY THE MARKET IS
THAT WHEN PROPERTIES GO FOR ON
THE GO UP FOR SALE- USUALLY
WITHIN A DAY OR TWO FOLKS COMING-IN WITH CASH OFFERS WHAT HAVE
YOU WHAT THIS DOES IS OPTIONS
GIVEN OPPORTUNITY- FOR THE
TENANTS TO TEN ORGANIZATIONS. TO
THESE HAVE A FIGHTING CHANCE-
TO- TO PURCHASE THESE
PROPERTIES- THERE HAVE BEEN FAR
TOO MANY FAMILIES HAVE BEEN
LOCKED OUT A GENERATIONAL WEALTH
AND MUCH PART BECAUSE THE
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS THAT
EXCLUDED THEM OVER MANY DECADES-
BUT BUT IN THE CURRENT MARKET
WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW THE
REALITY IS THAT. WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING DIFFERENT THE MORE P.
BEEN DOING- YES WE HAVE TO BUILD
MORE HOUSING WE KNOW THAT'S NOT
IT BUT IN DOING THAT BY ITSELF
IS NOT ENOUGH WE HAVE TO FIND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FAMILIES TO BE
ABLE TO PURCHASE HOMES- GOING UP
AGAINST YOU KNOW INVESTORS AND
CORPORATIONS THAT. ARE BUYING UP
PROPERTIES A LARGE SWATHS IS
BRINGING IN CASH SHOPPERS AGAIN-
THE SELLER DOES NOT LOSE OUT ON
THIS AND THAT THE HIGHEST OFFER
THAT IS MADE IS THE SAME AMOUNT
OF MONEY THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT FOR A ORGANIZATION OR A
TENANT THAT WOULD THAT THE- AND
IN TERMS OF WHAT THE SALE SALE
PRICE WILL BE. AND SO WE ALL
NEED TO BE PART OF THIS SOLUTION
THAT INCLUDES THOSE THAT ARE
PROPERTY OWNERS TENANTS AND
THOSE OF US OF LEGISLATORS WE
HAVE TO FIND CREATIVE WAYS AND
OPPORTUNITIES TO ACTUALLY OPEN
THAT DOOR OF OPPORTUNITY- FOR
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES WITHOUT
RESPECT PASSED WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU WE'LL TAKE IT UP ONCE
WE HAVE QUORUM THANK RIGHT
MISTER BLOOM I DON'T NUMBER TEN
AB TWENTY FIVE TWELFTH.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS LET ME BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
COMMITTEE STAFF AND- I THANK
THEM. THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR WORK THANK YOU EVEN NOT
BEFORE THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND RESULTING ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN. IT WAS GREAT FINANCIAL
STRAIN ON MANY SANCTUARY OR
RESCUE WILD ANIMAL FACILITIES
THE POSSESS WILDLIFE PERMITTED.
BY THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE. IF THE
FACILITY CLOSES HOWEVER THE
STATE IS EXPECTED TO ASSUME
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE CARE
RELOCATION. OF A FACILITIES
ANIMALS. ADDITIONALLY AS THE
FREQUENCY SCOPE AND BREADTH OF
WILDFIRES. INCREASES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA DUE TO CLIMATE
CHANGE. MANY OF THESE
FACILITIES. FACE POTENTIAL
EMERGENCY EVACUATIONS AND
ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL PRESSURE.
OF UGH AS AN EXAMPLE IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TO FACILITY- CONDONE AS
THE WILDLIFE WAY STATION IN
CELLMARK CALIFORNIA NOT TOO FAR
FROM MY DISTRICT WHICH COULD NOT
RECOVER FINANCIALLY FROM THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN CREEK FIRE. HAD
TO CLOSE RESULTING IN THE STATE
INCURRING SIGNIFICANT STAFFING
STRAINS AND FINANCIAL COSTS FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ANIMALS HAD
TO BE CARED FOR AND PLACED IN
THAT SITUATION THE COST TO THE
STATE IN ASSISTING WITH. THIS
FACILITY CLOSURE ALONE WAS
SIGNIFICANT AS THE DEPARTMENT
SEES- IN PLACE ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ANIMALS THAT
WERE HOUSED AT THE WILDLIFE WAY
STATION. OF THE DEPARTMENT HAS
SPENT APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN FACILITY
MAINTENANCE DAILY CARE OF THE
ANIMALS STAFFING PURCHASING OF
FOOD WATER AND EQUIPMENT. SITE
SECURITY VETERINARY CARE AND
OTHER ESSENTIAL SERVICES SO AB
TWENTY FIVE TWELVE MAKE SEVERAL
CHANGES TO THE FISH AND GAME
CODE TO REDUCE THE BURDEN OF
THESE CLOSURES ON THE DEPARTMENT
AND STATE. REDUCE REST OF THE
PUBLIC NATIVE WILDLIFE AND
AGRICULTURE CAUSED BY SOME
CAPTIVE WILD ANIMAL ANIMAL
SPECIES AND ALLOWS THE
DEPARTMENT TO MOVE MORE QUICKLY
TO ENSURE THAT ANIMALS AT THESE
FACILITIES CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
APPROPRIATE AND NECESSARY CARE.
IT DOES THIS BY MAKING SEVERAL
CHANGES TO THE FISH AND GAME
CODE THAT WILL GIVE CDFW CLEAR
AUTHORITY TO LIMIT OR PROHIBIT
ANIMALS AND THEIR USES GIVE CDFW
THE ABILITY TO REMEDY VIOLATIONS
AND GIVES THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCIAL ASSURANCE. BY BEING
ABLE TO ADJUST EXISTING FEES ALL
THESE CHANGES WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED BY PUBLIC PROCESS
THROUGH THE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION WITH STAKEHOLDER
INPUT. WHERE ACTIVELY WORKING TO
WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
THAT HAVE COME UP- WHICH WILL
TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF TIME BUT
WE'RE TRYING TO WORK OUT THESE
CONCERNS WITH OPPOSITION. AT THE
END OF THE DAY THIS BILLS ABOUT
MAKING. EXCUSE ME. MAKING SURE
THAT THERE IS A SAFETY NET FOR
THESE FACILITIES AND THAT THE
BURDEN IS NOT SOLELY ON THE
STATE THANK YOU AND I ASK FOR
YOUR- I VOTED TO- I AM AVAILABLE
ALONG WITH MIKE A CHIEF OF
STAFF. TO ANSWER- TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THAT MAY COME UP.
THANK YOU RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FIVE TWELVE. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
TWENTY FIVE TWELVE. SHOW SUPPORT
FOR AB TWENTY FIVE TWELVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE
FALL BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIR NOBODY IS QUEUING
UP. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION I HAVE
ONE LISTED MATT BROAD FROM THE
CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS WITH THIS ON BY
TELEPHONE. ARE YOU WITH US. HI
MISTER CHAIR I'M HERE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. YES OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER CARE MEMBERS MAP RIGHT
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS WE ARE BACK RESPECTFUL-
OPPOSING WHAT THE MAGNITUDE
ISSUE THE BILL. AT PRESENT
MEMBERS IN THAT AND TELEVISION
INDUSTRY THAT YOU'RE IN A MORE
HANDLING TRAINING AND DRIVING-
AND TO THAT END WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS ABOUT THE
PORTION OF THE BILL THAT WOULD
ESSENTIALLY GIVE THE DEPARTMENT
THAT BILL IN. TO CREATE A LIST
OF ANIMALS THAT COULD NO LONGER
BE THAT SLIP IN THE STATE IF AN
ANIMAL THAT ONE OF OUR TRAINERS
USES END UP ON THAT LET IN.
THEIR CULTURE AND DETECTION I IN
CALIFORNIA WHETHER BE A MOVIE OR
TELEVISION THEY WOULD- YES THIS
HAVE TO GO FILM OUT OF STATE SO
THAT'S SORT OF THE NEXT. THREAT
TO THE WORKER MEMBERS DEAL THAT
SAID- WE COMMUTE TO DOCTOR'S
OFFICE THAT WE ARE WILLING TO
WORK WITH THEM. ON THE FINANCIAL
SOLVENCY PORTION OF THE BILL-
ALL OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE GENERAL
LIABILITY INSURANCE POLICY IF
THEY'RE COMPLIANT WITH ALL. THE
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL LEVEL
THE USDA CERTIFIED VETERINARIANS
FOR OTHER ANIMALS AND ARE
COMPLIANT WITH THE NEW FEDERAL
REGULATIONS REQUIRING AN
EMERGENCY ACTION PLAN. THE
DEPARTMENT AT THE BET I WOULD
RECOMMEND CODIFYING BEAST I
REQUIREMENTS IN THAT WOULD
CERTAINLY GO A LONG WAY TOWARDS
IDENTIFYING WHO'S A GOOD ACTOR
AND HE'S A BAD ACTOR MAKING SURE
OUR MEMBERS JOBS ARE PROTECTED.
WILL CONTINUE WE'RE WORKING
WITH- THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE BUT
FOR TODAY WE CONTINUE TO BE A
CUT. BACK THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND THEN WE'LL DO HAVE. LISTED
CHASE BRIAN FOR THE SOLAR LIST.
OF AMERICA WITH US ON THE- OUR
WITH US. GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIR I'M HERE WHAT.
THAT MEASURE MEMBERS- JASON
BRYANT ON BEHALF OF THE
UROLOGICAL ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICA AND THE ACCREDITED ZOOS
IN CALIFORNIA- THROUGH
DISASSOCIATION. WE HAVE A
RESPECTFUL OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL AND ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR IN THE DEPARTMENT LOOKING
FORWARD. YOU KNOW WE SHARE THE
AUTHORS GOAL OF MAKING SURE THAT
ANIMAL FACILITIES ARE
FINANCIALLY SOUND. TO ENSURE
THAT. WE PREVENT WHAT OCCURRED
IT BUT THE WILDLIF PLAYSTATION
WHICH IS A NON ACCREDITED
FACILITY- BACK IN TWENTY
NINETEEN- HOWEVER WE HAVE
CONCERNS THAT SECTIONS OF THE
BILL THAT GIVE THE DEPARTMENT-
EMERGENCY RULE MAKING AUTHORITY.
TO PROHIBIT EVEN REMOVE THE
SPECIES FROM AN ACCREDITED SALE
AND WE HAVE CONCERNS BUT THE
PROVISIONS THAT IMPOSE THOSE
FEES THAT ARE DUPLICATIVE WE
THANK AND- AND PERHAPS
UNNECESSARY GIVEN THE FINANCIAL
STAY. THAT ARE THROUGH CREDIT-
AND JUST SPEAKING AB TODAY MOST
RECENT SET OF AMENDMENTS THAT WE
ARE LOOKING AT RECEIVED LAST
WEEK. YOU KNOW FROM IS A LOGICAL
STANDPOINT. THE LANGUAGE APPEARS
TO BE SIMILAR TO WHAT IS
DESCRIBED IN THE ACCREDITATION
STANDARDS OF JUST ONE OF THE TWO
MAJORS OF A LOGICAL
ACCREDITATION ORGANIZATIONS IN
THE STATE. AND I DON'T A
CORPORATE MORE COMPREHENSIVE
ANIMAL MANAGEMENT PROGRAMS THAT
THAT- THAT ARE OFFERED THROUGH-
MY CLIENTS ACCREDITATION
STANDARDS- YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY WE
CARE AND WE'RE CONCERNED LIKE
THE DEPARTMENT OF THE AUTHOR
ABOUT. ENSURING THAT WHAT
OCCURRED AT THE WILDLIFE WAY
STATION DOES NOT HAPPEN AGAIN-
ARE ZOOS HAVE WORKED CLOSELY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO ACCEPT. A
NUMBER OF THE ANIMALS THAT
NEEDED CARE AFTER THE CLOSURE OF
THAT WILDLIFE WAY STATION. FOR
EXAMPLE THE ORANGE COUNTY ZOO
WHICH IS A MEMBER OF OUR
ASSOCIATION TOOK AN EIGHT
ANIMALS FROM THE DEPARTMENT.
THAT HELPED IN AND ASSIST WITH
THE CLOSURE OF THAT FACILITY.
AND THAT FACILITY ORANGE COUNTY
ZOO- WHICH IS ACCREDITED BY THE
AA HAS TAKEN IN TWENTY FIVE
ANIMALS. FROM THE DEPARTMENT
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SIX AND
MANY OF THOSE ALRP STILL HOUSING
PROTECTED AT THAT FACILITY
TODAY. AT MANY OF THE OTHER THE
AGES OF DONE THE SAME- WE ARE
ENTRUSTED BY THE DEPARTMENT TO
BE GOOD STEWARDS OF THE SEASON
WELFARE AND MANAGEMENT. AND
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE WORK THE
AUTHOR. TO ADDRESS THOSE
FINANCIAL SECURITY REQUIREMENTS-
AND- WE LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
PROCESS. AND HOPING WE CAN GET
TO A SOLUTION THAT. THAT
RECOGNIZES- THE CERTIFICATION-
IN ACCREDITATION STANDARDS OF
FALLS IS. WE CAN REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL BUT UNTIL
THEN WE REMAIN RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
PAUSE WITH THE TESTIMONY AND
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. STONE HERE
CUNNINGHAM. HIRSON HOLDEN KALRA
. KILEY MAIENSCHEIN REYES. RE
REFER US. LEE WICKS HERE. WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM AND I WILL NOTE
THAT. MR PATTERSON. MISTER LIAM
IS WICKS ARE JOINING US HERE
TODAY ON A TEMPORARY BASIS AND I
APPRECIATE THEIR WILLINGNESS. TO
SERVE WITH US ALL RIGHTS WE'VE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM GOOD LORD.
THAT WILL MOVE TO OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION ANYONE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO
INDICATE OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
FIVE TWELFTH. AT MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURST AT PETE MONTGOMERY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ZOOS AND
AQUARIUMS NOT IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL BUT I THOUGHT I. WITH
THE CHURCH PERMISSION JUST
EXPLAIN OUR POSITION SINCE. MANY
MEMBERS HAVE MANY MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE HAVE BECAUSE THE
FACILITIES IN THE DISTRICT
INCLUDING INCLUDING THE CHAIR I
KNOW YOU'VE HEARD FROM MONTEREY
BAY AQUARIUM ON THIS BILL- WE
ARE- WE HAD SOME WILL BE ISSUED
A LETTER OF CONCERN PARTICULARLY
AROUND SECTION TWO ONE ONE NINE.
THE AMENDMENTS WHICH ARE IN THE
ANALYSIS IN WHICH THE AUTHOR. IS
ACCEPTING- ALLEVIATE THOSE
CONCERNS- THEY'RE STILL TO
AREAS. THE FINANCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY PIECE WHICH NEEDS
SOME WORK AS WELL AS THE IMPORT
SPECIES IN AQUATIC SPECIES
PIECE- GIVEN THE POSITIVE TRACK
RECORD WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OVER THE LAST
FEW MONTHS ON THIS BILL WE FEEL
VERY CONFIDENT THAT WE'LL GET TO
A POSITION OF. BEING OKAY WITH
THE BILL SO WE DO APPRECIATE THE
HARD WORK FROM- MR BLOOM AND HIS
STAFF. SO AGAIN JUST AGAIN ONE
BEHALF OF BECAUSE OF- WE REMAIN
CONCERNED ABOUT THOSE TWO PARTS
BUT WE FEEL CONFIDENT WE'LL GET
TO A PLACE OF. BEING OKAY. GOOD
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY FIVE TWELVE ALL RIGHT SEE
NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANY OTHER OPPOSITION
TO AB TWENTY FIVE TWELVE. I THIS
SHOW OPPOSITION FOR AB TWENTY
FIVE CALL PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME ONE FALL BY ZERO
FOR OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY FIVE
TWELVE. MISTER CHAIR NOBODY IS
KILLING UP. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
ARE PRETTY MAY CLOSE THE LINES
WILL BRING IT BACK TO. THE
COMMITTEE AND MUSLIM THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
ON THIS I THINK THE OPPOSITION.
TO RAISE SOME SOME GOOD POINTS.
IT MOST OF THOSE ARE REALLY
OUTSIDE THE JURISDICTION OF THIS
COMMITTEE. SO FROM OUR
STANDPOINT I THINK THIS BILL IS
DEFINITELY WORTHY OF PASSING BUT
I ALSO KNOW YOUR COMMITMENT TO
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION WITH
THOSE GROUPS AS WELL AS- THE
DEPARTMENTS AND- AS YOU'RE
BROKERING THAT BETWEEN THOSE
GROUPS THEY HAVE THAT FOR ME
THAT'S NOT ALWAYS. EASY TO DO IT
WILL TAKE SOME TIME BUT- I THINK
THIS BILL IS WORTHY OF PASSING
THIS COMMITTEE. AT THIS POINT.
THE OPPOSITION POINTS ARE ARE
NOTED AND CERTAINLY TALK ABOUT
IN THE ANALYSIS AND I HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT. THOSE CAN BE
WORKED OUT. OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS SEEING NONE MR BLOOMING
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU OUT- WILL-
AS INDICATED BY ALL OF THE-
OPPONENTS WHO SPOKE- WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON THE ISSUES THAT
THEY RAISE WILL CONTINUE TO DO
SO AND TO HOPEFULLY RESOLVE ALL
OF THEM AS WE MOVE FORWARD AS
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU I
CAN'T BELIEVE I CAN SAY THIS BUT
THAT'S- WELL TAKE A MOTION.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE. AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NO
PATTERSON HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN REYES FIVE
REYES AYE RIVAS. RIVAS I LEE
WICKS FIVE WEEKS I. THAT NEEDS
ONE MORE SO WE'LL PUT IT ON CALL
THANK YOU. RIGHT MS WICKS I
REMEMBER FOURTEEN AB. TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTEEN. QUESTION START
WITH THAT. HELLO MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO BOTH BE ON THE
COMMITTEE TODAY TO PRESENT MY
BILL. AB SEVEN AT TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTEEN IS A BILL TO CLOSE SOME
LOOPHOLES THAT HAVE BEEN
DISCOVERED IN THE TENANT
PROTECTION ACT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN ALSO. KNOWN BY ITS BILL
NUMBERS FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO. AB
FORTY TWO WAS A LANDMARK BILL
THAT I WAS VERY PROUD TO JOIN
AUTHOR. IT GAVE EIGHT MILLION
CALIFORNIANS PROTECTION AGAINST
RENT GOUGING FOR VOTES
EVICTIONS. THE BILL WAS HIGHLY
NEGOTIATED. AND AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTEEN IS IN NO WAY TRYING TO
RE OPEN THE PARAMETERS OF AB
FORTY TWO BUT ONLY TO CLOSE SOME
LOOPHOLES THAT WE- HAVE SEEN
HAPPEN WHICH WE BELIEVE GO
AGAINST THE TRUE INTENT OF THE
BILL. FORTY TWO INCLUDED
EXTREMELY REASONABLE TERMS FOR
PROPERTY OWNERS THAT ALLOW THEM
TO MAKE A DECENT RETURN ON THEIR
pTENANTS AT FAULT. A VIOLATION OF
THEIR LEASE. ENDS TO CHOOSE TO
TERMINATE THE LEASE OF TENANTS
WHO ARE ABIDING BY THE RULES IN
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES INCLUDING
WHEN THE OWNER WANTED TO DO ONE
OF THE FOLLOWING THINGS. ONE OF
ROOM- THEY WANTED TO MOVE
THEMSELVES OR A FAMILY MEMBER
INTO UNIT TO THEY WANT TO
SUBSTANTIALLY. REHAB THE UNIT IN
A WAY THAT MAKES IT TEMPORARILY
UNINHABITABLE OR THREE THEY WANT
TO TAKE THE UNIT COMPLETELY OFF
THE RENTAL MARKET. THOSE ARE ALL
REASONABLE TERMS BY WHICH TO
REMOVE THE TENANT. WHILE THESE
NO FAULT CAUSES WERE AGREED TO
IS REASONABLE WHAT WE'VE SEEN ON
THE GROUND IS THAT SOME PROPERTY
OWNERS ARE EXPLOITING. THESE
LOOPHOLES BY TERMINATING
TENANCIES FOR THE CAUSES I JUST
LISTED BUT NEVER ACTUALLY
FOLLOWING THROUGH WITH THE
ACTION. THAT IS THEY GET A
TENTATIVE ACTED BUT THEY NEVER
ACTUALLY MOVE INTO THE UNIT RE
RE HAVE THE UNIT- OR TAKE IT OFF
THE RENTAL MARKET. IN FACT WHAT
WE'VE SEEN IN SOME SITUATIONS IS
MERELY WEEKS AFTER ONE TENANT IS
AFFECTED ANOTHER ONE- IS IN
THEIR- PLACE PAYING A MUCH
HIGHER RENT THAN WHAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN ALLOWED BY THE ENTIRE AND
CATCHING. MEASURE IN AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO. AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTEEN WILL PLUG THOSE
LOOPHOLES BY REQUIRING PROPERTY
OWNERS TO FOLLOW THROUGH WITH
THE ACTION- THAT WAS THE
JUSTIFICATION FOR REMOVING A
TENANT THAT OTHERWISE. NO CAUSE
FOR EVICTION. THE BILL SPONSORED
BY THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND THE CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND
SUPPORTED BY. LEGAL
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE.
WE KNOW. IT IS OPPOSED BY THE
LANDLORD ORGANIZATIONS AND I AM
VERY WILLING T WORK WITH THEM A
VERY WILLING TO THINK ABOUT.
WAYS WE CAN BE IN THE MIDDLE WE
CAN COMPROMISE ON SOME LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD WORK FOR THEM AND
WORK FOR US- WE WANT TO TRY TO
FIND COMMON GROUND AS WE DID
FORTY TWO AND I KNOW FORTY TWO
WAS. WAS A LANDMARK DEAL AND I
DO THINK. YOU KNOW THE
OPPOSITION THAT IS NOT POSITION
TO THIS BILL. REALLY WORKED IN
EARNEST IN GOOD FAITH TO GET TO
A COMPROMISE ON THAT BILL- AND I
RESPECT THAT AND I KNOW THEY
WERE VERY. ACTIVE AND WILLING
PARTICIPANTS IN THAT AND I MY
HOPES THEY WILL COME TO THE
TABLE IN THIS BILL AS WELL. WE
CAN FIND SOME KIND OF A
COMPROMISE- HERE TO TESTIFY-
WITH ME IN SUPPORT IT'S BRENDA
GUEST A- FROM C. R. L. A.
FOUNDATION. AND SERRA STEINHEIM
FROM THE LEGAL SERVICES OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
FIRST WITNESS PLEASE GOOD
MORNING I AM SERRA ST
HAMMERSCHMIDT HOUSING ATTORNEY
AT LEGAL SERVICES OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE PROVIDE LEGAL
SERVICES TO LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AND SPECIFICALLY
TENANTS IN TWENTY THREE
COUNTIES. THE LACK OF AFFORDABLE
AND STABLE HOUSING IS THE NUMBER
ONE LEGAL PROBLEM TO CLIENTS
CALL US ABOUT IN EVERY COUNTY WE
WORK IN. AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTEEN BECAUSE
IT WILL CLOSE LOOPHOLES THAT
HAVE RESULTED IN IN OUR CLIENTS
LOSING THEIR HOMES ONCE OF SUCH
LOOPHOLE IS WHEN A LANDLORD
SERVED A NOTICE OF TERMINATION
STATING A FAMILY MEMBER INTENDS
TO MOVE IN. WE HAVE SEEN CASES
WHERE THE TERMINATION WAS BASED
ON THESE GROUNDS BUT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES STRONGLY SUGGESTED
THE OWNER. DID NOT INTEND TO
LIVE IN TO THE RENTAL HOME AND
IN FACT NEVER MOVED IN. IN ONE
CASE OUR CLIENT LIVED IN
APARTMENT COMPLEX WITH ABOUT
THIRTY APARTMENTS. HE RECEIVED A
NOTICE STATING A FAMILY MEMBER
INTENDED TO MOVED INTO HIS
PARTICULAR APARTMENT. THE FAMILY
MEMBER WHO ALLEGEDLY PLANNED TO
MOVE IN LIVED OUT OF STATE OWNED
A HOME IN THAT STATE AND WAS A
LICENSED REAL ESTATE AGENT IN
THAT STATE. THAT FAMILY MEMBER
HAD ACTIVE REAL ESTATE LISTING
SUGGESTED THEY CONTINUE TO WORK
IN THE STATE. OUR CLIENT DID
MOVE OUT THE FAMILY MEMBER
CONTINUE TO HAVE ACTIVE REAL
ESTATE LISTINGS OUT OF STATE
SUGGESTING THEY REMAINED OUT OF
STATE. IN ANOTHER CASE OUR
CLIENT LIVED IN A SMALL MULTI
FAMILY COMPLEX HE RECEIVED A
NOTICE OF INTENT. OF OWNER MOVE
IN. AND REPORTED THAT HIS
NEIGHBOR RECEIVED THE SAME
NOTICE. HIS NEIGHBOR THEN MOVED
OUT AND HE THEN SAW THE MANAGER.
HAVE AN OPEN HOUSE TO RE RENT
THE NEIGHBOR'S APARTMENT. WE
HAVE ALSO SEEN LANDLORDS AND TEA
ENTIRE APARTMENT COMPLEXES AND
RAISE RENTS AFTER SERVING LONG
TIME TENANTS SUBSTANTIAL
REHABILITATION NOTICES. IN ONE
RECENT CASE OUR CLIENT WHO IS
SENIOR AND A SENIOR AND JUST AND
BEDRIDDEN. DUE TO PHYSICAL
DISABILITY SPACE THE LOSS OF THE
HOME **** RENDON FOR SIX YEARS.
THE OWNER GAVE ALL TENANTS IN
THE SMALL APARTMENT COMPLEX
ASSEMBLY HAD NOTICED THAT SIMPLY
SAID THE OWNER WILL BE
REMODELING. THE OWNER HAD NOT
PULLED ANY PERMITS AND ALL OF
OUR INVESTIGATION SHOWED THAT
THE ONLY REPAIRS BEING DONE WERE
COSMETICS SUCH AS PAINTING. OR
OTHER MINOR REPAIRS THAT DID NOT
REQUIRE TENANTS TO MOVE OUT.
DISCOVERY IN THE CASE CONFIRMED
THAT THE TECH THAT THE LANDLORD
WAS NOT DOING REPAIRS THAT ROSE
TO SUBSTANTIAL REHABILITATION.
HOWEVER ALL TENANTS EXCEPT FOR
OUR CLIENT. MOVED OUT AND THOSE
VACATED UNITS ARE NOW RENTING
440270% MORE THAN AT THE TIME OF
THE SUBSTANTIAL RECAP NOTICES.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE TO CLOSE THESE LOOPHOLES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK
GOODNESS PLEASE. BY MISTER
CHAIRMAN BRIAN AUGUSTA RIGHT.
AND MEMBERS PROGRESS WITH
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND
SUPPORT- THE AUTHOR IS. LAID OUT
THE NEED FOR THE BILL AND I
THINK MISTER NUMBERS- EXAMPLES.
ILLUSTRATE THE PROBLEM THAT
WE'VE SEEN. THE REASON THAT WE
HAVE THIS BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY
IS. NOT TO REVISIT THE DEAL THAT
ARE- THAT MS WICKS DESCRIBED
ESSENTIALLY TO HONOR THAT DEAL
AND THE DEAL INCLUDED THAT.
AMONG THE REASONS THAT A TENER
COULD BE AFFECTED IS FOR WHAT WE
CALLED NO FAULT REASONS THE
THREE REASONS THAT THE AUTHOR
HAS LISTED OUT WHICH INCLUDE.
OWNER MOVE IN SUBSTANTIAL REHAB
REMOVAL FROM THE RENTAL MARKET
BUT IF. OF THE MAILERS GOING TO
RELY ON THOSE SPECIES. THAT
NEEDS TO BE A REAL BASIS AND
THAT. HAS MISSED NINE NUMBERS
ILLUSTRATED TOO OFTEN IS NOT THE
CASE THE USE THAT NOTICE. TO
REMOVE FOLKS AND THEN. NEVER
CARRY OUT THE STATED REASON AND
SO ALL THIS BILL DOES IS PUT
SOME TRUTH AROUND THAT IF THAT
IS THE STATE A REASON THAT
YOU'RE MOVING IN. YOU HAVE TO
ACTUALLY MOVE AND IF YOU'RE
SAYING THAT YOU'RE GOING TO STAY
REHAB. DONE THAT YOU HAVE THE
PER. AND THAT YOU. AND THAT YOU
ARE ENGAGED IN THE REHAB THAT IS
REQUIRED THAT MEETS THE STANDARD
IN THE BILL- IF YOU'RE REMOVING
IT FROM THE RENTAL MARKET
EXPLAIN WHAT YOU'RE INTENDING TO
DO IS TO REMOVE. REMOVED
PROPERTY AND FOR THOSE REASONS
WE THINK IT'S CONSISTENT WITH
THE AGREEMENT. IT HONORS THE
AGREEMENT WHICH IS THAT WE RE
NOT GOING TO ALLOW TENANTS. TO
BE EVICTED FOR NO REASON OR
FOREVER FOR A REASON THAT
DOESN'T MEET THE STANDARD IN THE
LAW. AND WE THINK WITH PASSAGE
OF THIS BILL WE WILL. ENSURE
THAT THAT IS TRUE AND SO FOR
THOSE REASONS WITH ASPIN I
THOUGHT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
OTHERS IN THE HEARING ROOM IN
SUPPORT WE WILL TAKE FURTHER
TESTIMONY BUT NAME AFFILIATION
THAT SUPPORT PARKS TIRES
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. CHEN
MEMBERS ON THIS PROMISE WITH
pSUPPORT. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
IN THE HEARING ROOM. RIGHT SAY
NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB.
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTEEN. TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
WHEN FILED BY ZERO AND I MISTER
CARROLL BEGAN TO FIND SEVENTY
EIGHT. I GOOD MORNING WE'RE
BACKING OF DOLLARS TO THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT. I NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I NINETY NINE
YOU ARE OPEN. OH ONE MORE SHOT
LINE NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. I AM I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE ONE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING
TWENTY FOUR THE WAY I THINK
SECATEURS DR HOUSING NOW IN
STRONG SUPPORT. BY ONE THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR OPEN. A GOOD MORNING
SURE MEMBERS ENTERTAINMENT ON
BEHALF OF THE THAI COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT CENTER IN LOS
ANGELES IN STRONG SUPPORT. ONE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING TERRY MEMBERS
CAMERA BALLERS ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN CENTER HOST FUNCTION THE
BILL AND SUPPORT AS WELL AS ON
BEHALF OF PUBLIC THANK YOU. AND
THERE'S A REMINDER TO SHOWS THE
FOR. AB TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ZERO AND WE WILL GO LINE
ONE THIRTY NINE. HI MY NAME IS
AMIT IS ON CALLING BEHALF OF.
LATINO WITH THAT JEFF.
FAHNENJUNKER WITH THE THANK YOU. AMATEUR WE DO HAVE ONE MORE Q.
UP THIS BE WHAT THE MOMENT.
BUT WILL THE LINE ONE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS SPECIFICALLY
COURT TACKLED ON BEHALF OF THE
BERKELEY TENANTS UNION STRONG
SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIR NOBODY
ELSE'S QUEUED UP. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION. THE RICCARTON FROM
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION HERE IN PERSON AND
THEN CREAM THREE C. FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WITH US ON THE
TELEPHONE. HELLO AGAIN HELLO
AGAIN THE LAST TIME. TODAY YET
TO A DIFFICULTY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
UNFORTUNATELY WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE TODAY WE
BELIEVE THIS IS NOT JUST CLEAN
UP NOT JUST CLOSING LOOPHOLES OF
FOR EXAMPLE AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTEEN REQUIRES A PROPERTY
OWNER OR A FAMILY MEMBER A TO
LIVE IN THE PROPERTY FOR AT
LEAST THREE YEARS THIS DOESN'T
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION A CHILD
THAT MAY NEED THE UNIT TO GO TO
COLLEGE OR A RANDPARENT WHO MAY
NEED. THE HOUSING IN THEIR FINAL
YEARS IT DOESN'T ALLOW A FAMILY
MEMBER TO MOVE AND IF ANOTHER
FAMILY MEMBER ALREADY LIVES IN
THE BUILDING. YEAH AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE PRIOR TO TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTEEN WAS CRAFTED BY
TEN ORGANIZATIONS. THEY HAD OVER
A HUNDRED AND THIRTY ATTENDED
AND LABOR UNION ORGANIZATIONS IN
SUPPORT ORGANIZATION CAME TO THE
TABLE IN GOOD FAITH I CANNOT
OVER ESTIMATE WHAT A BIG DEAL
THAT WAS FOR ORGANIZATION TO
COME TO THE TABLE AND AGREE TO
RENT CAPS. HISTORIC AND WHILE
BASIC JUST CAUSE. PROVISIONS
WERE INCLUDED IN THE LAW IT DID
LEAVE TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THE
ABILITY TO PROVIDE MORE
STRINGENT JUST BECAUSE
PROVISIONS. AT THE SAME TIME AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO DID NOT
AFFECT COSTA HAWKINS RELL
HOUSING ACT. GIVING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE ABILITY TO
IMPLEMENT MORE STRINGENT RENT
CONTROL PROVISIONS. AND FINALLY
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC FOR THE LAST
TWO YEARS YOU HAVE NOT
TECHNICALLY BEEN ABLE TO A VIC
SOMEBODY. EVEN THOUGH THEY- HAVE
NOT PAID THE RENT- AB FORTY NAY
TO TRULY HASN'T TAKEN EFFECT IT
WAS SIGNED INTO LAW AT THE END
OF TWENTY NINETEEN WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT AS A RESULT. OF THE
PANDEMIC AND THE ADDICTION
PROTECTIONS- THAT THIS BILL IS
NEEDED- THERE ARE NO LOOPHOLES
TO A CLOSE AND WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND THEN
CREAM THREE C. ON THE TELEPHONE
ARE YOU WITH US. YES GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS-
CLEAN GREASY AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS HERE IN OPPOSITION AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTEEN.
RESPECTFULLY THIS BILL MOVES THE
GOAL POSTS ON THE HEAVILY
NEGOTIATED PROVISIONS OF AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO BY AMONG
OTHER THINGS PROPOSING AN
OWNER'S THREE YEAR MOVING
REQUIRED- THE BILL'S OWN
ANALYSIS ON A. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY ONE WHICH WAS THE JUST
BECAUSE BILL IN TWENTY NINETEEN
PRIOR TO BEING ROLLED IN AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TO. QUOTE IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT JUST
BECAUSE PROTECTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE NOT NOVEL.
SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA CITIES HAVE
ENACTED YET BECAUSE THE VISION
PART. OR AND QUITE. INDEED
NATALIE HAD SEVENTEEN CITIES. TO
BECAUSE WE'RE- PRIOR TO BE. OF A
BEFORE EIGHTY TWO. BUT SEVERAL
OF THOSE- ORDINANCES FEATURE
THIS. THREE YEAR- OWNER MOVING
REQUIRED. THAT NOW BEING
PROPOSED MAYBE TO SEVENTH. IN
OTHER. THE SPONSORS WERE MUCH
WHERE DECORATIVE AT THE LOW
LEVEL AND TIME TO BE. SHE TWO.
AND YET THEY NEVER TRIED INCLUDE
PROVISION IN AB. EIGHTY DURING
THE MANY MONTHS OF DAY AND
BECAUSE- AND THE REASON THEY DID
NOT IT'S BECAUSE THEIR GOAL OF
THE PEOPLE. EIGHTY TWO. WHICH
WAS TO A BASE. STATE JUST CAUSE
STANDARD WOULD YOU. OF WHAT
GOVERNMENT TO ADOPT THIS.
STANDARD IF THEY SO CHOOSE. AB
EIGHTY TWO DOES THAT AND FOR THE
SPONSORS TO NOW CLAIM THAT THERE
SIMPLY BECAUSE- ANY ANTICIPATED
LOOPHOLES IS RESPECTFULLY.
CONCERNING WE ARE WE HAVE. WORK
WITH THE SPONSOR UNNATURAL FORTY
EIGHTY TWO UP WITH AB THIRTY
EIGHTY EIGHT. TWO AND WE WERE
SETTLING THE ARE IN THE SPONSOR
TO WAIT FOR THE RIVER. FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE PANEL OFFICE ON THE
EFFICACY OF THE B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TO KEEP. FOR MAKING
SUBSTANTIAL. TO THE HEAVILY
NEGOTIATED PROVISIONS BABY
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO. WE RESPECT
REQUEST A NO VOTE ON AB TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTEEN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN THE- ROOM WHO LIKE TO. INTO
OPPOSITE TO A- TWO SEVEN
THIRTEEN. AND WILL TAKE NAME
AFFILIATION AND OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS PAT MORAN
WITH THEIR AND READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. REXDALE
BEHIND THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION ALSO POST
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
IN THE HEARING ROOM. I'D SAY
NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTEEN. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
TO AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO ONE FILED
BY ZERO. THIS CHAIR WILL GO TO
LINE ONE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIRED
MEMBERS KATE BALLOT BEHALF
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION AND THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION OF GREATER LA IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. AND AS A
REMINDER TO- TO TOUCH OUR TO
SHOW OPPOSITION FOR TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AND WE WANT TO ONE NINE ONE
TWENTY YOU ARE OPEN. ONE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS IS
RUN KICKS IN I REPRESENT THE-
EASTBAY RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION AND THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION OF ORANGE COUNTY-
JOINING THE REST OF THE
OPPOSITION ASKING FOR NO VOTE
TANK YOU. HI MISTER CHAIR
NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUED UP TO THANK
LINES AND I'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS PLEASE REST. I DO
APPRECIATE THAT THE COMMENTS IN
YOUR OPENING STATEMENT OF THE
ALSO FROM- THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION ABOUT ALL OF THE
WORK THAT WAS PUT INTO THE
ORIGINAL BILL AND HOPE THAT THE
OPPOSITION. OF THE PORTS FROM
THE OPPOSITION ARE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE BILL- WITH THAT
I WOULD MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THAT MOTION IS TO PASS OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. RIGHT SEE
NONE THE SIX THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS OFFERED
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH THE-
OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL INTO THE
OPPOSITION I WOULD SUGGEST
SITTING DOWN AND BEING WILLING
TO WORK ON IT I THINK. THIS
LOOKS YOU HAVE ARTICULATED A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE. AND IF THERE
IS A WAY TO ADDRESS THAT. AND I
THINK YOUR INTENTION IS NOT TO
OPEN UP THE DEAL BUT TO GO AFTER
SOME. IN SOME WAYS THAT THAT IT
SEEMS THAT THAT DEAL IS BEING.
NOT HONORABLY IMPLEMENTED SHALL
WE SAY IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
THAT'S A LEGITIMATE ISSUE TO
WORK OUTSIDE. RESHAPE THE BELL
AND YOUR OPENNESS TO SOLVE THE
ISSUES AS PRESENTED WITH THAT
YOU MAY CLOSE APPRECIATE BOTH
COMES FROM YOU MISTER CHAIR AS
WELL AS YOU MISS REYES- I AM
VERY HAPPY SIT DOWN WITH THEM I
THINK WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS
ACTUALLY HONOR THE TRUE INTENT
OF THE BILL- IF SOMEONE NEEDS TO
MOVE IN. THEY SHOULD MOVE IN AND
I THINK THE VAST MAJORITY OF
LANDLORDS ARE GOOD LANDLORDS WHO
WANTED TENANTS WHO WANT A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR TENANT-
WHO I THINK. YOU KNOW- ACT
HONORABLY BUT I DO THINK WE HAVE
SOME SITUATIONS WHERE. AND THAT
IS THE CASE THAT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT- WERE CRAFTING A BILL
THAT- IS EFFECTIVE IN BOTH YOU
KNOW- ENSURING THAT THE TENANT
HAS THE PROTECTIONS THAT WERE
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL. BUT
ALSO GIVEN THE LANDLORD THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT WE KNOW THAT
THEY NEED IF THEY NEED A FAMILY
MEMBER TO MOVE AND- YOU KNOW IF
THEY WANT TO DO A BIG REHAB
PROJECT WHATEVER IT IS THAT THEY
ARE ABLE TO DO THAT AS WELL. I'M
SO HAPPY TO SIT DOWN WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO HAVE FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS- AND I WOULD LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT AND APPRECIATE
THE COMMENT WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY VOTE. THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND THAT
MOTION IS TO PASS CALDERON
PLEASE STONE. AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NO
PATTERSON. HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN.
REYES HI REYES AYE RIVAS. RIVAS
I LEE HI LEE AYE WICKS AYE WICKS
AYE. THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY THAT IS ALL OF
THE BILLS LET'S NOW ROLL THROUGH
OUR AGENDA PLEASE AND WE HAVE A
WHOLE BUNCH OF MOTIONS TO MAKE
I'LL TAKE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA. THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A MOTIONAND A SECOND ON
THE CONSENT AGENDA CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
PATTERSON. HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAINTAIN AYE REYES AYE REYES AYE
RIVAS RIVAS I LI. LI I WICKS
WEBSITE SO THOSE BILLS ARE OUT
THAT IS AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY ONE
DALY A. B. SEVENTEEN TWENTY
THREE PATTERSON AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY NINE FRIEDMAN AB TWENTY
THREE OH SIX COOLEY AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY ONE RUBIO. AB TWENTY
FIVE OH TWO CERVANTES AB TWENTY
SIX SIXTY FIVE CARDIO AB TWENTY
SEVEN ELEVEN CALDERON AB TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY NINE LOW AB TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY NINE TANG. AB
TWENTY NINE TO FIFTY NINE IT
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE BILL AB
TWENTY NINE SIXTY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE BILL AND AB TWENTY
NINE SIXTY ONE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE BUILD THOSE BILLS ARE
ALL OUT. RIGHT LET'S GO BACK TO
THE TOP OF THE AGENDA WE HAVE AB. TWENTY TWO SEVENTY FIVE WOULD
I'LL TAKE A MOTION. THANK YOU
MOTION AND A SECOND THAT MOTION
IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
PATTERSON HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES. REYES AYE
RIVAS. RIVAS HIGHLY THE I. WICKS
WEBSITE. THE BILL IS OUT ITEM
NUMBER TWO IS AB FIFTEEN NINETY
FOUR TAKING A TAKE A MOTION.
THANK YOU MOTION AND A SECOND
THAT IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE HI STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM NO
PATTERSON HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY KILEY NO MAINTAIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES. REYES I
RIVAS RIVAS IDLY THE I. WICKS
WEBSITE THAT BILL AS ADULTS I
REMEMBER THREE IS AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT SMITH OF THE
COMMOTION. THANK YOU THAT MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
PATTERSON HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES. YES I
RIVAS RIVAS HIGHLY THE I. WICKS
EXACT. THE BILL IS OUT ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY
RODRIGUEZ OF THE COMMOTION.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA PLEASE
STONE AYE STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. PATTERSON HOLDEN
KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES REYES HI RIVAS RIVAS
HIGHLY THE I. WICKS WICKES I.
THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB SIXTEEN NINETY
THREE OF US I'LL TAKE A MOTION.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NO
PATTERSON HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY. KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES HI RES I
RIVAS RIVAS IDLY THE I. WICKES
WICKES ACT THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM
NUMBER SIX IS AB TWENTY TO
TWENTY MINUTES SU CHI OF THE
COMMOTION. THAT'S A MOTION AND A
SECOND THAT MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO HEALTH CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
STONE AYE STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
PATTERSON HOLDEN KALRA KALRA AYE
KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE REYES REYES AYE RIVAS
RIVERSIDE LI LI I. WICKES WICKES
I. THE BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN A. B. EIGHTEEN FORTY FOUR
MEDINA I'LL TAKE A MOTION. THANK
YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE STONE
AYE CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
PATTERSON HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES REYES I
RIVAS RIVAS IDLY THE I. WICKS WE
EXPECT. THANK YOU THAT BILL IS
OUT ITEM NUMBER EIGHT IS AB
TWENTY FIFTY LEGALTECH A MOTION
. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO
PASS. OF I THINK WE NEED A
DIFFERENT SECOND PLEASE SO WE DO
HAVE A DIFFERENT SECONDS THANK
YOU. ABOUT THE AUTHOR ALL RIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE HI STONE I
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NO
PATTERSON HOLDEN KALRA KALRA AYE
KILEY KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN.
REYES YES I RIVAS RIVAS IDLY.
LEE HI WICKES WICKES I THAT BILL
IS OUTS ITEM NUMBER NINE AB
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY GABRIEL WE DO
HAVE A MOTION THANK YOU AND THE
SECOND THAT MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE STONE
AYE CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I.
PATTERSON HOLDEN KALRA KALRA AYE
KILEY. KILEY NO MAINTAIN
MAINTAIN AYE REYES YES I RIVAS%
RIVAS I LI LI I WICKS. WICKS I.
CONTENT OKAY ITEM NUMBER TEN IS
ON CALL LIVING IN THE WOODS YES
GIVE. GET REAL IS THIS I'M SORRY
AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY GABRIEL IS
OUT. YOU NEED FOR THE FORMALLY
YES SO ITEM NUMBER TEN IS ON
CALL THIS IS AB TWENTY FIVE
TWELVE PLUMAS GONNA LIFT THE
CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
PLEASE PATTERSON HOLDEN KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN IDLY LEAI. YEAH-
PLEASE CAN YOU GOING ON ABOUT
CUTTING NOT VOTING FOR NOW. OKAY
THANK YU THAT BILL IS OUT NEXT
IS ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY
SEVEN TEN KALRA. THANK YOU
THERE'S A MOTION AS THEIR SECOND
AND A SECONDS THAT MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO HOUSING COMMITTEE.
OTHER- PLEASE STONE HI STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM NO
PATTERSON HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN
REYES REYES I RIVAS RIVAS I'D LI
LI I WICKES WICKES I. THAT BILLS
OUT THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY SIX
MAIENSCHEIN. THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A MOTION ANDA SECOND THAT
MOTION IS DUE PASS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
PATTERSON HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES YES I
RIVAS RIVAS I'D LI LI I WICKS
WEBSITE THAT BILLS OUT ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND THAT
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
PATTERSON HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY KIND OF SORRY TWENTY
TO TWENTY YES TWENTY. KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN II REYES
. REYES REYES I RIVAS RIVAS I'D
LI LEAI WICKS MAKES AYE RIGHT
THE BILL IS OUT I REMEMBER
FOURTEEN IS AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTEEN I THINK EVERYBODY HERE
HAS VOTED ON IT. AT OKAY. SO
THANK YOU ALL WE STILL HAVE TO
MEMBERS WHO HAVE NOT BEEN HERE
MR HOLDEN AND MISTER PATTERSON
IF THEY WANT TO SHOW UP ALL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN A LITTLE BIT
LONGER TO ACCOMMODATE THEM
EVERYONE ELSE. THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. SO I'M GONNA HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN A LITTLE BIT
LONGER.
ALL RIGHTS THE- THAT CONCLUDES
OUR BUSINESS FOR TODAY AND WE
ARE A JUROR.